this is Joo podcast number 416 with Eko
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Ekko good
evening the president of the United
States takes pleasure in presenting the
bronze star medal 2 Naval special
Warfare operator second class SE AirLand
Robert a Holland for service as set
forth in the following Citation for
Heroic achievement a connection with
combat operations against the enemy as
Naval special Warfare task unit Bruiser
combat advis and machine gunner in
direct support of operation Iraqi
freedom on 17 June 2006 petty officer
Holland displayed exceptional courage
Under Fire as automatic weapons Gunner
during a daytime presence Patrol while
patrolling a narrow Street in a
dangerous Insurgent controlled
Neighborhood his element came under
heavy enemy fire with complete disregard
for his own safety he maintained his
position exposed in the street and
engaged the enemy with his Mark
48762 machine gun suppressing enemy fire
and allowing his element to take safe
cover in a courtyard of a nearby
residence after departing the residence
the element began to Fire and maneuver
back toward the vicinity of a US Army
Combat Outpost as they executed the
maneuver he was wounded by shrapnel in
the leg but continued to provide cover
for his
teammates by his extraordinary guidance
zealous initiative and total dedication
to duty petty officer Holland reflected
great credit upon himself and upheld the
highest traditions of United States
Naval
service the combat distinguishing device
is
authorized for the president JD kernin
rear Admiral United States Navy
Commander Naval special Warfare
command and that right there is the
citation from one of the awards for
Robert Holland or Bobby
Holland in one of the situations when he
stepped up and led and he did this over
and over again on that deployment and
throughout his
career and you've probably heard me talk
about how the squad leader makes a
difference that's the Marine Corps
professional way of saying it in in the
teams you've heard me talk about the E5
Mafia These are the guys that run the
platoon these are the guys that navigate
to the targets they set the breaching
charges they prepare the radios the
vehicles the creu surfed
weapons they shoot machine guns that
provide cover fire so the platoon can
maneuver well Bobby Holland was one of
those one of those
e5s part of the E5 Mafia and in the book
dichotomy of
leadership which was written while Bobby
was still on active duty in that book
Leif refers to Bobby as one of his most
Trust Ed seal enlisted leaders cuz Bobby
was in Charlie platoon task unit Bruiser
where he was known as lead
Bob and he was called lead Bob because
in the SEAL Teams whoever leads some
aspect of a mission or some part of the
platoon is known as the lead so it's
lead sniper lead breacher lead climber
lead
Navigator well Bob seemed to kind of
lead everything so he just became lead
Bob based on his ability to step up and
make things happen and Lead Bob
eventually moved out of the E5 Mafia
into the headshed the dreaded headshed
as a leading Patty officer of a platoon
as the chief of a platoon eventually
became a warn officer in the SEAL Teams
and he spent 21 years there deployed all
over the world including both Iraq and
Afghanistan and it's an honor to have
him with us here tonight to share his
experiences and Lessons Learned lead Bob
Bobby thanks for joining us bro Joo Echo
thanks for having me man um humbled to
be here yeah let's do it yeah let's go
uh lead Bob there's more nicknames we'll
uncover there's more there's more things
out there I don't know how many I want
to
unveil there are a couple yeah there's a
few uh all right let's start at the
beginning let's jump into this born in
your California Kid born and raised
California yep uh raised in Fresno I
actually uh spent my first seven years
in a place called Selma it's like 20
miles south of Fresno it's where my
parents grew up um yeah went to Fresno
when I was around 8 years old and lived
there until you know joined the Navy
basically and and so your mom she was
Portuguese right we are Portuguese
because that was one of the nicknames I
remember was Portuguese Pig yes the
Portuguese Pig yeah see we're already
getting into it man just saying we're
out of the gate yeah yeah all right so
big pig was one of my many nicknames
let's get it out and and the Portuguese
Pig yes so and and your mom was what
second gener generation American uh or
her grandparents yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah so my uh my
great-grandparents immigrated from
Portugal um my I don't know all the
details but what was passed down to me
was my great grandpa actually this is in
World War I um trying to flee all the
that was going on there um swam out
like a mile to to catch a boat so he
wasn't with my great grandma at that
point yet but he was fleeing to America
and uh Frogman Style frog man style yeah
yeah and then what what was up with your
dad what' your dad do or did your mom
work uh yeah so my mom was essentially
raised on a farm in Selma so uh
interestingly enough I was back in town
uh last week and we went back down to
Selma um cruise around and you know she
took me by the old farm and all that um
but she's raised on a farm you know kind
of hard living there um she ended up
somehow finding herself into the
financial services industry and later
became an entrepreneur um kind of like a
Rags of riches story there I I don't say
riches I mean we're middle class but it
felt like riches when you're coming from
a farm you know so um yeah just real
kind of gritty upbringing for her um my
dad spent most of his childhood in Selma
he was actually born in Odessa Texas and
uh his mom kind of you know took him and
his older brother from their dad left
Texas at a very early age fled to Selma
and uh my dad I mean for lack of a ter
basically raised himself from you know
12 on had a really rough childhood y do
and this is all in Selma all all in
Selma yeah Selma's kind of like a uh
best described it's probably like an a
town kind of a smaller Town Fresno is a
lot bigger um yeah and then did did you
did your say your dad had a brother that
that
died yeah no my my dad uh my my dad has
a story man um unfortunately he's not
around to tell that story uh you know we
lost him back in 2012 but uh yeah his
brother so his brother I mean kind of
raised him he was three years older than
him um got into the wrong crowd and uh
you know at the age of 21 was murdered
um so it heavily affected my dad you
know his entire life my dad struggled
but that and you know the you know being
pulled away from his dad and and his mom
kind of abandoning him
um and rumor has it I I mean I don't
know but that guy
who uh murdered my uncle and my uncle
was my name sake I was named after after
him um he was handled with some country
Justice when he got out out at prison uh
as rumor has it damn yeah well right on
uh and then what was your dad doing for
work so my dad uh found himself he spent
a
career at a guess a commercial water
filtration uh you know Corporation I
guess so he was a purchasing manager and
just kind of did that I mean as long as
uh you know my entire life that's kind
of what he did was he ever in the
military he was a reservist uh post post
Vietnam couple years uh I think he was
stationed at Point Wii or something for
a year Al so he's Navy Navy yeah yeah
yeah he was a CB oh right now
electrician and also a pig
Gunner yeah so he he introduced me to
the uh the
M60 which down the road I would actually
get to wield which was really kind of
need to go a full circle but yeah I grew
up uh you know my my dad was an active
duty he didn't didn't like get into it
um but held the Navy with such high
regard and the military and uh you know
was always talking about carrying the
pig and uh I never man
I I remember this um all the way
back in ratti in gunfights but my dad
used to tell me um the survival right
sorry the survival rate in Vietnam for a
pig hunter was like I don't know 30
seconds or something that was kind of
like the the rumor so um you know that
conversation talk with me and when we
were getting gunfights it was uh yeah
check you try and shrink your head down
a little bit yeah yeah try and keep that
low profile so what are you into when
you're growing up like in your childhood
uh I was really into sports yeah that
was kind of my my outlet I was a
rambunctious kid I guess you could say
my my mom um we call those delinquents
yeah yeah I mean I never spent any time
in the facility per se but uh yeah I
mean I I was just full of energy and uh
rambunctious and
stubborn and and a handful man but
Sports was my outlet so you know really
into sports played all sports grown up
uh you know started with soccer and
t-ball and uh then I got into football
and wrestling and those were like really
really my sports and I grew up playing
streetball street football I don't know
if anyone knows that that's the thing
but Echo yes sir do we play street ball
in Hawaii did yes what you play with uh
just neighbor kids yeah but what Like a
Rock oh no no a football man yeah hey I
don't know there's different levels to
stre Charles was playing that with a
coconut boy we have played with coconuts
before yes yes so street ball in the
street yeah I probably like every day of
my life from like age eight until you
know I was playing real football on the
field uh my brother and I I have a
younger brother three years younger uh
PL re ball man yeah it's great cutting
her teeth there and uh yeah I mean yeah
I was
uh into movies uh you know into sports
and then what's up with your parents are
your parents like I mean it sounds like
your mom's coming from a little bit of a
rough background your mom your dad's
coming a little bit of a rough
background how are they getting along
how was how was all that like the home
life yeah man it you know it was it was
good that the parents uh did a good job
of not both my parents did a good job of
not passing down their you know um
and that's that's a real gift that's a
generational gift and I was having this
conversation with my mom um the other
day you know I I've been doing a lot of
reflection the last week knowing I I was
going to come on here um haven't really
thought about a lot of this stuff in a
long time and uh you know I thank her
for that because you know she kind of
broke the kind of cycle of there
and that's been passed on to my kids and
uh so yeah you know I I had a great
bringing man I mean you know our parents
worked very hard to get a roof over our
head we had everything that we needed um
you know they didn't come from much uh
but you know man I wouldn't change my
childhood for anything I it was a blast
my my parents always supported me doing
everything and you know and and they
they let me be me and I think that was
the uh best thing that they could have
done was not not resist um you know they
they tried when I was younger and it it
didn't work and uh I think I turned out
you know to the best version I could
have
been what what um like guard rails did
you push up against with your parents
like what were you getting into that was
where they were like all right we just
got to let this go oh
man were you were you like getting good
grades yeah yeah I I was yeah I I was a
decent kid man I I was a pretty good kid
you know I got got decent grades um I
wasn't very focused in the classroom I
just didn't want to be in the classroom
but I got it done um you know my parents
did expect me to do well in school so I
did well enough to keep them off my back
and you know as I got older uh I just
got in a lot of fights
man you know and uh I
was yeah were you just mouthy or were
you a nice Target were you just hostile
I don't know I you know I think I need
some of my uh you know childhood uh
opponents to kind of remind me a little
bit I I I like to think that it wasn't
me that started it you know my parents
raised me to never start a fight but
always to finish it like it was always
very clear that if you get in a fight
you better finish it and it was like you
know not like you know if you want it
was like you're G to finish it we we
expect you to do that so um I I got
picked on for a little bit I was uh I I
got a little bit chunky you know or or
or Hefty Hefty um you know but it it was
like solid like fighter weight you know
like N 9 10 years old you know it wasn't
like sloppy it was like kind of thick
that happens to boys when they're
getting ready to grow like that age of
maybe 9 10 11 they get a little bit
thick we'll say yeah and then when they
grow usually they lean out a little bit
Yeah so um so you got picked on because
of that yeah don't don't quote me out
but I think from like second grade to
like sixth grade has 120 lbs and I just
that's pretty that's pretty beefy little
kid I just grew taller and then I grew
kind of thinner right um yeah so I got
picked on a little bit uh and and I just
handled people man you know I was uh
straight up bro completely untrained
like no skill whatsoever but I was I was
fueled by the movies of the 1980s man
you know I mean all those action movies
and uh you related I I related and yeah
I you know I think my record I think I'm
undefeated man in childhood fights
streets I fought uh I fought all my
neighbors except except for one there
there was one kid I I won't let him know
who he is that uh I didn't want to fight
he he was a tough guy he was older too
but uh yeah and and in school uh gotten
a lot of fights there and uh I mean just
damn near trouble yeah my mom was on a
you know first name bases with the
principal um I don't think I was
suspended but I was threatened to be
suspended I was threatened to be
expelled several different times and uh
yeah so just just like a lot of fighting
and uh man I got so many fight I I was
even getting cocky and and like trying
new moves and that I had no
business doing um what year is this oh
this is like Circa you know8 88 to kind
of 90 so like this is still pre-ufc no
one knows oh yeah no no no no all right
so you're still thinking Roadhouse moves
are going to work yeah oh yeah yeah I I
got a story for you all right speaking
of uh radas here so I'm uh I want to say
I'm 11 years old and uh on the playing
ground and playing basketball the
basketball goes out of bounds and this
kid you know like picks up the ball and
I was like hey man you give us the ball
back and he's like yeah not having it
threw it away I was like oh it's game on
right like fight is happening so we we
end up going after it and uh you know
throw a couple blows I'm like I'm like
11 years old man just little chunky butt
throwing throwing blows and like I said
I was like so cocky at this point been
so many fights I'm like it's go time I'm
doing it and I decided to try for the
first time in my entire life a
roundhouse kick oh yeah D bro it's real
right off not not only did it not land
but I fell on my ass and uh yeah not not
a great look
so is this when did you meet Tyler uh I
met Tyler
in eighth grade for sure may maybe
seventh grade but we got really close in
high school and the reason I bring up
Tyler is cuz well we actually all know
him cuz he ended up in the sealed team
as well not sure we'll get to that but
that was seventh eth grade you met him
started running with him yep yep and you
get in high school or did you keep
wrestling uh I stopped wrestling in in
eighth grade um man I I really credit I
I only wrestled for like four or five
years but um BR that wins every fight if
you're 11 12 years old and you wrestled
for four years you're winning every
fight just on that I mean and a nice
roundhouse kick
apparently yeah you know back then they
didn't have mix Mar sorry mix martial
arts they didn't have Jiu-Jitsu well it
wasn't as prominent I guess so no they
didn't have it in America it was kind of
like karate Taekwondo I mean those were
kind of like what what kids would do um
but I wrestled and I think you know
strongly encouraged you know especially
young boys to you know do one of those
things do martial arts wrestle because I
mean I I just learned things at that
young age that I carried on with me the
rest of my life and the uh the
discipline to wrestle um I mean the
hardest practices of probably all the
sports I'd imagine um yeah you know
cutting weight the discipline and then
just standing in the ring you know
staring that at their Dude down you know
the heart's racing and and like you're
going after it you know but uh so I I
was a good wrestler you know pretty
accomplished um up until 8th grade I
made it up to I'm not sure if it was a
state meat or Regional meat but uh
pretty big meat up in Sacramento in eth
grade and you know I got pretty close to
like finishing I got towards the end
then uh I met my match uh the Jun Junior
Olympic dude oh yeah who I mean looks
straight up like
Rocky and I I lack skill to be honest
with you I I was just kind of like
aggression and uh and I met my match and
I think he got me I think it's called
the surfboard move and he just maxed me
out on points and I was like you know
what man I feel like my wrestling crew
is over so uh went into to high school
and my high school had a really great
football program a year round program
damn and uh that was basically you know
I had to drop wrestling and I was all in
on football after that all in on
football and what what did you make like
are you playing freshman team varsity
team JV team like how'd that go what'
your career look like yeah yeah my high
school career uh I started out I played
played freshman ball um had a pretty
good
season and then after the Freshman
season ended uh our varsity team was in
the the playoff run so they had I think
they won the championship the year prior
like really really great team uh I don't
know what we were ranked in the state
that year um but my senior year I think
we ranked like fifth so like super solid
program uh the head coach came in I I
don't know what level he coached in
college but he came down and just ran
kind of like a college level program at
least that was the perception of it um
so they pulled me up to Varsity the end
of my freshman year uh by this point I I
played Iron Man ball uh which means
offense and defense um on the Freshman
side but they pulled me up and then I
just played defensive line from that
point on what did you weigh like in high
school uh I think I was 190 190s is that
by the time you got to your senior
year H yeah man I I don't remember like
what I came in at um freshman year but
yeah I I was like 190s uh senior were
you jacked were you lifting were you
squatting or was it just kind of like
normal yeah I growth I mean I wouldn't
say I was like jacked like uh you know
like Muscle Man jacked but I I was I was
super strong I one of the things that
you know I didn't mention we kind of
passed over but when uh you know I was a
chunky butt from like I don't know 9 to
11 or whatever I started to lean out but
one of the things I did I made a a pack
with myself um fifth grade some are
going into sixth grade I'm like I'm done
being a chunky bud so I just stopped
eating and uh and I started my my
dad had some weights so I started like
lifting weights and I was a strong kid
so yeah I was strong and uh I was fast
you know and I I say that like with a
huge grain of salt like compared to fast
people not fast but I I was you know
decently fast aggressive uh and I felt
like I was born to play football MH so
how far did you make it like your senior
year in football yeah so man I was all
in like uh uh you know I had aspirations
of planned after high school but I think
my social life and uh distraction kind
of gotone the way in high school and I
just stopped developing myself further
so you know I'm still like ranked pretty
high what grade was
that well I I would say probably junior
year and Senior year I just kind of
slacked off did you get a car or
something yeah you get a girlfriend yep
yep um I actually
met my future wife in high school so uh
dated sophomore year are we allowed to
say her name yeah yeah Beth yeah yeah so
you met Beth I met Beth s year know it's
crazy yeah um and big distraction right
there Beth big distraction just
distracting you all over the place let's
let's blame her for the reason why I'm
not you know I didn't play in the NFL um
not the fact that I was you know 511 and
not even 200 lb playing defensive line
nonetheless
Jack um yeah I was a very social kid and
you know man I just was distracted and
uh probably doing things I shouldn't
have been doing and not you know I I
didn't want to get big I was happy being
kind of strong and lean and I probably
had to gain another 30 pounds you know
which I would do later in life um but
yeah so we we made it uh yeah I I got
injured really bad high ankle high ankle
sprain my senior year it didn't take me
out of the game but uh you know I I was
just like less less in full force that
you know H first half of the Season
there stats weren't that great and uh
you know there were no no scholarships
at the end of that no no colleges
ringing grade grades were decent um but
it kind of squandered that and my my
final game man I I remember it like very
very closely because we were making
another run at the championship uh had a
good football season into the
playoffs or or it was the game deciding
if we go into the playoffs that that
part's a little bit fuzzy but um we were
down it was 2821 we're playing our our
rival so uh I went to Clovis West High
School and our rival was Clovis High
School um they were ahead Clovis was
ahead
2821 and uh you know I I think it's
poetic the way my career ended if you
want to call it a career at my high
school sports we're calling it a career
yeah all right all right um so it was a
play action uh you know run on the uh
offensive side and I was a nose guard I
broke right through the line and I just
saw the quarterback and I hit him he
fumbled the ball and I'm looking at man
I I can paint this picture for you right
now we're probably I'm probably like uh
40 yards away from the end zone and the
ball is there and there's no one I see
no one I pick up the ball and you know I
just I I start booking it and I made it
like probably three yards and I got
tackled from behind um that was my last
play football we drove it all the way
our offense drove all the way to the one
yard
line and they they couldn't couldn't get
it done man um so that was it end of the
career I was the uh you know we we went
into the locker rooms change and I went
back down the field and just kind of
like soaked it in man that that was
football was such an important part of
my life up that point and uh I mean
honestly man when I went through buds I
was looking back at football practices
and like I mean this ain't that bad
check yeah especially summer and Fresno
like oh yeah yeah miserable 110 degrees
and this is back when you know uh
hydrating was like a a
luxury you know yeah that's that this is
pre the big hydration you got to stay
hydrated yeah yeah yeah yeah we had back
like they started saying hydrate or die
back then it was just die just like just
die like you don't need water what
what's wrong with you you're freaking
wimp if you need water we had ambulances
come out this this was not uncommon and
you know everyone would just look at
that guy just like weak this guy heat
Caz you were into music too you play
guitar yeah I did so was that all about
my parents divorced when uh when I was
around 12 and my mom started dating a
guy uh ended up marrying him for a
couple years as well he played guitar so
he introduced me to guitar and uh I I
picked up I loved it um so I start
started jamming out I think uh man
paradise city was the first song I
learned oh dang yeah straight in yeah
and uh you know I never learned how to
read music um just tab yeah and just
kind of like selftaught I say selftaught
with the grand salt uh you know that
that gentleman taught me a lot Tau
taught me all the chords and then I
would just you know that that was kind
of my thing so whenever I was out of
football I would go to my room and I
would jam and I would play songs and I
would uh write my own songs and do that
and then uh you know eventually got into
hardcore music and hell yeah
yeah ekko's favorite no that's my
favorite but you know Ekko throws out
the hell yeah at certain moments in
podcast usually it's on some real dumb
be honest he'll go hell yeah like
someone will say like he actually
already said one today when I said roadh
house did you hear that he goes hell
yeah because you know that's some
meaningful the echo Charles bro
he's like you know that's a bouncer
right there that's his that's his uh
forefathers right there pat pat swy man
got after it so you listening to
hardcore you going to shows and
everything I did yeah uh I went to my
first show in 8th grade uh bad religion
was my first show nice yeah yeah good
good uh good good Punk CL band back then
um got knocked down in the mosh pit my
first experience with that walked away
had a bloody ear You're Fired Up fired
up like this is
look yeah yeah and and got more into it
in in high school uh actually I mean
backing up a little bit The Headbangers
ball I was really into that in the uh
late 8 late 80s early 90s y um with
Ricky ratman Ricky rapman remember that
yeah The Headbangers ball with Ricky
rapman yeah they' play songs that
weren't appropriate for the daytime MTV
remember when MTV had music on it that
was an interesting thing so as you're
doing all this do you have a plan
for your
future no yeah is that is that a shocker
I I mean football was my plan but then I
just kind of let that die um no plan at
all and that became clear uh senior year
I mean when football was over it was
like
so people like applying to colleges
and this kind of stuff man I what are
you doing like
uh just everything wrong you know so
like even backing up uh during the
football season it was so awful but uh I
took the SATs on a Saturday after a
Friday night football game up super late
uh I had to drive it's like 45 minutes
south of Fresno at 6:00 in the morning I
was doing touch and goes I mean I
surprised I haven't made it there in one
piece I was smoked I did awful you know
I I didn't have any big prospects wasn't
super into school um but my parents told
me as soon I as I was done with football
it's like go get a job so it's like
check all right I'm GNA get a job and
then just figure it out so I what was
your job uh I ended up getting a job at
the silver dollar Hof brow sure what a
restaurant it's a a Hof brow is like a
restaurant bar it's kind of like a bar
with a cafeteria set up it's weird um so
I I got a job working in the back so I I
was like in the kitchen cleaning stuff
up uh bus boy you know wash dishes
graduated kind of like was a bus boy in
a bar back and then um did some ad hoc
bouncing as well
yeah um but yeah so so it's you know I
no I I didn't have a plan um I decided
to go into junior college or Community
College um because that's what you do
when you kind of don't have a plan um so
figured I would do that and kind of
figure stuff out and you know that uh my
senior year I was just kind of doing a
lot of exploration like you know young
men do at that stage and like man what
what do I do were you thinking military
did you start to consider military you
know I I started having some ideas I
mean if you're watching freaking
predator and freaking Rambo and all this
stuff you must be yeah I I did I I was
raised on those movies I was raised on
you I have uh this Rambo knife here you
know first Blood Commando Predator so I
felt like I wanted to do some sort of
you
know you know action career if you will
but I had no idea kind of what that was
um so yeah went to Community College I
actually uh one interesting thing that
happened to me in my senior year uh was
I I found a martial art called
iido so uh I was actually at a party um
senior year this is after the football
season and at this guy's house and he
had like a full long Dojo setup in his
in his house now we look back and know
that this dude was a
nerd for sure at the time we're like yo
he's been trained by the Ancients or
something oh he had he had straw mat out
like it it was it was legit so um I'm
I'm like hey you know what what's this
and uh he showed me some moves and I was
like oh okay that's kind of cool and you
know he's like oh by the way this is uh
you know you heard of Steven
Seagal I was like oh please tell me
more you know that that's what uh Seagal
did and I was like I was intrigued so uh
I ended up going to a class that next
week and and got really into that so
that became my outlet did you buy those
weird pants and everything no no no I I
have a great picture I'll show you after
this uh I I got to do uh some like black
belt testing at
Seagal's residence damn and uh I have a
picture of him wearing the funny pants
and elf shoes yeah wait the pants are
for the like the M the teachers and
stuff right it's not for the regular
students oh oh yeah I'm sorry you're
talking about the Haka I'm just talking
about like the aido pants like that
whole outfit that they wear no I I never
I never made black belt I got up to uh
do you need to have a black belt to get
the pants or whatever you're you're
supposed to yeah before that like a
regular ghee just ghee okay yeah I know
this cuz I did iido back in the day oh
damn look it all comes out I I the only
thing I know about iido is I bought my
first ghee ever from an aido School in
Ocean Beach and it was it was cheap it
was
$40 it was it was called unbleached so
there was like a white one right Y and
it felt a little bit sof softer but that
was like $48 and the one that I got was
$40 okay and it was unbleached so it was
real rough and it was like a yellowish
kind of gnarly looking color and it
lasted like 3 weeks cuz they didn't know
what we were about to do with these
things cuz we were
turning and just killing each other yeah
so the thing didn't last long at all and
then I had to go back I had to go get
like a real Jiu-Jitsu G but that's only
so the only the high Lev people wear
that weird outfit in iido yeah so it
depends on you know if you're going to
like a non-traditional um place they
they may do that which gets really
confusing because like we used to travel
and do seminars and training events and
so sometimes Bobby in the freaking
training program so so sometimes you you
would go to these seminars and and you
know you're training with folks and you
pair up with people and you're training
with dud you're like man seems like
you're not a black belt yeah and you're
also like it seems like I could kick
your ass yeah yep um yeah but it in iido
it's young chunky bobb's going to come
out whoop some ass wrestling you're
you're basically a white belt all the
way until you wear a Haka so there's no
you you don't know kind of who you're
dealing with um until you get the Haka
and then you know that's just first
degree of black belt and then you go on
from there so how many how often are you
training a lot like every day type thing
uh not every day multiple times a week I
mean it it became it became my new
football and this is your senior year of
high school senior year and then it
carries into when you go to uh community
College you keep training yep yep I I
trained trained really hard uh and you
know started traveling it it just really
kind of consumed my life so uh aido yeah
basically I went to school um you know
worked out and did iido and uh and then
later when I got motivated to you know
go the route of prepping to go to the
teams I mean that's just kind of all I
did so what so how didd you find out
about the teams just straight the movie
Navy
Seals it it played a huge part so and
he's just straight up like that's like a
game changer for him freaking Navy Seals
movie that someone else was on here was
like Navy Seals and uh Dave Burke Top
Gun like 100% yeah get 100% he's like oh
yeah Top Gun came out he's like okay
that's what I'm gonna do so was that
where you first heard of the
DS I don't know where I first heard of
it but I do recall I had a teacher in
8th grade who uh the rumor was he was a
seal turned out not to be the case and I
I've learned many years later that he
went to buds he didn't graduate buds but
I I remember I think that was the first
time I I heard of it and you know kind
of pequ my interest um you know and then
then I I I start iido and Steven Seagal
and you know Under Siege oh that's right
he was a Navy SEAL cook Navy SEAL cook
I'm like man I don't want to be a cook
but I kind of like you know I so I
started looking into it more
and then I watched Navy Seals the movie
and there's no turning back I the
best best movie hands down this good I I
I've watched that dozens and dozens of
times and if it's on you know if I'm
scrolling through the uh the channels
it's on I have to finish you're watching
it I'm watching it pay homage
yep go to a recruiter like and and Tyler
you you guys did you guys just sit down
and watch it together and freaking just
geek out and go like let's go join the
Navy so it wasn't like a linear path to
go to the team you two weren't like on
it together we got there but we weren't
there immediately so probably spent um
six months outside of high school um
just kind of mess around no real designs
to go into the military um then I
started looking into the seal
thing and talking with Tyler and Tyler
was actually uh looking to become a
Marine so we went to a uh like Armed
Forces Mall you know like like you go
like just like on a street corner it
wasn't in an actual mall but it was like
you know Army Navy Air Force yep and we
went there um just trying to talk to a
couple dudes to kind of f it out and I
wanted to talk to the Navy guy um
shocker that like Navy guy was out for
lunch Jack but you know who who wasn't
out for lunch was gunny yeah gunny came
out you know saw two two FIT dudes
standing outside and I was like hey boys
come inside and he had us up on the
pull-up bar immediately
cranking him out he's firing us up and
you know introdu us to force Recon and
you know put on a video and I walked out
of there 100% thinking I'm going to be a
I was going to say I don't know how you
didn't sign the dotted line that day I
did I I actually I so much so I went
home I told my mom yeah I was living
with my mom at that point I'm like Mom
I'm going to be a marine and she just
completely broke down and and and really
because I hadn't talked much about the
military up to that point so it was like
completely out of the BL BL and she's
like please don't you know just think
about it give it some time um and yeah
so anyways I I did take some time I was
like all right yeah I woke up the next
morning and the uh gunny's you know
spell had kind of worn
off and from that point on I I was like
man I'm I'm all in uh and then probably
6 months after that all in for the teams
for the teams yeah but you still hadn't
talked to a recruiter yet no no okay I I
ended up going back probably like 6
months later something like that um by
that point Tyler had kind of gone on
board so we decided to uh to to do that
later yeah and and basically it was all
in you know on the Frogman path from
from that point and then uh spent the
last at least the last year and a half
maybe even longer of just training and
Tyler and I trained uh like Mad Men you
you know I mean for better part of two
years and trying to get ready trying to
get ready was that like that all that
time was it because you were thinking oh
this is going to be so hard like I'm not
ready yet I need to get ready was it one
of those things yeah yeah it it was and
there wasn't a whole lot of information
back then as you know I mean there were
books from
Vietnam um the internet was just you
know coming online but like people
weren't really using it that much um so
yeah I I was trying to vinced myself
that I could do it and I was trying to
prepare myself and uh I did come across
Tyler and I came across a couple of
books um that had like man I think it
was a steu Smith book it was like a
workout book and then there was another
book so you know we gobbled those up and
we created a a training plan I mean this
was like the first real exercise I'd had
in my entire life of setting a goal and
figuring out how to conquer that goal
like invaluable stuff but uh yeah I'd
never ran more than than the uh High
School sanction mile you know like I I
ran lots of uh you know yards and
football um but had never ran more than
a mile so started running a lot uh
worked our way up to 30 miles a week was
running uh two or sorry swimming 2 miles
in the pool which
is measurable it's awful like like a
like a 25 meter pool or something like
that exactly yeah started doing uh pool
skills stuff so like we knew enough
about buds to know what requirements
were so Tyler and I were drown proofing
ourselves we were uh breathholding I
mean doing looking back especially when
I got into training and and you learn
some stuff it's like man just really
dumb stuff so uh just for everyone
that's listening one up one down man
when you're working in the water you're
doing breathholds you're doing drown
proof and anything like that one guy on
the top the other guy can do breathholds
don't be competing against each other
cuz you you can you can definitely both
pass out and die and it's terrible so
one up one down is the rule for that
that stuff if you're listening and
you're a freaking
knuckleheaded young man between the ages
of 13 and 24 and your you and your buddy
decide you're going to go and you're
like we need to do breath holds just one
up one down that's the rule and so you
guys are running you guys are swimming
you guys are doing drown proofing and
you're getting ready what um you finally
go to the recruiter was it a hard
process uh no that that was easy um you
know basically I got my my ticket to
MEPS so went to MPS and uh that was up
in
Sacramento and uh you know MEPS is
essentially I don't know what it stands
for but it's kind of military processing
or medical type stuff military entry
processing station something like that
there you go yep yeah so did I mean it's
like an all day Affair up at early and
they're proding you and poking you doing
you know every test known to man uh and
then at the end of that you sign your
paper so I I did all that and I talked
to the to the recruiter and prior sorry
backing up I talked to the recruiter and
he' put me in for the seal contract I
think there was like a you know $2,500
bonus yeah oh man lot so so I had that
contract going up there to maps and you
know I do the whole uh slew of test
there and I get to the point at the very
end of that you go to an office and then
they go through your contract and I was
trying to get into the delayed entry
program so I I didn't want to go I was I
mean even at this point I I was in but I
was like hesitant to pull the trigger so
I was like cuz you thought you need more
preparation yeah yeah I did so I was
like you know I want like six seven more
months um so anyways I I'm at the desk
with the recruiter person whatever that
is I'm going through the contract and
I'm flipping through I'm like yep good
good solid nailed that um and then I get
you know to the back and there's a
signature I'm like man I'm not seeing
any seal in here
and you know that it was a lady uh just
told me like yeah you uh you failed an
IT test you don't qualify oh yeah and I
was like what are you talking about so
uh I mean I was devastated and I I
walked out of there I I didn't I
obviously didn't sign I'm like yeah I'm
out man and I was like brokenhearted I
spent the last you know 18 months so
what part of the eye test did you fail
so you know I spoke on this on another
podcast a couple months ago and I may
misspoke because my memory was Fuzzy I
had to consult my mom on this but she
just said I I failed the general iight
like the uh not sure if the requirements
were 2020 I don't know I have no idea
for sealed back then um but yeah just I
failed the eye test so I got kicked out
and you know went back to my mom and uh
devastated my you know my mom was kind
of hesitant for me joining the military
at all MH she was kind of
stoked she was but you know what she
actually helped me uh I I went and got a
couple doctor appointments on my own I
went to some optometrist and I was
determined to find a way in so I ended
up I went to two separate optometrist
until I got the one I liked and got what
I needed and man I guess that's all it
takes for the Navy I I went with a
permission slip and I I went back to
maps do you wear glasses now
no do you know what your vision is now
uh it's
I mean it's not 2020 like my left eye is
a little bit weak so I think probably
you know my my left eye was probably a
little bit lazy I know there's a depth
perception test yeah that I've known
kids that have failed and they you don't
you can't go and it's a weird thing it's
like one out of every hundred people or
something they can't see depth and
that's one of the few like you can get
just about any job in the Navy but you
can't be a seal and it's a bummer I was
talking to one of the master Chiefs
that's like sort of in the team still
and he's actually trying to push for
some of these things to change because
you have kids that they failed the depth
perception test but they like played
freaking baseball you know what I mean
where obviously you have depth
perception if you can play baseball and
there's just a weird thing I don't
really remember the test the depth it's
like dots you're looking at dots or
you're looking at a house or something
and and you have to see is this dot in
front of the house behind the house and
some people just can do it and some
people can't so I don't know maybe you
failed that thing I I don't know but I
went and I got whatever test they needed
and and and it got me in so I did Tyler
what what happened to him when you
failed was he like yeah you you
suck yeah he I mean he he carried on and
uh what was interesting was we we ended
up I mean I I got that resolved I don't
remember how long it took but I got that
resolved pretty quickly I mean I I
wasn't pouting too damn long on it I I
went and I'm not one to give up too
easily and yeah I mean that that was
like another there's all these moments
throughout your life these like little
you know micro decisions these character
building moments like I hadn't out you
know like people had known at that point
I was training to do this um I could
have taken that out um but that was the
case where I I kept pushing my mom
helped me out um and so I I got back on
the debt program and then Tyler and I
were were aligned on that and uh but we
ended up not coming in at the same time
he had kind of medical issue that
delayed him MH um but man that last
after I signed those papers train like a
pycho I trained like a psycho I was
still in school at the time and uh I had
to explain this so I ended up going to
school later and where my transcripts
were necessary and there was this like
this period where you know like good
grades you know first two years in
college a first year and a half and then
this
semester um where I just man I I was
just part partying and just you know
thinking like you're going to leave and
never come back yeah type of thing like
just just getting after it and uh so I I
was just training like a psycho just
partying just trying to get it all in uh
still doing you know heavy iido at this
point um Beth and I had broken up like
whenever I started going full Psycho
full psycho like towards the Navy and it
was like Navy Nothing Else Matters aido
working out you were like it's best for
you yeah you're like I'm not I might not
come home you just find another full
Legends of the Fall no man it this was
this was not me this was like she was
done she's like yeah you know I mean oh
she was over your dumbass yeah well
there was no time I mean I was just
working out
nonstop just a psycho man so um it's
weird too when you're going in the
military if you like if you don't know
people that were in the military you
just think you're that's it like I know
when I joined the Navy I was basically
like saying goodbye to my friends for
the last time I was like you know it's
been nice knowing you I'm out like I'll
never see you again that's how I felt
yeah and part of that was kind of good
but I didn't have any like if you grew
up let's say you grew up in San Diego
you'd see military people everywhere and
they' be like oh like you know you go in
a school and they' be like oh some dad
that's there that's in uniform picking
up his kids you like oh it's kind of a
norm there's a normal side to it if you
like I grew up in a little town in
Connecticut dude there's no military
people I thought well there's no
military people cuz when you join the
military you're gone that's it you're in
some other world so yeah you get that
attitude like it's over you know all
your all your old friends they're out
your girlfriend's gone doesn't matter
parents good luck thank you goodbye I'm
carrying
on I had a good buddy and I I'll call
him out here um Carrie he he was one of
my iido buddies but uh I I had a heart
to heart with him um getting ready to
leave man cuz I I was having like second
thoughts man you know I it's tough like
when you are you've never done anything
like that as a kid or young man you
haven't left your family um it seems
daunting and just like what you said man
it felt like I was never coming back
like I was never going to see my family
again um because I I was going to get
shipped to some farway land on on
clandestine missions you know that I
felt that way too but I was super
pumped I was super stoked I was like
just I'm out I'm out of Connecticut I'm
out I'll see y'all
later remember me in the Setting
Sun yeah just too many movies man you
know check so you had your heart to
heart with Carrie what did you say uh
you know man he just kind of he just
kind of fired me up he just kind of
pulled me out of it you know I mean it
was just that kind of weakness creeping
in I mean just like everything else when
whenever you're about to do something
really tough you're going to have those
those thoughts and you're going to have
that uh you know I mean it's it's that
human survival Instinct trying to trying
to pull you out of like the you
know um Jack yeah so you know uh
obviously went through with it my uh my
dad took me to the drop off um this was
right after Y2K oh yeah so we barely
made it out of that one we barely made
it out yeah um and then I was shipped
off man and off off to boot camp in uh
Chicago in January that was good times
man that ain't no Fresno no that is no
Fresno it was uh epic snowfall and
really I mean I'd been up in the snow we
got mountains near Fresno um but I'd
never seen snow like that yeah boot camp
shock regret dismay didn't care uh
rcpo H yeah we you the rcpo for like a
week okay you got but then they found
out I had no rhythm because one of the
rules or not not the rules but roles of
the rcpo uh the arpo right is uh you
seing Cadence and the
Navy they sing their Cadence I hope they
don't do this anymore but it's not like
the Marine Corps where you you have like
a an aggressive Cadence an aggressive
Cadence you're like sing yeah I wasn't
singing no Cadence no um so I got
demoted to mastered arms you're probably
a solid mastered arms yeah that was good
that was good doing the uh back then
they had the uh I don't even know what
they call it but the like seal did you
do the seal PT stuff in the morning at
boot camp no no it's good they they had
like a a small dead there and then
everyone who wanted to go steal program
you go and you work out there because I
mean basically if you're a really fit
dude you're just getting out of shape
yeah in boot camp so at least you're
getting a little bit there and then you
get double
rations at the Chow hole yep that's
legit um but yeah I boot camp boot camp
was easy um you know I I was I'm the
antithesis of you in terms of like
you're a morning person very clearly a
morning person and uh I grew you know to
be better in the morning but I was not a
morning person so you know one of the uh
Nifty Things that I did that I'll pass
on to any prospects out there you could
use my trick here was uh you know we had
to make our bed every morning right and
cut those creases and all that stuff and
uh one thing I would do is I I would
make my bed and I would just never sleep
in it I slept I think everyone did that
I did that too yeah I think everyone
well I I slept on top of the bed and
then I had this trick you know cuz they
have revly I think it's 4 or something
like that in the morning and I was just
so tired and I would post myself
underneath the bed and uh like I'm
fixing the bed you know so if the feet
are are hanging out I just hang my hand
like in the bed I just sleep for another
45 minutes every day um but yeah glad to
get out of boot camp um and then I went
off to uh Isa school well check in
Virginia then damn neck y right on yeah
and so now you must have seen some Team
guys around there no you know uh no I I
was on a different side of Base there um
I didn't have any real interactions um I
did at one point so you know in a school
I was teamed up with other guys who
wanted to go to Buds and we were
training together and getting back in
shape and uh one guy was a like super
nature tracker guy like I'm not sure
have you heard of uh Tom Brown yeah he
was like one of those one of those like
disciples oh like legit from Tom Brown
well or just into it really into it but
probably probably like legit but uh he
had us like he took me in the swamps in
Dam Neck they have legit swamps there
sure and uh swam with alligator gar you
know what those are no they're gnarly
they're like uh I mean it's if an
alligator and a fish I was going to say
isn't it like some kind of weird fish
alligator combo thing a prehistoric fish
looks like an alligator and they're I
mean get like six feet long and they
have teeth so you swam with these things
like yeah what like they were in the
same lake or swamp or you were
interacting with them like what's up I
was interacting with them this guy was
like uh you know what's the the Steve
Irwin dude Steve Irwin yeah yeah so of
the damn neck swamps he's like petting
the alligator guard oh damn right on and
uh he's like hey man yeah go ahead do it
I'm like did he go to buds this guy they
went to buds I everyone I went with buds
with uh didn't end up taking there at
least in my my class yeah that alligator
gar only goes so far
homie yeah there there were uh I think
there were like four or five of us great
guys um you know definitely would like
to get back in touch with some those
dudes so you show up to Buds and how's
that welcome
aboard uh yeah it was good I I went on
uh I took a month of leave from a school
so that was like a couple months there
and during my leave uh I went water
skiing and now I'm not a doctor but
knowing because I've had these injuries
since pretty sure I tore my
Meniscus and I showed up to buds you
know just like in a bad spot with my
knee um and it wasn't like you I was
mingering and not doing I just I
was in pain so um but I had a little
wild the class up had had a few months
there and kind of got through that or
you know it got you know to a
serviceable point um and ended up
classing up with class
233 and this is uh in you know
July well I guess we classed up in
October of 2000 October 2000 you class
up Chris in that class
233 uh he was for a little he graduated
with that class but he started I think
he started in uh 230 or 3-1 and he
rolled back so after hell week he rolled
into my class and then uh I ended up
Perforating my eard drum in second phase
uh doing the tower drops oh yeah ear
exploded underwater and then so I got
rolled out of that class into 2 three
four how was so first phase you kick off
first phase what's going on is it hard
for you you feeling like was your knee
healed enough anything kick you in the
ass uh you know man I felt like I felt
like I excelled in first phase like I I
was very well prepared for that
everything that I did that Tyler I did
it it paid off man I mean was Tyler with
you no no was he behind you or ahead of
you he was behind Okay yeah he was a
couple classes behind but uh I mean we
had done so much prep in that that uh
you know I I was very very prepared the
one thing you really can't prepare for
unless you do it is running in soft sand
um but yeah man I I was I I was a good
runner and yeah I say that again with a
lot of humility compared to like real
Runners but for a 200 pound man yeah I
was a good runner um swimming was kind
of like was not my thing so I i' done a
lot of swimming I but for whatever
reason you know in the ocean uh I was a
bad
guer and so you know a two nautical mile
ocean swim was probably like two and a
half miles and like that was just I
survived every single swim just barely
just seconds away from failure just
seconds away and it was like you know I
was I was giving everything that I had
every single swim um but past all the
other like uh you know all the the
underwater stuff uh we had all done that
man so like you know when you talk about
the role that training plays in in
preparation uh I felt like I had to leg
up I mean I had done the 50 meter
underwater on my own um in fact Tyler
and I both after a night of uh partying
if you will um both went to the pool
straight after that I I did I don't know
probably 60 underwater he did like he
did full 75 mhm um you know but yeah we
we had done all that stuff uh very
prepared first phase you know thought I
did pretty well there um in hell week I
was like in the Rockstar boat crew for a
bit M and then I found myself uh which
you might get a kick out of this but uh
because I mean I'm not like a short dude
like an average P guy but yeah what are
you 5'11 yeah yeah uh I found myself in
the Smurf crew how man I guess the uh
with 233 they were like a bunch of
giants okay and uh so you weren't like
the towering over the other SM cuz
normally like the Smurfs are like 55 5'6
maybe I was towering yeah okay so you're
like boat full on head yeah yeah so so
come Wednesday night you know we're
we're sitting there and I'm just like
you know we've won like every race up to
this point we're just like cruising man
and then they're doing like all right
get in a height line and they set us up
and they're counting I'm kind of looking
around and I'm like looking to my left
I'm like oh
yeah there's only six guys to the left
of me and sure enough uh I I got put in
the Smurf crew for the last last part of
Hell weekend that was absolutely brutal
so um now that I'm you know here with
your audience I'll just apologize for
presumably what all the weird noises I
was making you know just that boat was
crushing my
neck it's freaking gnarly I could hear
the if you take two rocks and you rub
them together I could hear my neck doing
that during a week and like lit
literally that noise I was like this is
probably not good um so yeah be
careful that uh so then you you make it
through hell week anything crazy
happened in hell
week
uh yeah I I mean I guess uh I have a
good little Story I mean this is just
like one of many of where I'm just doing
kind of stupid and other people are
paying the consequences but uh we were
doing a a drill to where you're like
uh I'm not sure if it's like a kind of
like escape and evasion I mean basically
you're trying to go undetected from the
instructor staff and you're like
crawling on the oor and for like a mile
or something like that and my my swim
buddy and I were like really into it I
mean we're just like we're not going to
get caught and you know they have a
bunch of wreckage and stuff out in the O
course and we found a little piece of
wreckage you know because they have
instructors coming with spotlights and
doing all that and so you know this
guy's you instructor coming and and
we're like all right you know dig in and
we dig into the sand in this like
wreckage and then I wake up like an hour
and a half later because we just passed
out because like if you in hell week if
you stop yeah yeah if you stop for any
amount of time like you're just toast
you're out so um they they you know at
this point they'd Gone full admin oh
lights are on they're beating the class
right and it's like you know they're
they're calling out our names and we
come too and it's like oh
sorry
guys shck but no get through H week all
right in one piece um and then went into
second
phase and uh did did uh was there anyone
that shocked you that they quit any of
these like D1 athletes and all that
exactly that yeah what' you see we had
our in two through three our OIC was a
uh I think he played I think he was a
quarterback for Notre Dame uh don't
don't remember that guy's name but he
was a big hulking dude I mean just like
Superman looking guy and uh yeah he he
went and then there were some guys you
know guys that went with uh isn't that
freaking crazy you're the freaking
quarterback at Notre Dame you're like
you know what I'm going to be a seal and
you tell all your friends and you tell
your mom and dad you tell your
girlfriend and you show up and you
freaking
quit yeah that's wild there were other
guys uh you know the ones that stand out
to me uh a couple loudmouths you know
these are the guys that are pleasing
everyone up you know cuz guys aren't
squared away and not doing the right
thing then in hell week you see you know
you got the uh the car lights you know
looking at you and you're in the surf
and then like you've just seen their
silhouette kind of going away it's like
damn yeah there's this whole thing I did
a few podcasts about the psychology of
military incompetence and it's this
whole thing about it's written by a guy
that was in World War II who's became a
psychologist but he like talks about how
people that are like super orderly and
and like highly
authoritarian kind of things that you're
talking like hey you need to square
yourself away they like things to be
followed and then you get into hell
league and it's just like total Mayhem
and their brains can't handle it and
they just quit that's it game
over yeah I I mean for me um yeah people
always ask when
whenever you know you're talking to a
seal for the first time it's like it's
going to happen within the first two
minutes is did you ever think about
quitting and I can honestly say no yeah
me neither I hear guys like everyone
thinks about quitting I'm like 100% I
not just me I know all kinds of guys
that didn't think about quitting I guess
maybe a lot of guys do but a lot of guys
don't look it if nothing else I mean
even aside from like you know I I want
to do this job and whatever I mean just
the uh you know not wanting to let
people down and like you said you're
going to do something not doing it like
all those reasons there's just no way
man yeah just not happening no so then
you go from the you you make it through
hell week now it's first second phase
diving and what you hurt your ear drump
is that what you said I did yeah so we
had done the uh we had that they since
decommissioned it I mean the teams have
moved uh all that stuff but um they had
a tower the 50- foot Tower and we used
to work in that that that thing was
daunting man so we did some work in that
in first phase and and no issues like
went down and tied some knots and then
in second phase um they're building up
your competence you know for all the
underwater stuff they were do doing in
second phase so they had a couple
different events and one of them I think
I think it was just called bottom drops
where you just go down to the bottom and
uh I had a
cold and I started to go down and I made
it like 20 feet and I'm trying to like
Val Salva you know to equalize the
pressure of my ears and it's not
happening I'm like well I have to keep
going down just keep going bro keep
going and then that underwater explosion
happened in my head and I got vertigo
and I was like all right I'm going back
up and went back up and then uh yeah
sure enough I perforated my eardrum
pulled me out of that cloth and uh man
that 23 three those guys were just a
bunch of rock stars and uh you know so
definitely was hard leaving those guys
but so so did you become friends with
Chris at this
point uh not really not so you guys just
knew each other but and it was short I
mean it was only uh I don't know how
many weeks after hell week but Chris
rolled in to 233 after hell week and
then um that Evolution was like the
second week of first of second phas yeah
yeah and just reason I bring that up
because I know you guys became uh you
know super close and everything and when
we were together you guys were
freaking you guys were all tight yeah
man he he was actually part of the
reason him and one other dude um who
were in that class so another guy rolled
in when Chris rolled in ended up being
in Charlie platoon and those two guys
are the reason why I found my way to
still team 3 Charlie sure so you get
rolled and now you're in 234 yeah and
this is the one with the freaking
documentary Yeah man so what was that
like it was wild it was uh you know such
a difference uh 233 I mean we were just
like we couldn't do anything right we
were just getting beat down uh and
234 had a lot of scrutiny on it because
there were cameras there so it was like
it was a different vibe you know because
cameras are rolling so it's like all
right guys we can't can't be doing that
on camera um but but the guys were were
amazing uh they were a really small
group so I don't remember how many guys
they had rolling out at hell week but
it's like 20 or something like that
really really small class and we ended
up graduating with
25 um but I mean a lot of great mugs
there uh you know dudes are still keep
in touch with great guys and uh but you
know it's tough anytime you're going
into a class like that that you know
small group that's really tight you know
took a little while to kind of how much
were the cameras there a lot no kidding
a lot yeah they they found me they seem
to find me like uh during every moment
of weakness I had it's all documented
it's all documented like none of the
hero now I'm going to go watch it
bro no no you're not it's oh no I am I'm
going send you screenshots
yeah the only like hero shot they they
have of me is in the intros I'm doing
like this perette and then a just
looking just just looking badass just
looking badass man but you know they
they got me it's like uh like all my low
moments they got me you know struggling
and pushing pups and uh they got me
doing a dive soup uh check rolling up uh
with my oxygen or sorry my my air
bottles
off so I get beef for that and then uh
the only other time like I I passed uh I
passed all the like water test first
time every time you know and anyone who
does that says that with a certain
amount of pride um but you know I had
issues during the Drager buddy breathing
so wait you got through
pool week all first time every time
including pool comp yeah oh so they
really did have cameras flowing the
whole time oh come on man I'm just
saying bro I mean you know though I I I
do have to clear there and I don't want
to Dime him out here but on the video
they mistak uh me for someone else as
failing pool comp so if you look closely
they have like a quad screen of like OC
whatever it is uh and uh and it shows
someone getting pulled up from the
surface and you can very clearly see
it's not me but it says Holland oh were
just determined to uh make it look like
you failed yeah yeah yeah um but yeah so
uh you know drer buddy breathing they
they got me uh coming up to the surface
so I I was the you know the top buddy
and in your passing a rig around
basically a and uh yeah he was kicking
it out and I think the hoses got kinked
and uh homeboy wasn't getting no air up
top so that world was like you know
shrinking down fade starting to fade so
I I came up and they got that on video
you know me on oxygen so just like yeah
damn bro documented yeah but luckily no
one will ever see that after this oh
yeah luckily they won't p d myself
out uh and so now you go into third
phase all good there no Factor good
times at se yeah man good times you know
I had uh like one issue I don't know
what it was uh you I grew up shooting
like my dad you used to take me to the
range a lot um but I had like a hard
time quing like on rifles you know so
it's like that was one of those moments
any times I hadn't failed anything up to
that point so you know in the teams you
start to fail something you get uh the
pressure ramps up really quick and I I
personally think the gun was shot out
you know I'll I'll stick with that story
but uh yeah aside from that got through
that uh went to went to sqt after that
got to do Airborne school you know I
felt like I was I'm definitely not the
old guard like you're you're the old you
know '90s Frogman Old Guard you know
guys that raised people like myself but
I feel like I got a you know the tail
end of it in terms of like some of those
experiences so you went to airborn
school in
Georgia where were you at when September
11th happens because you must have been
in training still were you in sqt or you
in buds yeah no I was in sqt um I
graduated in uh June of 2001 Buds and we
were in
sqt uh um getting close to the end there
and we were out at Nyland and we were
actually doing some Claymore Ambush
stuff like old school Vietnam and
it was one of those overnight Evolutions
so go out there um do that basically
until sunup so we were cruising back to
the compound made it back 6:00 a.m. you
know 6:15 618 uh you know the news was
on the first Tower had been hit and you
as everyone knows at that point no one
really knew what was going on uh you
know we kind of grab reference we're all
glued to the screens and then second
tower hit man and it was it was very
clear at that point you know what our
career was going to entail after that it
was clear to you that at that point even
in sqt you were like oh it's on so much
so that uh we actually had um we had a
guy in our class quit on on 912 damn
yeah I I mean everyone knew like we
didn't know what yeah to what what it
was going to look like but I mean it's
like you you know that we're going
to we're going to be in there somewhere
getting after it you had a guy quit yeah
on 912 you know what man from sqt good
on him there's a there's a lot of guys I
want to say a lot um some guys go in for
the wrong reasons you know and they'll
they'll do a pump they'll get out and
and when you're in a non-war Time
situation all good no big deal no foul
man but you know you know you got
pending combat and uh you could be a
liability if you're not if you're not
all in so this guy wasn't all in and uh
yeah so that was uh I ended up I checked
into Seal Team 3 two months later yeah
that's one of those things I've I've had
that conversation with a few people over
the years uh the first time I had it was
talking to some woman wanted me to meet
with her and and her son wanted wanted
to be a seal type thing and she was like
oh I'd really like to meet and I was he
was like a friend of a friend of a
friend so I was like yeah this is like
probably 10 years ago and I was like
okay yeah and I meet with and the kids
like all fired up and stuff and I can do
this many pull-ups and I have this swim
time and I blah blah and I was like do
you want to kill people and are you
ready to die and it was like both him
and the mom were kind of like they
hadn't even they haven't they hadn't
considered that part of the job you know
what I mean and that is that is actually
the job the job is you're to kill people
and you're you're going to put Be In
Harm's Way for you and your friends to
get wounded and killed that's what the
job is that's actually what the job is
everything else is is whatever it's
training it's you know getting ready but
the actual job is you kill people and
you're going to be in a position where
you and your friends could get wounded
and killed and if that's not in the
front of of your mind it's not the good
job for you you know any other reason
any other thing any other fantasy or
Vision that you might have that's not
what the job is the job is you're going
to going to kill people and you're going
to be in a situation where you and your
friends can get killed or wounded and
that's the way it is so yeah probably a
good call for that guy to freaking bail
yeah no doubt at that juncture um so was
team three and where when you got to
team three did you did you go into a
workup was did you get thrown into a
platoon how'd that go down yeah uh I
showed up at the end of the prodev
period so that was November I think we
were
uh starting work up you know I don't
know April of the following year um so
it was kind of junk time you know so it
was kind of getting into the holidays we
went right on a trip like within I think
of me uh my first week being there we
went on a trip um up in central
California Long the coast um may or may
not have gotten into some trouble up
there which got some people disbanded
from a whole city um
damn I'm trying to think of what this is
so this is 2001 the slow incident oh was
that you guys yeah well there's a couple
slow incidents along way there were s
there was there was one where the guys
went up and got in a fight with like Tim
Kennedy and a bunch of Chu Liddell Chu
Liddell and a bunch of actual UFC guys I
I'll take it back we didn't get people
disbanded but we started we opened up
you know the the can of worms um but
yeah I mean that that was like you know
first trip welcome to the teams yeah and
yeah man we were rocking a roll and we
we kicked off uh workup and then you
know CQC was our first block and and so
now you're with Chris we are y so this
is Chris Kyle Chris Kyle's in in in this
platoon is Jeremy in there too he is yep
damn okay yeah
so just you're a new guy what's you know
so I talk about like oh your job is to
uh kill people and be in positions let
me tell you about the other part of the
job when you're a new guy an enlisted
guy in the SEAL Teams it's a freaking
bluecollar job right you're building
pallets you're moving gear you're fixing
gear you're fixing Motors you're
cleaning gear you're cleaning Motors
it's a it's like a blue collar hard work
freaking job that's what it is and
that's what you're doing when you're a
new guy you're getting like extra extra
of that uh what what did you get what
was your job in the platoon Pig
Gunner straight up yeah yeah I mean it
was like no doubt uh I think at one
point they tested me on the radio and
they're like
nope not a chance yeah can you carry
heavy things I'm like yeah I can
probably do that uh yeah so I was adubb
Gunner and you know no quals at all and
I was thrown in uh first
lieutenant uh East Coast calls it
engineering um but yeah man and that was
like Boats and Motors and uh I was also
uh Chris and I were both is's
intelligence specialist so you we were
in the Intel Department as well um but
yeah a lot of responsibilities in there
for two new guys in Department guys like
get a map yeah you have to get the maps
and you have to get you know chem lights
and yeah very tough job yeah you could
you could sell that sounding so cool
like we the in in the Intel Department
like I can imagine you and Chris as new
guys in the quote Intel Department it's
like laminate these Maps you freaking
meatballs yep was it there was no Jason
Bourne going on there no no none of that
no no Tom Clancy stuff
either and so you guys you guys go
through your workup how's the workup it
was good it was good you know that was
the first time I I felt like I'd kind of
gone through buds you know relatively
unscathed but you feel the pressure as a
new guy did you get your Trident at the
end of sqt I was one of the last guys to
get it at the Seal team okay so you
showed up new guy no yeah yeah yeah for
uh
man I want to say the better part of a
of a year so yeah walking around without
that trident and earning it and studying
for my board back then we had a trident
board and and trying to learn I mean
that's what you're trying to
do as a new guy you you think you know
at that point uh you think you know
everything coming from buds sqt you're
like man I am just ready to rock ready
to run and Gun and you show up to a Seal
Team to a platoon and you're like I
don't know anything at all you know it's
like such an it sqt has gotten so much
better um and the new guys are way
better prepared than we were back in the
day but you know we had no exposure to
CQC for example uh Close Quarters combat
um until my first Splatoon so that was
like drinking through a you know fire
hose and uh you know throwing shots and
like you're getting counseled I'm like
you know holy man like I'm going to
get booted from the teams
so they kind of want you to think that
too I mean at least they used to they
used to like want you to think you're
probably going to get canned like
that was always kind of a little bit
little bit over your head of like you
you don't freaking you throw another
shot you're freaking out of here you're
like what the you know that was a
freaking 5050 yard shot with a shotgun
slug dude that's a hard shot bro they
like we got to make these you're like
can I see you do it you shut up new guy
yeah that that's it man I mean it's
uh you know and that that's the mindset
that you want to have that's you want
guys you know not not to be scared to
fail man but I mean it it matters and
like everything is cons consequential
everything matters and you're all in
like every second like there's no
there's no mailing it in you know and so
also at this point like you guys must
have known You're Going To War I mean
it's like a different workup than it was
four months ago cuz four months ago and
I did a bunch of workups where there's
no war going on and look you take it
seriously you do your best and but it's
it's always like there's a chance
there's some slim chance that you're
going to get the big mission whatever
that might be but for you guys must have
been thinking oh we're 100% Going To War
for sure so we had had guys from Team
three that had already been to
Afghanistan so I mean we we knew we were
getting in something you know Iraq
hadn't kicked off yet um but yeah there
was a different mindset now I can't
speak to what the teams were prior but
there was a a certain focus and a
certain kind of eminence about what we
were doing so you I was just trying to
keep up man and making all the usual
dumb guy you know dumb new guy mistakes
and uh trying to overcome those and and
trying to learn the job and you know I
seem to you know always find myself in
some sort of trouble uh you know just
damn near drowned a couple times as a
new guy how' you drown as a new guy man
I I don't do well with like you know a
half inch cord underwater stuff like
that so like you know we were you're
like a freaking half inch half inch
nylon freaking magnet you are dude so
you I mean like we were uh as a new guy
you're carrying all the oh yeah
that's right and so and if you have a
propensity to carry more then you
just carry more stuff so yeah we're
doing Dives I'm carrying a bunch of
and uh we were diving on a rig in the
open ocean and uh I got caught up you
know underneath and had to abandon my
rig Dam dude get up to free S free
swimmer asent yeah it was that's amazing
oh my God so what was kind of funny
about that was uh I mean the guys were
up at the surface at that point so they
they had already gone up uh in a
controlled manner like you're supposed
to do and um I was kind of stuck down
there and the guys running the dive are
kind of freaking out a little bit and
you know you have limited visibility and
so you everyone's kind of like looking
down trying to figure out what to do
with me and then uh I kind of popped up
and I i' kind of floated like behind the
group and uh not sure if you've seen the
uh Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade
when when Indy goes over the cliff and
they're kind of like all looking over
the cliff like like he's perished so it
was kind of like that moment where you I
kind of cruise up and you know with the
group and like hey what's going on
guys it's like oh there you are was your
rig Den Down Below on the line or
whatever yeah yeah yeah so that that was
one time the uh other time we were doing
uh
a subop uh during the big exercise uh
off the California coast and uh working
with boats off of the submarines and uh
I was the only one in in a boat in our
inflatable boat and it
capsized and I saw the whole side of a
submarine like way way too much of a
submarine that you should ever see
because the SE state was like gnarly so
it flipped the boat and I was like
trapped under there it felt it felt like
minutes I'm sure it was like only 10
seconds but but uh I popped up out of
that my eyeballs were
huge you know so that that was just like
how my first Splatoon went you know it
just kind of like always always on the
wrong side of things and uh a lot of
learning I had some great older guys uh
you know my my first Louie uh C Daddy
was an amazing he's an amazing guy but
he he raised me right um you know taught
me kind of you know it didn't take as a
new guy but taught me everything that I
knew um just really solid guy some great
operators there um but yeah first team
was all figuring it out and then
eventually we uh we we deployed and
found ourselves uh over in Kuwait when
did you get there so the war hasn't
kicked off yet no staged yeah it's uh
you know all the stuff is going on in
the news and we don't know what's going
on but it feels like it's it's going to
be happening so we were there in late
2002 mhm um ended up
doing uh I guess it was was supporting
un sanctions mhm so doing ship boardings
yeah yeah yeah so we did a ton of
those and uh man that's just good old
school Frogman pirate man just
running around the what do they call it
the nag do you remember that term
Northern Arabian Gulf the SAG and the
nag the SAG and the nag running around
the nag and the SAG in our boats and
helicopters other boats and going and
hitting ships and taking them down and
getting control of them yep so uh you
know we did that for for a few months
and then uh winter set in and then
things were starting to build for Iraq
and we were starting to you know the US
had a plan at that point and we were
starting to train and uh we had been
nominated as the desert Patrol vehicle
platoon the the Mad Max platoon the DB
dpvs so these are they're they're dune
buggies they're like highspeed dune
buggies that people drive around out at
Glamis and there's some kind of racing
protocol with those things there's like
a whole group that races like those kind
of vehicles but we had them in the SEAL
Teams for a
while we don't have them anymore we
don't have them anymore because for a
bunch of reasons the number one reason
is they're they're a racing vehicle
which means they have high standards and
very tight tolerances for the way they
function and the way they're built and
which means they're going to you put
them in very tough situations they're
they're going to have problems and so
they were they were generally speaking
pretty problematic in terms of their
mechanical stability they broke down a
lot and then on top of that if you break
down anywhere in the world and you need
let's say a tire or a gasket or a
freaking carburetor or whatever you
might need you can't get it I guess they
weren't carb fuel injector but if you
needed aart for those things you you
couldn't get it whereas another vehicle
such as a Humvee you could get any part
anywhere take it from another one like
they were just so there's Humvees
everywhere in the military and so it'd
be it'd be almost like if we used
weapons with a different type of
ammunition you know like where are you
going to get your ammo from so that was
kind of the deal with the dpvs they
looked freaking cool they they always
put them in highlight Navy SEAL videos
they put those dpvs everywhere but I
tell you what you you want to see some
eyeballs you you know rolling onto a
base on a army compound and yeah you
look like rock stars man they don't know
like like everything you said the upkeep
on those things and uh the capability is
when you weigh them down yeah yeah yeah
that's right they make them super heavy
because they're made to they're not
four-wheel drive they're not four-wheel
drive so they they're made to be light
and Float over the sand and once you
weigh them down with a bunch of Team
guys and a bunch of gear and a bunch of
rockets and a bunch of ammo like they
just sink in the sand and mud and they
just get stuck yeah man and you guys
were designated the dpv platoon oh yeah
yep and then you had a plan of what you
guys were going to execute When The War
kicked
off yeah so uh we ended up being part of
the uh you know kind of Strategic
Mission to to invade Iraq so we we were
part of that um securing some of the the
onshore sites there and uh that was that
was just a that was a wild kind of week
leading up to that because we were on I
mean just like uh you know scud and gas
alert notice so we were in mop gear
which is the Kim bio gear and in Kuwait
you know the uh you know us had massed
kind of all the troops for The Invasion
it was pretty clear that this thing was
emminent and Iraq was launching you know
Rockets or scuds or you know whatever
they were towards us and we were
constantly under the threat of like you
know getting gassed so walk around in
gas mask and and getting jocked up like
all the time so uh leading up to the man
I have to look at the days I feel like
The Invasion happened on the
21st um doesn't matter someone else can
fact check it but anyways leading up to
that night you know we were kind of in
mop gear the entire night and then we
got the the call like it's it's go time
so we uh we got in the the
dpvs and loaded these things in uh in
ch-53 the the sea
Stallion and and we Cruis into Iraq man
and that was uh that you know there were
a couple times in my where out of all
the things I
did um where I just felt that that
pucker factor and going into you know uh
Iraqi national
territory you know uh they had they had
anti-air systems and all that and
uh you know we were trying to do things
to mitigate that but I was a new guy you
know in my mop
gear uh in body armor strapped in a
gunner seat in a racing harness with 4
in of room on either side in my in my
roll cage and then the uh the dbv was
strapped into the 53 with three inches
of room on both sides you know to the
walls in the pitch black dark and we're
and and the call comes over the radio
you know whatever uh you know whatever
code word they they pass over I mean
like we've crashed or we've we've
crossed the uh the national territory
line there and then there throwing Chief
yanking and Banking and I I don't know
if we were taking anti-air fire someone
else could it felt like that because we
were doing hard
moves and I just had the realization man
that's like like if we get hit I'm just
I'm gone I mean there's no surviving
this there's no you know egressing and
swimming out like just toast yeah and
it's complete unknown um the first gol
war that went down it was like I was
watching the news and they were like
there's gonna be 40,000 casualties in
the first 24 hours or 48 Hours something
like this and you just it the the
unknown is way worse than the known and
so like that's a perfect example like we
hadn't you know you fast forward three
months even if you fast forward like
four days you're like oh okay they don't
really have the capability that they we
thought they may have had but you're a
freaking a new guy what you just
described being in that dpv strapped
into that Gunner seat inside of a 53
when that thing is strapped in there you
are doomed like doomed this thing even
if that thing successfully crash landed
and was on fire you're never getting out
like you are you are freaking dead so I
like to connect things you know I'm a
big like movie buff guy and uh in shows
and all that and uh banded Brothers had
come out prior to that deployment and
I'm not sure if youve seen that and you
recall do you recall the the scene to
where they're jumping out yeah yeah like
that that is how felt that's how I felt
is we're getting shot at like get me the
hell out of here I want to get on ground
like now I that's my overwhelming
feeling as a military human like anytime
I'm I'm in a aircraft airplane
helicopter uh vehicle
tank Bradley Humvee I don't like it I
want to be on the ground I want to be on
my feet I want to be with my platoon
like that's it that's what I I'm just
the whole time I'm just waiting so I can
be on my feet cuz then I feel like we
can control what what's what's going to
happen to us y all that other stuff is
just in the hands of fate and it's not a
good feeling for me it was never a good
feeling yeah yeah no doubt man the one
that you just described is a pro I think
that's a worse feeling than I ever had
in any of those situations like I've
flown into places driven into places
what you just described I never had that
feeling before I'm trying to think think
if I have no I've never had it that bad
before there's been a couple times like
going into a couple places where I was
like oh we're going to get IED but not
quite I I always feel I I always feel
like someone else is going to get eded
and even if I get eded I'm gonna be okay
I'm G to get out and do awesome kickass
right that's in my little stupid brain
but if you're in a helicopter that's not
happening if you're strapped into a
helicopter if you're strapped into a dpv
in a helicopter that's strapped into the
helicopter bro good times
so uh and and you know going back they
were expecting casualties you know I
mean you don't know what you don't know
uh we hadn't fought in a major conflict
I mean they were you know a year into
Afghanistan that was a much different
War um you know we're fighting a country
here um so really had no clue kind of
what we were getting into and so yeah
like all that shit's running through
your mind and and having no like you
know we' done a bunch of ship boardings
and stuff like that but having no
missions under your belt I mean it's
just your mind running wild mhm and what
was the mission by the way so what do
you guys do you guys hit the ground
launch the dpvs what are you guys going
to do basically set security around a
facility that that was it uh we were
working in conjunction with the Royal
Marines and some other
folks um and it ended up being I mean
basically I want to say a soft target I
mean there a lot of guys there but the
uh the cast that happened prior I mean
just softened kind of all those defenses
so we went in and yeah it pretty pretty
simple Mission actually dude's
surrendering dude's dead what' you find
both both yeah yeah we didn't uh in the
morning like we didn't have any
interactions uh you know we were kind of
in the
peripheries uh some of the Royal Marines
were were getting after it and then uh
the sun came up and there was Carnage
you know uh yeah I mean a lot of guys
got uh the irais uh just got handled and
then um yeah there were some that had
given up and you know we're being kind
of detained and and worked there and uh
and then we started cruising around uh
you know I mean
again we were figuring stuff out and and
not just like the steel teams but you
know we we colletive PR the collective
weed so we were just kind of like
cruising around we just kind of cruise
around without a mission a little bit
and uh you know for all the talk that's
gone on for the reasons why we went into
Iraq I I'll just tell you this because I
have the pictures to prove it is those
dudes and I'm not talking the Iraqi
soldiers but the people there were
stoked to see us there I mean they were
waving along the roads you know they
felt liberated so for you know whatever
that's worth that's what happened and
how long did you spend you know on the
ground uh we were there I think a couple
days you know it's kind of fuzzy there
and then we uh went back to Kuwait kind
of refitted and then we got launched
back out to place called nazaria for a
little bit um and just kind of doing
wrecky like not not doing any sexy
type da stuff that was still in the
dpvs still in the dpvs yeah we did a uh
an Sr on the um the shot laab waterway
that separates uh you know Iran from
Iraq did that and that was that was kind
of that deployment you know and then uh
went back
home did it seem like that
the war was going to be over pretty
quick yeah it did I mean I think even
before we had gotten home I think uh you
know President Bush had had the mission
accomplished on the the Lincoln I think
it was you know yeah if I mean we
cruised I say we and I'm talking about
the US again and we had guys we had
other elements that did the road show to
back dead and it's like man I mean they
were there within a couple days and had
taken over the country and uh you know
we just couldn't hold it
y uh and I wonder so from your
perspective as a new guy that's a great
like you're very lucky right you're a
new guy you're going into war in your
first deployment did you realize how
cool that was I did yeah yeah no no
doubt I mean it
was a huge Mission you know maybe not
the sexist Mission but uh still I think
the largest you know nsw Mission
collectively that we've ever done yeah
and to do a mission any Mission at the
time was like you're freaking
stoked so did did you uh was there
anything that you personally like lesson
learned that really stuck with you from
that first work I mean I know there's
like a thousand little ones any major
ones that you're like I I I need to make
sure I do this that I mean obviously you
had your guy that was sort of like your
C daddy in first lieutenant who who kind
of passed on the way of the Frog man to
you um anything else in that first first
deployment I mean too many to name
nothing like big that comes out but you
know there were just a lot of micro
Lessons Learned and you know I I felt
like a stupid new guy during work up you
know I just felt like you know there was
a lot of pressure going on and by the
end of that deployment I felt like a
team guy like I felt like I was starting
to get and you know unfortunately I
just have have to learn things the hard
way and sometimes it takes me a little
bit longer to get there but I felt by
the end of that deployment I felt very
confident now uh you know still like a
lot to learn that's just like you know
your your yellow belt but yeah yeah it's
uh the learning curve in your first
platoon is freaking steep it's you can't
get ahead of it like no new gu is's
going to get ahead of the power curve
when you're new guy in your first play
it's just not it's not possible there's
too much to know and too much to learn
but once you're in your second platoon
like it it's so much easier it's like
infinitely easier in your second platoon
it's hard to be behind the power curve
in your second platoon so in your first
platoon you got guys like there'll be
like two one or two new guys that like
bro are these guys even going to make it
through workup all the other guys are
kind of like fighting to get through
workup and then you have I guess you can
have one or two guys that are like yeah
they're pretty squared away but by your
second platoon no no one's doing bad
generally speaking maybe one out of 100
is doing bad in their second platoon
like they made it through their first
platoon you get your second platoon
you're generally speaking you should be
pretty good you don't have any
responsibilities you don't you know
you're not really in charge of anything
in your second platoon or you're not in
charge of like leadership so you can
your second platoon you should
be you should be a solid team guy in
your second platoon yeah for sure and
and really what you're trying to get to
is you want to be someone that people
can rely on you want to be dependable
and you're just trying to get there as
fast as you can and some guys get there
you know sooner than others and uh
there's a lot of pressure to do that and
I wouldn't have it any other way man I
mean that that's what builds character
is you know that intense pressure of do
I belong here do I have what it takes
what do I need to do to get there and
that you know whole kind of evolution
kind of makes you who you are yeah uh
come back from that deployment You're
Fired Up roll right into your second
platoon cuz that's what you do in the
team you go right get your next freaking
platoon freaking awesome um what so
what's up with your next platoon did you
get any schools I did yeah I I finally
got a bunch of schools uh ended up you
know I went to the Hurst school so oh oh
yeah yeah Jack helicopters fast R
propell so I did that I you I did the
dive soup RSO all those things uh the
big one I got was was breacher so that
that was the one I wanted um that prior
platoon
was like a very you know we and and
actually team three had like uh just a
lot of breachers and a lot of uh
breacher training that they would do on
their own that was was not even part of
the workup so that was something that I
was like man I I feel like this is this
could be my thing you know I like
carrying heavy things I like breaking
um so yeah I I got breacher school
actually Jeremy and I went to breacher
school and then Chris is this when Chris
went to sniper school he did yeah Chris
Chris went to sniper um so yeah it it
was good man I went to breacher school
and you know so maybe there was a little
bit of Hangover from my my new guy you
know figuring out but I had a close
call breacher school that another like
kind of defining moment that uh you know
I mean like you you know me as you know
the lead breacher for for a task unit
and uh you know I went on to you know do
a lot of real world breaching but uh you
know I got ahead of myself man I was I
won't say cocky but we had been doing so
much breaching at Team 3 and in that
platoon
prior uh that I was I was working on
speed you know and we got to we got a
couple weeks in and I was I was doing
really well in the course and we
transitioned from um one one device to
another device which required like a
different
procedure and uh you know my mind was
like speed it's all all about you know
just kind of mastering mastering the uh
the art of breaching there and uh it was
during a rehearsal but we were doing a
rehearsal with a with a live cap and I
ended up uh I mean detonating a c that
shouldn't have been
detonated and Jeremy actually took took
the brunt um took a little frag in his
leg peppered him a little bit but uh
that was that was the first wakeup call
I mean that was the first time uh in my
you know going through buds like no
issues in buds
um you know I I talked about I I didn't
struggle as a new guy but I mean
certainly I I had my mess ups there but
this was like a first complacency issue
to where I was going too fast um I was
rushing through something and I wasn't
realizing the full impacts of you know
making a mistake like that and you make
a mistake with explosives you make a
mistake with a rifle and people can die
people can get maimed and it's happened
super unfortunate
and I had that happen to me in breacher
school and I thought I was going to get
booted out and then you don't know the
repercussions after that um but I don't
know why they did it um the kadra kept
me there and you know maybe it was my
performance up to that point um they
kept me in and and I fought my way back
I needed up being one of the the
nominate guys to be like uh the lead
breachers for the FTX MH um so I got to
be one of those guys but I mean you do
something like that and you feel like
you have to repit the rest of your
career yeah CU I mean if that had been a
live uh explosion I mean with a full
breaching charge on there who knows what
would have happened to Jeremy no doubt
no no doubt it it's not lost to me and
and again you know to jump away and just
talk about like training and why we do
things the way we do you know the crawl
walk run is there for a reason and
there's a reason why we we go dry before
we go live is so when mistakes like that
happen they happen with paint and with a
cap and not with a you know full
charge um how's this platoon so you're
still together with Chris you and Jeremy
like this and I keep bringing this up
because you guys were such a prominent
piece in Charlie patun and tasking Brer
like the three of you you freaking
Knuckleheads were just like such a um
Cornerstone of the of the task unit you
guys I think well Jeremy was an e E6 at
the time but you guys were like kind of
the E5 Mafia the E dogs making
happen and so you guys are you guys are
together in this platoon you got your
platoon Commander at this time is Rob
who's freaking just just freaking
outstanding um just a maniac awesome
Frogman team guy and your platoon is
it's kind of Mayhem
so I I know this because like I
obviously you guys rolled into tasking
of Bruiser and so I got to see and hear
about what your previous deployment was
like but also just knowing you guys and
KN one Rob like and hearing stories from
all all of you guys so this was like
Mayhem you guys were you guys were
freaking going going hard we were
meaters yeah we we had a great group um
yeah Jeremy and and Chris and uh one
other guy we we suck together so we had
a good contingent from from the prior
the other guy Jake
uh no just an older guy I don't want to
mention his name just because I don't
know if he wants to be mentioned but um
yeah so we had a good group of returning
guys and but all the older guys had left
the platoon except for my my C Daddy
became the lpo got it so we were in this
weird position right uh that we were
like I think to a certain degree looked
at like these combat seasoned
dudes which was not the case like we we
had done a couple missions uh that
weren't you know super tough that
deployment but I think I mean because
like when you don't know I'm sure like
like you've been in 90s frog man the
guys who did like you looked up to
it's like man I can't believe those guys
were on the mission y like we had guys
that had been in
Grenada Panama we had guys that had been
in I I don't think I never had a guy in
a platoon that was in Panama but I had a
guy in up tun that was in grenade and I
had some guys that were in the first
Gulf War by the way the combined like
combat operation time of both those was
like 3 days of both of everyone but like
you're saying it was like hey they had
combat and we didn't and it's just you
just don't know what you don't know and
you just have to think that this thing
is this elevated thing and what's it
going to be like and what it was like
and they they went through it and so now
basically everyone's looking at you guys
with that attitude yeah that's it so I
mean we were me eaters and uh and we had
a good time man and we we trained hard
and and like any sort of uh you know
issues I felt I had as a new guy or lack
of confidence or whatever the hell you
want to call that was just gone you know
even the breacher like once I got
through that and I I I survived all that
you know it's full steam ahead and just
make myself the best team guy I could be
and and and like what you said that
second platoon when you get into your
second platoon it's like things are
clicking and things felt like they were
clicking not just with me but with our
guys and we were highly functional you
know I mean just kicking ass and and
doing really well in all the training
blocks and having fun outside the
training blocks and uh yeah just Full
Speed Ahead like in all aspects you know
of Team guy workup did you guys not did
you guys get a did you guys not get in
trouble no that's impressive yeah and I
I that's impressive I don't know what
the statute of limitations are uh for
for for all the trouble that we caused
during that time but uh no we we St it
out of trouble um others weren't so
lucky um man lots of lots of great
memories uh and I I treasure those and
you know whenever the boys get together
you know we love bringing up the old
I mean you know you have to think
too that uh I've done a lot of
reflecting over the years and I feel
like especially as the war was ramping
up and the mission in Iraq changed such
that we were doing like direct action
missions guys were getting gunfights
things were getting a lot more Dynamic
the wars were ramping up and you know
kind of going back to what we were
talking about like joining the Navy I
mean it just felt like you know like we
were going into the it it was it
was imminent um you don't know what's
going to happen so just like live life
to the fullest get every ounce of it and
that's what we were doing man we were
living hard and fast in all aspects of
everything that we're doing uh enjoyed
the out of it glad we didn't get uh
rolled up and that we survived and uh a
lot of great lessons learned and ended
up having pretty good deployment as well
yeah there's there's no doubt that you
have something in look when you're
skydiving and Diving and shooting live
fire and blowing things up all the time
even in the '90s even when I you you H
you have that feeling in the back of
your head like yeah you know and like
we're jumping or we're doing whatever on
Monday and it's Friday fre let's rock
and roll man let's go like you're not
thinking longterm you're thinking like
let's let's enjoy this gig that we're on
so now when the war kicks off 2001
you're like you got that but now it's
Amplified and intensified by quite a bit
cuz you're going into combat and people
are trying to kill you
so that's like you you add that to the
testosterone you add that to the
freaking like the Friendship Brotherhood
you add that to the shenanigans and the
good times and you're out just go out
and do something hard like just go out
and you know go out and go into the
desert and spend whatever four weeks in
the desert out there out all day up and
down hot dehydrated all that stuff hard
training you get back it's like oh we're
going to go rock and roll that's what's
going to happen so all these things
combined together this is you get the
life of a of of a frog man and that's
what you guys were doing getting after
it yeah that's it man I mean uh we we
live the life that platoon is great so
you're going on deployment and at this
point what year is this like
200 five four yeah okay 2004 so at this
point they were taking guys and you
would basically do three months in the
Pacific and then three months in Iraq
and they were look in my opinion they
were doing that it was kind of like the
fair fairy had showed up and it was like
hey we want to make sure everyone gets
combat we want to make sure everyone
gets to go to war and hey what we'll do
is we'll send because we didn't no one
knew the freaking wars were going to
last for 20 years right so they're
saying oh let's we'll put you over there
for three months then send the other
guys for three months so that's what you
guys did on deployment yeah and I mean I
think I don't know if they have this in
mind as well but you think yeah not
knowing how long the wars are going to
last in terms of the benefit to the
community and get more guys deploy to
comact Z as well yeah true that's a
maybe not a bad move but if we would
have known that the war is going to last
20 years which eventually once they
figured out the war is going to last 20
years like yeah you just you're going on
because it's a big just the logistics of
taking guys so expensive yeah so
expensive and such a pain and and really
in three months like you're just getting
up to speed so why are we going home
let's keep or why are we going to this
other AO let's keep going uh what so
your typical exercises and stuff over in
the
Pacific no I did you go to the Pacific
first I did which I think it's good yeah
yeah well it no it' be better to do the
other way it it'd be better to go the
other way but at least we had something
to look forward to
MH there there's pros and cons right
because if you do it the other way and
then you're there is like what's the
point right um but at least we knew we
were going to the show and um yeah and
and we knew that we were going to be in
a spot doing Das doing direct action
stuff so had all that to look forward to
and uh just kind of buying our time
until we we got there and then uh yeah
so actually Chris and and the other guy
got pulled from our platoon for the push
through fuia in November 2004 so we were
like just super pissy about that hanging
on in pcom and uh just reading after
actions from Chris yep yep yep and it's
like man and so uh eventually we linked
up in January and then uh as a good
little deployment man I mean yeah we
were only there for about three and a
half months but uh I don't know did
maybe 15 plus Das and uh that's where I
cut my teeth as a breacher you know man
that that was in those were like the hey
days of doing roll up assault you were
like riding the rails um you know fast
roping on the X got to do some of that
sexy stuff um but I'll tell you what
wasn't sexy was my first op as a
breacher let's go what went
down hey lesson was learned but uh so
we're we're rolling up and um I have my
charge on me and we're we're heading to
Target so uh you know basically kind of
breachers part of the the point element
if you will we we head to the Target and
we have to hop over a wall well this
wall was pretty short like a 4ft wall um
we got a structure there and I had my
nods on right this is kind of how we
trained but we you know maybe hadn't
been using that many walls or hopping
over walls so like the art the art of
the Hop hadn't been uh perfected yet so
I had my stuff like all ready and like
I'm good with that and uh so I I roll
over the wall you know kind of four foot
wall that I can kind of walk up to and
just kind of like roll over and it was
10 ft on the other
side and so I just spilled you know uh
you know asso Kettle or whatever and it
was just a complete mess so I mean got
up and like you know my nods were
flopped up and I was catching they had
like closed lines it was just like I did
everything wrong just Keystone Cops all
yeah yeah just making so much noise and
then um but I I made it up to the door
the breach went fine breach went good uh
you know the guys didn't leave me enough
room um to not blowing myself up so you
know got was a little bit too close but
um other than me spilling over the wall
it went pretty good but but but I
learned a valuable technique which I use
after that is I I would never go over a
wall on nods I mean you you look over
the wall on nods but always looking
underneath trying to use that uh you
know the depth perception isn't great on
those things yeah so after this you know
uh first breaching little Fiasco at
least over the wall so what was your op
Tempo
like uh I think we were doing a couple
Ops a week cool yeah so like like I said
I don't know the exact number but we we
did you know I don't know 15 18
something like that um actually I mean
those are like going out on missions but
we would often do multiple targets so I
don't know we did couple dozen something
like that da and uh cut our teeth man
and that was really uh you know I think
team five was kind of like the uh
you know the Godfather of creating the
modern Seal Team da at least that that's
how it was perceived on the west coast
in terms of creating those procedures
and uh and doing all that stuff and so
yeah we got really good at it and you
know those were like the good good old
sexy missions if you will where you're
just rolling it hot blowing up you
know taking things over with violence of
action and uh you know rolling off
Target with the Bounty it's like 45
minutes bro it's like you know what I
mean it's such immediate gratification
and with such limited like downside you
know like it's just good we did one uh
one kind of unique mission that we were
doing a this was like my
first uh real
OverWatch where we were um we joined up
with a this was just kind of a weird one
but we joined up actually I think with
the first with the
506 out in uh in habia so we we moved
around a little bit and they had a kind
of an OverWatch Mission major uh thrir
there and some separate teams kind of
mutually supporting positions whatnot
and so we were paired up it was me and
another
Frogman and two army guys and We snuck
into a town and I these guys just do
different right so uh snuck into a
town you know free climbed up like a
second story building in the middle of
like you know like a city Square I guess
and in the morning to my surprise the
whole city was surrounded us like we
were we were like in an
apartment overwatching stuff with an
active I mean there was like I looked
out the window at one point you know
very very sneakily looked out and below
I mean they were selling fish there was
like a fish market right below us and we
were in this kind of like abandoned
building and
you know you had guys like kind of all
around it's like holy man you know
this can get Gnarly really really quick
um of course nothing did I it's pretty
uh pretty easy Mission there but um yeah
other than that did did a bunch of
Das uh I didn't get roped into any of
the uh security type stuff that that the
other dudes were doing yeah I got lucky
good uh come home from that deployment
and now you roll into so now it's 2005 I
guess 2005 before you might have gotten
home but it's
2005 when we form
up so were you already done no cuz we
went we went to Desert like almost
immediately so you guys had already done
proda so you probably got home in 2004
no five okay yeah so I I deployed uh
that was a quick turnaround we had a
couple quick turnarounds so oh that's
right there was no prodev yeah yeah we
came back in uh April 2005 and then went
right into it check uh um what's cool is
you still are with Chris and Jeremy so
and I I I the Triumph it so do you know
what that means I think it means three
people it does so I once I I was like
you know cuz Le used to say it all the
time he's like oh it's a triumphant and
and I kind of was like finally yesterday
I was thinking about that and I go what
does this even mean where does this come
from and it's like some Roman term for
three people that are in a position of
power and they had like a bunch of
examples you know cesure and this guy
and this guy and so that 100% came from
Leif you know Leif would only only Leif
at that time had the historical
knowledge to come up with
triumphant um so you guys roll in to now
it's your third platoon together um
Tony's BTF Tony comes in as the platoon
Chief I was thinking about this too you
guys must have been bummed that freaking
Rob wasn't going to be your task unit
commander and you were getting some
freaking random guy you never heard of
me yeah some some caveman looking guy
yeah and if you're calling me a caveman
and you're comparing me to Rob like
these are the options there's there's a
lot of neander fall activity going on
between us to uh yeah but you guys must
have been like damn a little bit bummed
out because you guys were Bros with Rob
you just did a deployment with him and
it's kind of normal that he would just
Fleet up in the same troop and just take
over I don't know why that I don't know
why it happened the way it did yeah I
don't know I mean we obviously loved Rob
he he was he was the man um so yeah you
know I don't know how things shook out
but it all worked out so somehow the
Ouija board got
um I think I just figured out why it
might have happened that way but we can
talk offline about it yeah yeah yeah um
so I show UPS to you Commander Leif
shows up as the platoon Commander BTF
Tony's your platoon Chief that's kind of
a new headshed coming in but the cool
thing is Jeremy steps steps us up as the
lpo yeah so Jeremy steps up uh Chris is
still there and not only that but we had
all the previous new guys they all stuck
around so we had the yeah we got these
freaking we had dude we had I mean the
Dream Team and in these guys we had uh a
ridiculous amount of quals like I don't
know like I think seven breachers and
seven snipers like we were just tasking
a Bruiser ended up with 13 snipers which
is freaking badass yeah unreal that's
that's one set of quals um and you guys
roll in there and it's cool you know
that's always a question I get asked a
lot about is like stepping up from being
a peer to being a leadership position
how' Jeremy handle that and maybe I'm
sure Jeremy will come on the podcast at
somebody but how how' Jeremy handle that
from your perspective I mean he rocked
it man he he stepped right into it he
was one thing really impressed me about
Jeremy was you know he was a couple
years younger than me um but you when
you're in your 20s that's like a big
deal right like I'm 22 and he's 20 um
but he was a little bit younger and but
he he had made first class and you
hadn't basically what are you saying man
I'm just wondering no that that's how he
got it right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
he was the highest ranking guy um but
definitely the guy for the job man I
mean he was kind of a a prodigy if you
will you know just really solid frog man
and he stepped up and did all the things
that you would expect you know in lpo to
do and it it makes it easier when you
have a good guy that you know is a good
guy right like so it he was just easy to
work for y no he's freaking stepped
right up but that's a question I get
asked all the time like I'm getting
elevated and you can go you can go too
hard or you can go too soft you can be
like that's right I'm in charge now or
you can be like I guess I'm in charge
like I don't know and he did a right the
the the right balance of like hey you
know what I'm I'm in charge now I don't
know everything but I got to make a call
and this is what we're doing you know
like he just did it good it depends the
group of guys too right because if you
have immature guys and uh you're not
able to respect the position um and
honestly I think Leif did that I mean he
was like masterful at how he did that in
terms of developing good meaningful
relationships with people um but doing
it in a way that like there was never
any question that he was in charge and
that when it came down to a decision
being made there's a time for discussion
and then there's a time that you know
this is what we're doing right so yeah
Jer Jeremy was good at that and if
you're a if you're a good dude I mean
that's hopefully how it should roll and
our first trip was straight out to land
Warfare and it was just freaking awesome
yeah I mean like everybody was just
kicking ass oh man I I just realized the
uh the never ending march oh yeah yeah
that was a rough one um especially for
guys that maybe didn't take things as
seriously as they show have so we get
told um that we're going to do a
ShakeOut Patrol ShakeOut Patrol is like
oh we're going to go make sure our gear
feels good make sure that you know our
equipment's riding right and walk around
you know probably be back in a half an
hour maybe 45 minutes something like
that this is day one yeah this is day
one we just show up out there so like
Hey we're going to do a shake out they
literally say we're going to do a shake
out Patrol this is a common thing shake
out Patrol the original idea is hey make
sure your gears not making any noise so
it's like go out there shake shake it
out a little bit make sure you don't
have go through like the hand and arm
signals like just shake some stuff out
45 minutes hour something like this
would you call it like a practice run
but it's even less than that it's less
than that it's like it's like just a
shake out I'm trying to think of a way
that if you were uh uh in a school play
and they were like just walk through
where you're going to go yeah you you're
not even going to deliver any lines
you're not going to sing any songs if it
was football what what's your football
equivalent for Echo Charles
um it would be a walkthrough like a like
a Friday you know afternoon walkthrough
or something like that so you're you
literally shouldn't break a sweat yeah
you shouldn't break a sweat you should
just be hey we're cruising
but me so I'm like okay shake off trol
was that mean like I get all my gear
totally squared away like water
everything that I'm going to be carrying
I'm carrying like I just do what what
I'm supposed to do as a good freaking
frog man not everyone did that including
le le fabin had had his freaking he had
had his water in his canteens since
sqt and so he he had water and like the
first sip he took okay so put yeah the
first sip he took it was like spoiled
like rotten water yeah so so anyways
they they go hey we're going to take you
guys out for this Jakob Patrol then they
drive us out in the middle of the desert
and then they start dropping it off off
by pears and giving us linkup points and
it ends up being like an allight
evolution walking all through the desert
and guys like Leif hadn't cleaned his
canteens other guys just didn't bring
water bigles or he'd brought like very
little water and so we end up on this a
little bit of a Death March and this the
story that Leif likes to tell is he
comes up to me and he's like
hey he's like hey uh have you got have
you got water and I was like yeah he's
like do you have any uh spare water and
I was like why and he's like uh Bagel
does have any water he's he's starting
to feel it and I'm like and LEF LEF uh
when he tells the story I look at him
I'm like is he going to die I'm like is
he GNA die and he's like no and I was
like well tell him to remember to bring
his own water next time so that was one
example of you know a few things that
went down that night but like Leif was
out of water I don't know what was your
status yeah I I run hot man I I brought
my water but I burned through it we
marched I mean it was hot Y and we
marched not acclimated because it was
day one not acclimated and a carrying a
full you know Pig Gunner Loadout so
third third platoon you know I'm still
carrying that pig and uh yeah I I was
smoked man and then did you go down no I
didn't go down no no no one actually
went down no everyone sucked it up no
one down and then at the end of that we
did like a combat conditioning course
right oh was in the because it was just
getting light and they're like hey
combat conditioning course is next and I
was like oh
cool good I was like cool let's go
freaking combat conditioning course um
hey also so we're out there Bagels is
out of shape and he's like L dude you
could tell as a new guy he got done with
Buds and sqt and was like I just
finished Buds and sqt and I'm gonna
freaking relax for the next 30 days of
leave and that's exactly what he did and
you know normal I I was thinking about
this normally in a normal Seal Team
you'd be like oh cool then you get back
to the team and everyone would be in
prodev and you kind of get back into
shape and whatever and you can also
think like bigles having been a wrestler
he probably like you know cut weight and
he was like on that 30 days of leave he
was finding some food man he was getting
in there and he he liked to eat you know
what I'm saying you know he liked to get
he liked to eat so he put on some lbs
and the very first trip he shows on is
is for a desert Warfare and he's not in
shape and um he was hurting on that and
he was hurting on the combat
conditioning course and so right out of
the gate it was like this guy's not in
shape and he had a cool attitude but
basically you got assigned to freaking
Square his ass away right yeah well tell
me about that yeah we just got paired up
I mean it there was really no program it
you know Leif just told me hey take take
Ryan under your wing and square him away
so what that meant was is we started
running together and so every you know
not every day but you know several times
a week and on every trip we just ran so
yeah we we ran the deserts of uh of
Nyland and Leif just always like the
image just pops up in my head of you
know we're running with our shirts off
down the siphon Road and uh you know I'm
I'm like Portuguese tan middle summer
and and bigles is just like glaring just
white just uncomfortably glowing white
down the road yeah yeah that's freaking
classic
uh we
get that other story that's freaking
classic is freaking Johnny Kim like you
you guys had just like hazed somebody
and I don't think that's the term that
we use you guys had just hazed
somebody and it was like real obvious
and everything and so I actually got the
platoon Chiefs in Sea and I was like hey
hey guys and so I pulled like hey guys
like I get it but you can't be dumb like
you can't be doing this like it's
real obvious like
freaking freaking keep it under control
boys and they're like yeah got it got it
and I you not as we're walk cuz J
cuz Johnny had been at sniper school so
he showed up late and this this 20
minute period I you not the
20-minute period that like I saw this
happen and I was like dude you guys so I
go hey let me talk to you guys muster
them out outside we're out freaking
standing by the whatever that Tower is
we're standing there like having a
little freaking man on man conversation
with the khakis and then during that 20
minutes Johnny Kim had showed up at the
at at Nyland as a new guy late you know
now he's late even though he's at a
freaking school but you guys are like
you're freaking late and I come walking
back in and you guys had taken him like
shaved half of his head beat him up or
whatever and I come walking in and and I
hear someone like it was actually Chris
Chris is like go report to the commander
and I'm like what is going like that's
just a weird thing to hear you know CU
everybody calls me jao and now I hear
like me being referred to as the
commander he's like go go report to the
commander and I look over and here
here's freaking Johnny and I look at him
and he's like a little bit shell shock
looking but also I see like toughs of
hair like on his shoulders and like half
of his head but he's got a hat on and
I'm like hey bro how's it going he's and
he's like sir um I'm petty officer Kim
I'm I just got here from sniper school
I'm honored to be a part of this and I
was like cool bro it's awesome to meet
you man I I look forward to working with
you and then just like walked around I
was like God I got some freaking out ofc
control Knuckleheads um which is kind of
what you want um so that was all good
all good yeah good times but there were
some old school bonding going on did I
say hazing or did I said bonding rituals
bonding I think you meant bonding I
think I meant bonding rituals so there's
some bonding rituals that took place
that were uh going on so we get done
with that we freaking gen um I think we
did we went out to the desert for
vehicles next um Mobility then we go to
CQC um and this is when we were still
doing CQC out at a civilian place so
that was awesome training yeah great
great workup yeah that's a good one we
really had a an awesome workup going to
mount was also at an army base so we had
a big facility to use out there and and
this whole time we're having good times
as well um both on and off the training
areas was a good crew yeah no doubt man
I mean the uh we had we had a lot of the
energy from that prior platoon so we
were still you know a bunch of meaters
yeah um but with a little bit more
civility and uh a little bit more
structure well yeah I mean you you throw
Tony into the mix and like that's just a
diff you know Tony's a freaking animal
right and I mean by by that I mean like
he's an he's like part human but part
animal like you want to talk about
needing water in the desert doesn't
drink water no just coffee and dip yeah
coffee and dip he's like oh we're doing
a ShakeOut Patrol it's going to be nine
days long cool I'm going to eat dirt and
be good to go by the way so when when
you were talking about hey you know
forming up a new platoon when when I
heard he was going to be our platoon
Chief I was like oh this guy
because he had put me through uh he was
you know he was like the Desert Rat out
in Nyland he did like years at an island
and uh multiple tours probably and he he
put us through our 60 Gunner course oh
yeah the infamous course and this is the
multi-day course and uh it was hell on
Earth man I mean while the the
grenadiers are like you know sipping tea
Riflemen yeah the The Riflemen graders
what whatever the hell that they were
doing training for that week and we were
just grinding up and down middle of the
summer buddy carries and just stuff
feeding until our like fingers were
bleeding it was awful and he was just
sitting there you know just drinking his
coffee and dipping and uh and then
luckily he would give us a break during
lunch and we could go unpack CL unpack
ammo while everyone else was eating so I
mean you know he thing about that is you
might not know how hard he is as a human
being cuz you're like oh he's just like
sitting up here telling us what to do
but you know what well I'd like to see
him do that and then you then then he
does it then you realize like oh he'll
do this and that freaking that type of
thing when you in the SEAL Teams when
you have somebody and there's always
someone like this that's into whatever
they're into like the breaching is on
the backs of like a handful of guys that
were just super into breaching and just
took it to the next level the snipers
like there's guys that just all you know
from generation to generation like
someone turns over that SC schol that
train that block of training is just
like someone goes in there and takes it
over it's like they love it and they
want it to be the best training and AWS
and comms guys and everybody you get
these people in the teams that that
create the school or the training for
people that just takes it to the next
level like the aw course is a classic
example the aw course could be like a
2hour session maybe a 4H hour session
you'd be pretty good you know you'd be
pretty good after 4 Hour of good drills
with a with a heavy machine gun you'd be
like okay cool like we're pretty good at
this and most communities would be like
okay cool yeah we we've really trained
our automatic weapons Gunners to a high
level but when you see what the aw
course is like you think oh these guys
are literally ready for anything that
can happen with an aw it's freaking
awesome and that's what you end up with
you end up with badass people that have
been trained to the nth degree and
they're going to be able to crush in any
situation yeah for sure and you know I
didn't know much about Tony's background
so like him coming in I'm like you know
is this guy I'll talk or whatever and
he's certainly not like the hardest frog
man I've ever worked with I mean the guy
is just like what you said you know I
mean doesn't need water doesn't need
food he just I mean he does need dip and
coffee and that he can run off you know
for weeks off that yeah and so he and I
grew up at team one together so we knew
each other so but we had never been in a
platoon together but like when I was
coming to team three and I saw that he
was one of the platoon Chiefs and and
the same thing like we were both like so
freaking stoked cuz I knew you know his
reputation as a frog man was awesome you
know and his reputation as like beating
people up and all that he had that too
but I knew like hey cool we can you can
contend with that like you can contend
with like hey dude dude can you do me a
favor for the next 48 hours not punch
anyone and and here's why and like we
want to you know he'll be like no
no yeah I'll just sit in my room then
it's like but he gets it you know and he
did things that were so one one of the
things that was so professional I'll
never forget this I'm out there we're at
we're doing um we're doing mobility so
we're out there at Nyland with the
vehicles and we were supposed to be
setting up like a little mini Opera or
something and I'm just standing there
and Tony's like hey and he's talking to
Le and he's like hey what we should do
is put Vehicles here put vehicle here
send the guys over here boom set it up
like this and uh leif's like yeah cool
and he says and Leif says hey want you
go ahead and you know tell the platoon
and Tony's like no you go ahead and tell
him it'd be better coming from you and
just to have that that humility for him
he you know this was early in the workup
he wants Leif to get get that uh rapport
with you guys to be like oh yeah Leif
knows what he's he's wanting to build up
his boss and there's so many times where
people's ego's like LT you go ahead and
stand down I'll brief like he just
didn't play any of that so he's hard and
tough as hell and an awesome operator
but he also like really truly understood
the Dynamics of leadership and the
Dynamics of a freaking seal platoon
which was outstanding outstanding to see
and beautiful to work with yeah I I
think uh
you know we build our kind of leadership
blueprint with everyone that we work
with but you know mine certainly was
heavily influence with with Tony's and I
just grew to really respect the hell out
of him great Frogman great great leader
and I mean just like you know just a
tactical badass yeah yeah
um you were you were mentioned something
before we hit record about when we were
at Mount and like I was encouraging you
somehow
to what was it an off school course that
we were doing a mount off schol course
what went down tell that's exactly what
it was and I I'm surprised that that you
don't remember this um but we were
paired up into groups of three so it was
I don't remember who the third was but
it was you I and someone else and we
were in these teams and it was like a
combat condition course where we're
doing all these different opst schools
in the mount toown and one of the obst
schools was like we're running up a
building and we're repelling down and
it's a pretty tall building I mean I
don't know six stories something like
that and I don't even know if we had to
Bay dude um but yeah we got up to the
roof we rushed up to the roof and you
know yeah we're trying trying to trying
to win this damn thing right and I I
don't know you know what your motives
were but you were compelling me to take
more slack with the rope and I mean mind
you I'm I'm like a trained hearse guy I
know my way around a Repel rope um but
you were eging me on a little bit and I
don't know I canli so I took I took a
lot of slack and I jumped off that roof
and it must have looked like an ' 80s
action movie man because I jump I went
like two stories down I Disappeared into
one of those open windows and my o
meter was like going off the charts man
my eyeballs were big and I was just
holding that rope and and I it kind of
like ricocheted me out so I I flew in
and then the Rope kind of like
ricocheted back and I was just like all
eyeballs I just carried on smartly and
then went down but I was like oh
man that's classic that's awesome you
obviously messing with me testing me a
combination of probably I don't really
remember it you know but for me to be
like encouraging people to freaking go
hard and do tougher yeah it's
pretty pretty standar but that's also
the trip where Tony broke his ankle and
like he tells he tells the story like
just like hobbles over to the side of
the roof and then just goes like to like
try and force his broken ankle to heal
it was of course after he made some kind
of speech like you know so something
happened you just BTF through it you
know and sure enough what'd he do he BTF
through it just freaking holling around
on a broken ankle oh hell yeah
um we were set to deploy to Baghdad yeah
and we went on a pdss so like a
predeployment site survey to Baghdad and
met up with the the Special Operations
guys it was seals and Green Berets that
we were going to go and replace and we
were going to be working with this this
Iraqi counter Terror force and
very let's say a a very cookie cutter
kind of deployment was set up for us
like everything's in place the guys have
been trained the operations are kind of
steady and flowing and it looked like it
was going to be just a really good solid
deployment and that's what was happening
and so I went over there on
predeployment all good like high five
with the guys yeah we'll see you guys in
a few weeks come back when I came back
they had done for whatever reasons well
I know the reason they wanted to unify
the entire western part of Iraq under
one special operations leader they chose
our leader at Seal Team 3 to be that guy
and now the opportunity for him was to
unify his whole team Underneath Him in
Western Iraq in Alomar Province and they
ended up coming up he he I got called in
and you guys were on leave and he's like
hey there's a chance for you guys to go
to ratti if that makes sense to you and
I was like because I knew what was going
on in ratti ratti was total Mayhem at
the time and I was like yeah well that
makes perfect sense to me and that's
what we ended up doing now did you did
you guys did we we I don't even think we
had a capability of getting that word to
you while you guys were on predeployment
leave no no we came back from Le and uh
that was just kind of dropped on us and
you know um didn't really know like what
that meant hadn't really had time to
kind of absorb what the changing mission
was I mean the original Mission was kind
of like what I had done the prior
deployment that's what we were expecting
to do yeah yeah there was a lot there
was a lot of people that that was almost
like uh what's that expression that was
like two birds in the hand is worth one
in the bush it seemed like that was a
real obvious like hey this is we're
going to go there we're going to do this
type of mission it's already going on
like there's no drama we can just go and
do that I looked at what are you
laughing at EO Charles that was
that was a gross misrepresentation of
the expression but you know it's kind of
the opposite but hey man okay you do you
my boss you do you no what I'm saying is
going to Baghdad was like oh this is a
good deal it's already like two two
birds right here right in our hands we
have this real
nice kind of easy mission two two birds
in the bush is better than one in the
hand in the hand yeah the the one in the
hand is the
unknown no the one in the hand the one
in the hand is the one that's known you
have yeah you said two in the hand is
worth one in the bush which is okay so
I'm I'm all jacked up yeah yeah all
jacked up well that's the way it goes
sometimes we had this opportunity to
have one bird in the hand now I'm
tracking all right we we could have had
one bird in the hand which was these
nice
clean simple straightforward operations
in Baghdad Great
optempo or we're going to this Wild West
area which was really bad at the time
and the task unit that we were going to
be taking over for they were conducting
operations but it was like really hard
for them to get operations approved they
they were getting out of the wire
sometimes but it was kind of tricky for
them to get out
and it's definitely like some guys were
like damn it seemed like we are taking a
risk by going to do this other stuff in
ratti when we could have just kind of a
nice silver platter with cool Ops in
Baghdad I looked at it like hey there's
a lot of bad guys in ratti and they're
concentrated there and there's really
bad things happening and we can go there
and I think we can do a lot of good and
do a lot of damage to the enemy and so I
rogered up you guys all came back and um
we went
undeployment you remember getting
there no I I don't really remember uh
you much about arriving there
um was it the first night that we got
into the uh I think it was your guys so
I went early with like Tony and like a a
few guys like there was some of us went
early and then you guys showed up like
four or five days later something like
that but yeah we got like uh the there
were some assault on the camp and so we
end up with the entire task unit
including TCH just up there on the roof
just laying waste across the river oh
Shadow stalker getting get with with
like no no and just shooting from the uh
the hip yeah I that was uh that was my
intro to ratti man I I had a feeling
that we were going to be getting after
it the entire
deployment yeah and I I just knew so
when I got there got on the ground I
realized you know some some I went and
talked to there was a guy from um
Special Operations Command who was a
friend of mine that was there at the
time and he kind of briefed me what was
going on his Intel officer had been my
Intel officer when I was at Seal Team 7
so I knew her well and she told me what
was going on and then I kind of
obviously turned over with the the task
unit that was there before us and got a
feeling for what was going on and then
talking to the conventional so I
basically figured out like what we could
do that I thought would be very
beneficial to the fight you know and so
by the time you guys got there I kind of
had a pretty good idea of what was going
to go down and and how we could start
knocking it out and I for for a while
for a few days we were for probably like
five six days we were actually working
for the COO of Seal Team one so the
sealo of Seal Team 3 hadn't taken over
yet so there was like five days or six
days where we were working for the co of
Seal Team 1 who I kind of knew and what
we tried to do is do as many missions as
we could in the first five six days so
that we developed a precedent of like
Hey we're going to be working a lot and
that's exactly what we did um Leif tells
a story about
the first op that he ran which I'm sure
you as a DA in like right outside in
tamim and Leif was like stressed like
there was paperwork do and there was
this do and he was like we you know he
kind of came to me like dude we should
just like roll this and I was like bro
you you got this you this is this is
like a literal no-brainer your platoon
knows what to do you know what to do
just go knock it out he was like Roger
that and guys went knocked it out was no
factor and came back and he's like
you're right dude like we're ready and
we just did that as much as we could for
the next few days
and almost immediately also started
doing sniper OverWatch positions the one
of the best things that happened was
Tony took a crew out up in a firecracker
I don't know if you were on this or not
but he took a a little sniper OverWatch
team up in a firecracker and I was this
was so
early I was meeting the Brigade
Commander for the first time and when I
walked into the
talk they Tony's element had just Ked
killed an IED in place her in an exact
spot or like a block away from where an
IED just killed like three Marines and
this you this was like the timing was
impeccable I'm going into the talk this
radio traffic is coming in the Brigade
Commander Colonel gronsky's hearing this
radio traffic that the seals just got
here and they just killed an IED and
Placer which was right where these we we
lost these marines he looked at me and
was like we need you to go to Eastern
raditi and I was like Roger that sir and
boom like that's kind of all these
little elements kind of got the ball
rolling really well um and on top of
that like going to Memorial Services
right out of the gate for army guys and
Marines that's like one of the first
things we did and that was a real eye
opener as well I think for
everybody yeah man I mean from my
perspective coming in obviously it was a
different kind of deployment than we had
done last last couple but uh you you
guys made it clear that we were there to
you make an impact whatever whatever
that meant um and getting creative like
what you guys were doing behind the
scenes which I really wasn't super privy
to at that point um to find employment
that was meaningful and not meaningful
to like you know um beefing up our evals
you know doing doing a bunch of Ops that
don't really matter but um like what
you're saying I mean guys guys were
getting you know conventional forces
were getting getting hammered pretty
good you know the Iraqis weren't going
out um you know the effort required us
to do some things that that you know we
weren't used to doing um but it needed
to be done and I think you know us
walking away after that seeing the kind
of strategic impact of of doing that was
pretty cool yeah the a great example so
we ended up doing these sniper OverWatch
positions all over and when you think
about it how many how many Urban sniper
overwatches did we do during workup the
answer is zero so I was actually talking
to a guy the other night
and you know we were talking about
workup and he's currently going through
workup and I was talking to him and he
was sort of like saying well hey you
know we've got this thing going on in
the world we got this thing going on in
the world it's kind of hard to tell
which one to actually prepare for and I
was talking about I talked I told this
to a few other guys as well
um what workup does is it puts you in
really challenging situations that you
learn to figure out and if you can take
your Mark 48 and get it waterproofed and
swim across the beach at San Clemente
Island and go live fire hit a Target
somewhere and then get back in the water
and swim back out to a boat that whole
thing is just a bunch of problem solving
that's what it is it's a bunch of
problem solving you know I I don't think
the uh Sr training that we used to do
gets enough credit true you know I mean
I think that was the training I mean you
look at the muscle movements in terms of
the the things that we're doing the
planning the multi-day missions and all
that the only difference is is how
you're setting up in an urban
environment y but when you have to adapt
to oh I'm going to do an OTB then you
have to adapt to going to Sr then you
have to adapt to Vehicles then you adapt
to boats then you adapt to this then you
adapt to this you can't do it all and
you can't do it all but what you learn
what you train to do sure you train to
do overwatches or um or you train to do
Sr and yes you train to do das but what
you train to do is you train to think
you train to adapt you train to learn
that's actually what the workup is is
getting people to learn how to adapt how
to see patterns how to recognize where
they can
improve and that's what workup is and
that's actually what seal like even buds
buds is like Mayhem how it's How do you
deal with Mayhem how can we take this
freaking total chaos of hell week and
get a head count how do we do that and
that's what carries through and that's
what we that's what we're good at we're
good at looking at a sandwich and
being like okay we need to turn this
into an operation that we have control
over well us more than others too I
think you know we're not mired by
doctrine that the teams are you know out
of all the other soft elements out there
you know we're probably the least
Doctrine focused now that could be bad
in some ways but it's bad in some ways
but it sure is good in other ways like
what what you're talking about I mean
throw us in challenging environments and
situations and we're going to figure
out yep and then we'll get get
better at that down the road yep yeah
even when we were out of the water for a
while meaning like nsw in general you
know in the workups they we started
doing less and less diving and less and
less marops and people would talk to me
about it be like you know we're not even
getting the water I was like hey man if
we need to get back in the water we'll
get back in the water we'll figure it
out I'll take I went through that cycle
you know it's like oh we haven't done
OTB in a while cool how do you rig the
boats and you'll go screw it up and you
like hey we need to put one in Tu be
nylon around this and oh yeah hey we
need to make sure we prep them motor
like this oh yeah cool hey we need to
make sure that the cham lights IR chits
are so you you just relearn it but
because you have an open mind and
because you've learned how to adapt
that's what makes it work and that's
really exactly what we did when we got
to ratti we were doing operations that
we had to figure out we were doing uh
interact interoperability with Marines
and with army that we hadn't done we
were using vehicles that we hadn't used
Bradley's tanks we were using air
support that we had and used to patch
like there's a whole bunch of things
that we just had to go okay how we going
to work this
we we couldn't be like hey we know how
to do this we be we've never done this
before what what do you think what give
us your opinion how would you execute
this Mission army guy or Marine guy like
those army guys have been there for four
months 6 months 10 months Marines have
been there for 3 months four months 5
months at that time like Hey how do you
guys think of this what do you guys
think of this learn from them and then
go oh what about this and that's really
what it was was like an exercise in
adaptability yeah the other thing that
was interesting is we show you know we
do this whole workup as a complete task
unit we get to ratti and we split up
into five separate elements bunch of
different you know little five six-man
elements are are now running things and
people like you you were in your third
platoon you end up as like the assault
chief for the special Mission Unit of
the Iraqis as a combat adviser which is
a huge freaking
responsibility that in particular was
was really cool and just kind of dumb
luck how it panned out but yeah we broke
up into different groups there and you
know we were at a fiveman mixed
element and with our uh special missions
platoon I think they were called right
the the Iraqi element that essentially
we were partnered with whenever we were
targeting you know bad guys to go after
um and gave me a great
opportunity yeah I mean to kind of plan
and Lead these assaults when I had no
business
doing that you know structurally in
terms of like where I was structurally
didn't but experience-wise and
level-headedness and performance and
Leadership capability you were
definitely ready to rock and roll
obviously yeah yeah that that was uh
that was good man that was great great
experience like super fortunate that I
found myself um you know in that group
and I I was with Leif always a great
time working with Leif and you know
learn so much with him throughout that
and I got really into the mission
planning process and kind of the
non-sexy stuff but you know what like
all that stuff if uh you're going to do
a career in the teams you know learning
how to do that learning how to uh
you know whether it's dealing with
products um briefing like I wasn't
a great briefer um before then and I was
probably not great during that but I got
a lot better at it and you know learning
how to run you know and and uh at
kind of a higher level and it it was
cool you know got to run some I mean
task uni size Das and deal with all that
and to have the opportunity to kind of
be in the position I was in was yeah
pretty cool you were um you threw out a
lot of Rambo quotes it's kind of your
thing yeah you know I mean going back if
if you were to look at my childhood you
probably would wonder why I didn't go
into the green Braes you know yeah huge
Rambo
fan uh you were uh we did a hostage
rescue we did yeah and you what were you
the were you the assault lead on that
one so I I wore a couple different hats
on this this was an interesting one for
me um so backing up for the last two
platoon all the direct action missions
that we had done Chris was the point man
and you know I I don't recall Chris
talking much about in his book you know
what he did behind the scenes um just to
kind of deviate here for a second
because I think it's worth telling is uh
he was a tremendous like Navigator and
planner and not just in like routes to
Target but I mean you know like Mobility
navigation so like out of all the
convoys and missions that we did on the
most treacherous roads in Iraq never got
hit by an ID and I give Chris a lot of
credit for the Deep Mission planning he
was doing in developing routes and
finding the best ways to get us in and
out um and yeah great great Point man
you aside from all the stuff he did as a
sniper and everything else he did um but
this was the first mission so when we
did Das generally Chris and I were like
Inseparable as part of that point
element heading up to the assault we got
the mission you being breach team and
him being like Point man yeah
Inseparable
um and for this mission in particular it
was a short notice time sensitive
Mission we didn't have much time to plan
or to think on it and uh I don't recall
exactly why but we we broke up uh there
was an OverWatch contingent I know why I
know why because there was a tall
building that had a great vantage point
over the Target and the target we had
Intel that there was like a Machine Gun
Nest and there was
IEDs around it and so in order to
mitigate that we didn't want to just hit
the target cold we wanted to get eyes on
Beyond we we know we obviously we tried
to get aircraft but we wanted to get our
that was something I was always into I
was always into like whatever we could
whatever I could do with us organic I
wanted to do and so in this particular
one there was a building which we
weren't supposed to go into by the way
but there was a building that was like
perfect OverWatch to look at the Target
area is that like a university or
something it was in the University so
there was this there was an area called
the Alomar University that we weren't
supposed to go into and you know
sometimes you got to make a decision
where you're going to bend the rules a
little bit this is one of those times I
made a decision like yeah we're going to
bend the rules there's it it's literally
the perfect OverWatch for this target
building where there was a hostage where
there was reports of IDs in the
courtyard and and heavy machine gun in
in position in this building so before
we hit this thing I was like we need to
look and see what we need to have our
own eyes on and once the assault starts
we need to have OverWatch as it's going
down in case there is a machine gun or
somewhere there so that's why that
little split took place now that now
that you're bringing it up sounds like
the worst environment imaginable and
like going back to the little vignetta
you know talking about going over uh you
know invading Iraq you know that was
like another moment there because I
ended up being pointman for my first
time ever on that op so it's pointman
slash
breacher um going into what I thought
was the worst environment imaginable um
ended up not being that bad um but yeah
that was that was one of those ones you
know especially now father to a couple
of kids um pretty cool man pretty cool
that we did that I'm glad it went it
went smooth we got to Target um and you
know it always shocked
me you know I mean we we stormed that
entire house made it to the roof before
they even woke up so a shot wasn't fired
um you know did what we had to do um got
the guys wrapped them up you know saved
the kid and uh yeah that that was pretty
cool one yeah I I think I was staged by
the OverWatch which was only like a 100
yards away but as the assaults going
down I whatever grab a couple guys and I
go to get to the breach point of the
assault and you know 48 seconds goes by
or something and the get the target
target secure and then like Le call like
Joo Le and I'm like go and he's like
jackpot meaning we just got the hostage
and at this point man I mean this was
you're always suspect of Intel anyways
but I was like I think I was like
jackpot he jackpot I was like Roger that
like freaking hell hell yeah let's go
and sure enough like you said we we got
the it was like a 15 or 16year old kid
that had been kidnapped from fujia and
then taken into this Safe House enemy
safe house in raar body and so yeah that
was a that was pretty good yeah if I
recall was he like uh you know like the
provincial leader son or something like
that yeah I want to say it was like the
provincial police chief's son or
something like this so he was his
parents were some kind of um some kind
of political official and that's why
they took him but yeah and I I I may or
may not have said or navy SS we're here
to get you out yeah and if he would have
spoken English he may have been
impressed with that line but also
interesting Le pointed this out to me uh
a couple years later the people that we
captured went on trial and they had to
have testimony from the assault team
that captured them and so the assault
the the people that were were testified
was you and Leif and you and Leif
obviously you couldn't use your real
names because then the enemy might you
know find out who you are so you guys
testified via VTC a couple years later
as Lieutenant Ray Tango and petty
officer second class Gabriel cash Tango
and cash Echo Charles you that Tango and
Gabriel
cash oh good times you know those are
just a little ways to kind of get back
you know yep you got to get them back
got to get them back uh but the op Tempo
there clearly I mean it was really high
we almost you know we had guys in the
field all the time um you and your team
and the other elements we just had guys
going out all the time the obviously the
the fighting was really heavy
uh we we talk about like when I got back
and I was talking to one of the uh prior
enlisted Captain over at warcom who is a
machine gunner seal machine gunner in
Vietnam and I'm kind of debriefing with
him and and you know for us we always
held the we always thought the guys in
Vietnam were just like constant
combat and I was talking to him and he
said you know I was like
well like how many when you were
deployed like how many guns gun fights
did you get in and he was like I forget
the exact numbers but he was like six
and I was like okay and I mean that was
like three days in ratti and um and I
was like oh did you did you how often
did you run out of ammo and he's like I
never ran out of ammo and I was like oh
and we had guys go Winchester on the
pigs a decent amount like not a regular
occurrence but more often than you'd
think for sure and you know guys were
were too eager to throw that box of ammo
whenever we got in a gunfight try try to
get that weight yeah yeah yeah cuz guys
were carrying extra rounds and then you
know we're getting a gunfight you just
see boxers getting peppered at your back
and what was your how much did you carry
on your person 500 yeah I man my first
Splatoon I'm not even you it
was a thousand rounds and it was like
weaved in my kit it was ridiculous I
couldn't even move but uh no we we got
down you
know doing a couple of uh deployments
and then the SOP kind of changed a
little bit because you have to be mobile
enough you got to you know we're hopping
over walls we're running gunning um so
that was usually
it
um you end up that that uh citation that
I read in the beginning
was you got you got hitting the leg with
shrapnel um you end up getting
metac uh that was Tony's birthday by the
way yes BTF Tony's happy birthday was
big gunfight that's probably that's I
guarantee that's the best birthday
Tony's ever had that's probably like his
50th birthday yeah he was either he was
either 50 or 21 or like or like 742 and
he's a vampire and he just like lives
War to
War uh you end up it didn't look bad
like I remember looking at your knee and
I was like it doesn't look too bad but
it was not good um it was worse than it
looked I should say so you end up
getting Medevac and sent to Germany I
got an email here oh Sunday July
23rd 2006 Leif hey man I talked to Joo
yesterday gave him the lowdown I'll
repeat myself as usual for you sir they
were unable to find that tiny
with the orthos scopy orthos scopy
apparently the shrapnel was on eane from
the scop so naturally they ripped open
the rest of the knee set up an L Ambush
and eventually found the little son of a
it was pretty not good sounds like
it's going to be a little more recovery
time than anticipated I've talked to the
docs here and my basic plan is to hang
out here for a few more days then go to
unit 2 for a few weeks to a month or
however long it takes to be good enough
to walk around and then get flown back
to you guys I don't know if I'll be good
enough to Op with you guys but at the
very least I'd like to come back and
help out any way I can even if that
means means being a talk
I'm figuring I'll know a little
bit more in the next couple weeks well
just know on the bright side I'm in a
hospital bed sweating my ass off being
bit by mosquitoes constipated and I'm
pissing on myself on a regular basis and
luckily they are underfeeding me with
shitty food as
well now I think I'll go back and lie
about my pain so I can get a morphine
perette cocktail relax and itch my full
body rash hate hate hate Bob I I'm blown
away that you have that uh W had it Le
had it oh my God that's that's wild that
was that was a wild time man um you know
getting back to it it was a weird you
know some shrapnel that found itself
right in the middle of my knee and it
was hard to get to and I remember uh we
had a
conversation you know they weren't
forcing me to go it this was like a
decision
like do what you want if you leave it in
there it's going to tear up the inside
your knee if you want that to happen um
but I I had a decision to make and that
was kind of a tough one I didn't want to
leave the guys I mean when you're in it
like that and you're going through all
that the last thing you want to do
is leave the guys and you know we talked
about working to be dependable and being
one of those guys that are relied on um
so to get pulled out like that it just
sucked and you know they were telling me
they were hopeful they thought they were
going to be able to get in into it with
a scope which is really easy throw a
scope in there pull it out and they
weren't able to do that so it just got a
little bit more invasive but um I don't
think I've shared this with anyone that
kind of like how those couple days went
um I ended up I I caught a flight to uh
I think it's a chopper to
bad and then I took a uh c17 Medevac
plane which was wild yeah um I mean
if no one's fortunate to be on on
something like that if it's pretty
gnarly you know basically that whole 17
was filled with Wounded guys that were
they had stretchers stacked like four
high all the way across so um to walk on
ambulatory with a backpack you know just
kind of kind of hit me there and then
had the surgery um you know was uh
rehabbing got got out of that uh that
awful I man just that that email I'm
gonna have to get a copy of that it
takes it takes me back um but yeah had
had some uh some Team guys there that
were was that was that in balad or was
that was that email sent from balad July
23rd or was that sent from Germany no
that was from Germany okay yeah that
that was post surgery there so I I was
in uh in the the hospital there that's
where they sent all the casualties there
and uh recuperating they kept me in the
hospital a couple days and then um they
gave me an allowance to go get some
clothes because a lot of people that go
I mean they're like coming off the
battlefield and they not like hey go
pack a suitcase um and I I went and
grabbed some clothes before uh they were
sending me to the to the debt over there
and I remember just kind of a funny
little note is uh they didn't have
anything at the exchange so I just got
like some shitty clothes and I looked
just like you know the the dudes in pul
faction you fence and uh you see Santa
Barbara I mean just like a dork walking
around German you know rehab next two
weeks there but uh yeah it was tough
tough being away from from the guys and
not knowing what's going on and um and
then I got the call from from Jeremy on
on August 2nd you know that Mark was
killed and uh bigles had been hit hard
and was uh was in route to to Germany in
fact the same hospital that um you know
I I'd left at that point I'd been out of
the platoon for uh two weeks um just
over two weeks so I mean kind of a
blessing in disguise to to be there and
to and to see see Ryan and and to be
there for him you know although you know
I don't know how cognizant he was he was
in a really really bad spot and uh to be
honest with you it was it was hard to
see him like that like like really tough
uh but you know I I also got to be the L
on to his family there which I know was
was meaningful to them to hear a voice
someone who knew them um you know
provide a little bit of comfort there
and so hung out with him for a little
bit and then he got shipped to was he
still in a a coma like medically induced
coma at that point no he was uh he was
awake though heavily heavily sedated and
making you know I mean just I I I have
him giggling a little bit the best that
he could kind of giggle but you know he
had hoses and all sorts of stuff and he
just looked bad you know and definitely
not not how I saw him last so one of the
uh it was tough you know being not not
being there with the guys during that
event is just one of those things I
don't share with the platoon and you
know I I don't say that lightly um you
know because there's pros and cons to
that obviously I I wasn't wasn't there
you know wasn't able to help uh all that
stuff but on the side I'm thankful I
didn't get to I I didn't have to see
that I got another email from
you um this is August 9th
2006 Leif today is Wednesday and we will
be on a flight with Mark out of
Philadelphia to San Diego we'll get back
at about 8 o'cl tonight and transfer him
to Greenwood
Mortuary sorry about the lack of updates
connectivity has been bad and we've been
on the road a lot trying to get down to
see Ryan in
Bethesda I will call I will try to call
when I can to get through and talk to
you guys about what I know Ryan is
getting better bit by bit he's sitting
up he knows where he
is
and he manages to speak to us when we
are there I'll be it
slowly it's kind of like he's really
drunk from his medication his girlfriend
Kelly has been by his side pretty much
Non-Stop and his family has been there
for him too every Admiral in Spec war is
coming to see him when Dober Biff and I
went to see him we managed to make him
laugh a bit and he gave us a good Tu
Bruiser fist pound his spirits are up
generally
speaking his left eye is a huge question
they ask us every time we are there if
he could see out of it right after he
got shot and I can't really
answer that question I know the doctors
are anxious to talk to Johnny Kim the
bottom line is that sometimes he can see
light when they flash it into his left
eyelid and other times not
the current prognosis is not narrow he
may have allnone or partial Vision in
his left eye and is going to be crucial
in these next few days to find out for
his sake Mark still doesn't know about
his right eye and he still doesn't know
about Mark just yesterday he found out
he wasn't still in Iraq his dad is going
to take the burden and tell him all
these things as soon as he isn't so
heavily sedated and they are hoping to
tell him that his left eye is okay
everyone is expecting him to be pretty
upset understandably and his dad has
already been asking us if there will be
a place for Ryan in Spec War if he only
has the use of one eye one of the
captains from warcom here told him
absolutely they will find
something hopefully that will help ease
the burden when he hears all the bad
news at the same time as much as you can
imagine or as as you can imagine the
family is pretty upset but they are
grateful for all the support there's a
guy here Chris from group 2 medical he
is a frogman who has been by their side
throughout he has a pretty good point of
contact for you guys if you want the no
situation he is also going to
escort Mrs Job out to Mark's funeral he
is great and has really been taken care
of Ryan's family that is about it for
for what we know as for Mark you guys
know about as much as we do the memorial
will and all will be on Saturday good to
hear the updated version of the video
Nick made was sent we have a ton of
Mark's pictures already and we'll put
something together for the family we are
flying out of out at 5 East Coast time
and get to San Diego at 8 we'll make
sure to get picks and whatever is handed
out at the funeral for all of you guys
Bob
God man just took me back there
I I don't know where I I'm
surprised Le had these these emails um
yeah that was a heavy time man yeah yeah
it's um it's really strange that like
these emails I mean you they just get
saved you know these are these are like
civilian emails that you know you are
going back and forth with Leif and like
I have I have have emails that I sent to
my wife and it's very interesting
because they're all like they they don't
say anything like I know everything
that's going on and I'm like hey how are
you and it's very strange to see it
um
yeah so you ended up flying home with
Mark did you fly home with Mark all I
wasn't in the
uh they call that the hero flight yeah
is that what that's called Angel Flight
Angel sorry um no I wasn't on that I I
flew flew
separately um the uh other guys that
that went you know left country were the
ACT escorts yeah because we sent home
three guys did we send three guys home I
think we sent three guys home
um and then
like you know going to the service that
just had to
be yeah so crazy for you it it was man
it's
uh how everything went down you know um
you know I left then this happened and
then we're flying back it was it was a
whirlwind of like every emotion you
could possibly be feeling and then on
top of that um you know the other guys
spoke at the service I I didn't speak at
the service and I I wasn't capable of it
to be honest with you um so the guys did
a really good job but you know I was
kind of sitting in the back during
during the service it was it was
weird yeah yeah whole that whole
time and then we we buried Mark
um and
then the other guys I think they went
back pretty quickly they went back
pretty quick and and I hung out and one
of the
things my situation uh I was trying to
stay in in Germany um because we had
kind of felt that was my path back yeah
like closer yeah yeah yeah yeah like if
we're out in Germany there's a chance
getting back I want to get back and then
I got to San Diego and they don't they
didn't want me to get to go back so the
you know doctors wanted me to heal and
then I think the command yeah I mean
they just want to send didn't want to
send me back um it was a tough time and
and I I wrestle with it and you know
like that first email you know makes it
sound like I'm super gungho and it's the
the reality is is all the goes down
it's like a month something has passed
no one wants me to go back like you know
those kind of demons on my shoulder like
it man you know just hang back
we're we're creeping in but I just had
this like overwhelming sense of guilt um
you know and and knew I had to get back
out to the boys and and felt in maybe
some way that that was like maybe um I
don't know some sort of gift that I
could give them you know some some sort
of positive thing um not replacing
anything anything like that but just
something positive to bring the platoon
that had gone through so much
um and and I found my way back so uh
thank you guys for for making that
happen that was you know I I mentioned
it prior but you know your life there's
just these kind of micro decisions and
moments that kind of Define you I think
in in little ways and uh I would have
regretted not going back I I my entire
life I would have regretted that yeah
well it's a representation like when KO
got wounded he he was like in Charlie
Med telling me like please let me stay
freaking bigles blind like talking to
him like I can I come back and you know
you were in a situation where you you
could come back and you did you know
which is freaking
outstanding um and you know I remember
there was definitely resistance there
was definitely resistance from like and
probably for the right reasons I get it
you know nssw trying to take care of the
force and everything like that but man
it was it was freaking good when you
came back I mean it was freaking good
for everything yeah it it was good for
me and uh everything had changed I mean
that that's like I said that is a moment
in time um all the that I'd been
through with Charlie platoon everything
um the most meaningful moments
I wasn't there you know so that's that's
the kind of Gap in that kind of uh
history there but I I got to go back and
uh help the platoon and and the troop
heal and and we went back to work yeah
you know yeah we went back to work that
was it man and that was
um what we owed to those guys and so
what we do man we're a frog man
um and then I mean obviously you know we
we weren't done losing guys yet um cuz
we had we had Mikey get killed yeah uh
which was another
nightmare
um and you know we we had a lot of guys
get wounded too you know I guess Co
being the worst of the guys that got
wounded um a lot of guys got fragged a
lot of guys got you know took a hit here
um pretty
much you and C were the only ones that
had to leave right anyone
else uh no no that was it yeah and mine
was yeah I caught the million dollar
wound I mean yeah other than obviously
when when Mikey died you know Mike Doug
they they were they were jacked up and
they got
caked it was the end of deployment so it
you know it's like uh kind of their
their redeployment it was almost there
it was maybe a few days early um and so
what were you thinking when you came
home from that
deployment man I I felt like
uh I felt like I I'd seen kind of
everything that I needed to see and
gotten out the teams that's kind of how
I was feeling I was you know three
platoon
deep uh I mean certainly was in the
that entire deployment and I was just a
little bit kind of kind of tired and
burned and I I had had a plan I never I
never planed to do a career in the teams
I mean I I was like I got pulled Kicking
and Screaming every reenlistment
contract in like three-year intervals
until finally it's like hey dude just do
it you know um I was planning on getting
out so I actually got I had orders to
trade at um and those got switched over
to
buds so I ended up going over to Buds
and uh the intent was
to finish school to go back and and uh
get my degree and then to get out and go
go work for my mom who had like a
uh a leasing business essentially so
that was that was kind of the thought um
I I had a loose plan going into it uh
and yeah you know I just I I also felt
um extremely
grateful to come back in one piece from
from that deployment and definitely for
a couple years you know whenever you've
been through something like
that you realize how inconsequential
like all this other that we
stress and worry about and all these
other things how they just don't matter
you know and that's kind of freeing a
little bit uh it doesn't last forever
though and then you get caught up in
life and all the other but I I
do remember um yeah I I lived it up I I
had a lot of fun as a buzz instructor
you know what where did you work at buds
I ended up being uh the prease it's gone
by different names
um prebs fourth phase whatever the
initial guys are showing up there yep
yep um did that
and went to school uh joined a dodgeball
League uh played played with Leif hell
yeah down down in down in OB uh and and
we were just crushing souls in Ocean
Beach man with these poor poor hippies
who didn't have uh health insurance and
just bashing faces and
uh Jack did you as you're as you're at
buds now seen it from the other side did
you work hell weeks yeah what was that
like like what did you learn from
that uh man I
remember it I mean first of all seeing
behind the scenes is is really really
neat to kind of Go full circle and to
see that that other side but um you know
I learned being at Buds and and in hwi
that you don't know like what guys are
actually going to make it through and I
remember a couple times being surprised
in uh uh Chuck Kean was actually one of
the guys I I remember put through put
through training and uh in hell week he
was
emaciated I mean I I don't know like
couldn't hold down his food maybe or
something like that I don't know if he
was sick or had pneumonia or something
but like he lost a lot of weight and was
gone and just seeing guys like that
power through it's like yeah man
this is teams teams is great this is the
best organization in the world so you
know being able to see that and uh it
was fun man it was good and and to be a
part of people's history like if you
remember all of your instructors yeah
and hold them to high regard whether
they deserve that or not you know that
uh that impression that that you get
from those instructors it lasts a
lifetime and I still remember my
instructors that way so um it was really
cool later in my career to run into guys
a decade later and like hey you put me
through buds do you remember this and to
hear all the funny stupid that I
said and uh it's good man and and and
and sometimes you know I me guys come
back like hey I I remember you telling
the story or doing this man it's just
like it feels good it's cool I I never
worked at Buds and so I now I kind of
like would like to go and work at buds
right now just to kind of see what it's
like but it was always kind of like oh
no I'm in the teams dude I'm not going
to go back to buds why would I do that
but I think you'd learn a lot and or
just not not even learn a lot but or yes
learn a lot but also just interesting to
see like I was talking to Andy stump
and he was talking about like he he was
in second phase and did pool comp and he
he has like all these little things that
he can tell you about oh when he'd see a
guy's like hands to a certain position
he's like oh this guy's about to go like
he's about to bolt to the surface oh if
he doesn't bolt to the surface his hands
do that and he doesn't Bolt the surface
oh that means he's about to like
freaking pass out or he just had all
this knowledge about like watching
people in really stressful situations
and how they react and it's just I mean
you must have seen that in hell week
you're like oh this guy's about to break
and you can decide like well if I say
this to him probably going to get to the
next Evolution if I say that to him he's
about to ring the bell well yeah that's
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get people you know to quit
essentially you're trying to create that
environment that people reach that
moment of Despair and either Charlie
Mike through or they quit I mean that's
that's what that's what the selection
program is trying to do
um and people say like my my son's going
to buds do you have any advice for or
like I'm going I'm going to buds do you
have any advice for I was like yeah
don't quit that's the freaking advice
don't quit yeah train train prepare
yourself and don't quit yeah don't quit
yeah there's there is no magic sauce no
don't quit that's magic yeah don't quit
could
be
um so now you're you're you're saying
you were planning to get out I was yeah
so uh I had a three-year tour uh set at
Buds and uh yeah I'm supposed to get out
and I think 2009 or 10 um and then the
market tanked for one there were some
contributing factors and then uh more
importantly Leif recruited me to stay in
hell yeah um he was going back to he was
the opso I believe the opso at team one
one yeah and he was uh fleeing up to be
the EXO and and and this was his pitch
is H hey man you know come back I'm
gonna pair you with Jeremy you do a
platoon together um and that's exactly
what he did he I that's a solid pitch
it's a solid pitch and I was like you
know what this whole getting out thing
the economy tanking you know what's
another couple more years um and that
was also my opportunity to
do a lead a leadership tour a true like
leadership tour um as a leading petty
officer so uh got pulled over there
actually I left uh I started kind of
doing like a mini workup once I knew I
was like going to the team I'm like all
right you know cuz you don't go to buds
to get sharp for seal
um so I started kind of doing doing
some uh kind of workup stuff jumped on a
couple trips and then I wanted
to you know I I wanted to get the buds
stink off me a little bit so I found my
way uh snuck on team one's deployment
they were deploying in 2009 um as just a
strap hanger basically and I did did a
couple months uh went out to Afghanistan
um didn't do anything out there to be
honest with you but uh you know it gave
me a chance to kind of get out there and
and get away from buds a little bit
interact with the team that I was going
to be working at and then uh yeah Jeremy
and I linked up and and we we did a pump
bro that's freaking ridiculous I mean
yeah that's just awesome doing a doing a
deployment with you're the lpo and your
your best friends the freaking platoon
Chief yeah and I was in all I was in all
of Jeremy's platoon so damn dude pretty
cool it's freaking impressive um and now
your guys are just kicking ass because
normally there's like this whole period
the platoon has to go through where
everyone got to get to know each other
the leadership's got to learn to work
together and they're having their little
e but you guys just roll right in 100%
not to mention all your Sops you're like
hey this is what we're doing this is how
we're doing it that must have been
ridiculous yeah it it was great man I
mean there was no no conflict at all
between Jeremy and I and you know we we
rock and rolled and it it made us a
strong platoon uh you know we had a
great OIC good good group of dudes and
yeah man I it it went really well and in
really neat and you know I'll take
working with people that I know
especially good people you know we go
back to the old two two birds in the
bush one one in the hand thing what is
it five birds in a bush and one in the
three in the hands what is it every day
of the week so we we were set up for for
Success uh you know had a good workup
got a little bit weird around
deployment just because uh of world
events and some some changing things but
we were supposed to deploy we did our
whole workup
um you know thinking we were deploying
to Afghanistan so Afghanistan was
heating back up um this was an area that
uh I was excited to go operate in you
know I mean just
auster um so I was really pumped to get
get a chance to go there um The Troop we
were in um some of the guys had been
there prior
so um but it didn't it didn't work out
that way we ended up for whatever reason
there was a delay in our deployment they
swapped around
happens um and we didn't Deploy on
schedule in fact it was like several
months later so bags bags were packed
and um this is actually when I was
introduced to to golf who introduced you
to golf besides Navy Seals the movie do
you need anything else
right so I was there a guy in the
platoon or something that was in there
you know the uh I I don't remember
exactly who it was but our our bags were
packed like the ioes were packed we were
ready to deploy I mean that that's where
we were workup was done you're deploying
and then I guess we were waiting on a
deployment order and it it was like it's
okay we're deploying on Monday and then
we show up on Monday it's like no you
know wait 72 hours and then that just
kept going and going and going um so our
backs were packed it's like what else
are we going to do someone recommended
that we go play golf I I don't remember
whose idea was and I don't really think
I gave a but uh once I got out
there man got hooked it got you huh it
got me I mean that that round it got me
I think I hit one one ball I was like
damn that felt good that felt good where
did you play North Island yeah yeah
that's a nice place to play I mean I
guess right I'm not a golfer but it
seems like a nice place to play you're
in Coronado yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
good so you got your little uh
introduction to golf how like did you
get did you go out and buy clubs and
stuff I went and I got uh I went to like
a a golf store and I got used clubs yeah
like that same night I think I went yeah
I I went out I got some junk clubs and
then just started started whacking
around now we obviously had a pending
deployment so uh you know I think we
actually went to they had like a couple
of uh charity things that we went to
went to a couple golf events actually
the platoon went
um and I actually we ended up deploying
we deployed to Iraq and I brought my
golf clubs damn dude yeah golf is a
thing it's something I never talk golf
is the thing in the teams for like
certain Team guys they just look there's
Team guys that are in archery there's
Team guys that are in Jiu-Jitsu there's
Team guys that are into uh skydiving
there's Team guys that are into golf and
and motorcycles like there's little
clicks of guys but golf is absolutely on
the list actually I got a friend that
was a older guy not quite a Vietnam guy
but like a little bit after Vietnam but
he tells this story his his wife um like
whatever a after 13 years or something
he comes home from work and like his
is sitting outside in the yard and
she says I hate the teams I hate Golf
and I hate
you that was it bro getting divorced but
that's like a team guy thing right like
oh what do you care about the teams and
then Golf and for me it's like oh the
teams and Jiu-Jitsu and some guys like
the teams and motorcycles so they put
all their money into motorcycles or golf
or whatever and that's what they're
doing all the time um and it's but but
golf is definitely one of the things
like there's guys that surf in the teams
what else what are other little Hobbies
surfing jiujitsu these are jumping golf
is in there man for some reason golf is
in there but like spear fishing um I'll
tell you why man because the more you
get into it it's hard and I say this
with a grain of salt like a huge one is
like all right how how hard is golf it's
challenging it's a mental game though it
it's a mental game I mean there's a
physical component there's a lot of
strategy to it I mean there's a lot of
going on in that golf swing that
has to happen you know all within a
split second and it's frustrating and to
be a frog man or some type a dude who
thinks that he can conquer the world and
then you're hovering over this ball and
you can't make it do what it should do
it doesn't seem right and that that's it
like that that's what got me is like
this man was anyone when you went
for the first time was anyone good at it
uh there there were a couple guys in the
platoon yeah and there's some
competition like oh that guy that guy
can hit the ball I can do that
sure uh that deployment you go to Iraq I
did and this is now this is now like
2010 2011 2012 11 2011 you're going on
deployment yeah so we were uh so Iraq is
kind of shutting down did you guys close
it down it is actually shutting down so
we had uh Jeremy and I and I don't know
I mean someone else can come out and be
like hey I had that distinction as well
but I mean we were the two guys that had
the distinction of starting and ending
like a war kind of because we were there
during the invasion and we were part of
the last element when they closed down
December whatever it was
2011 um made a nice little certificate
about it and and then did you guys leave
Iraq on that deployment like you
personally and Jeremy personally like
left Iraq and went somewhere else we
closed it down and we redeployed it
where so you went back to America yeah
yeah yeah so that was it and you were
the last troops that are like I mean
mission accomplished mission
accomplished what did you do anything
good on that deployment or was
everything kind of like winding down no
nothing sexy it it was winding down and
uh it was like Catch and Release so we
were grabbing Bad Dudes but because of
the inner squabbling and politics they
were getting released so
it's kind of like what are we doing
what's the point um kind of sucked but
we did have what was really neat was we
were the last show in town in terms of
soft um and again there may have been
another element or something out there
but pretty much the last show in town
and but all the assets were still there
so like all these great assets we had
everything that's sweet I mean all sorts
of overhead stuff like everything they
you everything we wanted for every
deployment we had at our disposal so
it's really neat to kind of run the
mission like that with having too much
um but yeah it was kind of
anti-climatic we we closed it
down and and head back and uh that was
it short deployment too and then you
roll right into another deployment did
you make Chief during that deployment I
did I I made Chief uh right before we
deployed so we ended up um I got I
actually got sent to Southern Iraq uh
for a month or two and had my own debt
so I was a chief had my own debt that
was a really neat feeling to like all
right I got my group and kind of like a
Prelude to being a platoon Chief MH uh
and then we we joined forces I think in
Baghdad um with the entire platoon and
then beat Feed and then yeah I I got
back and uh by that point the the
incoming
CMC just asked me hey do you want do you
want a spot and uh you don't turn down
spots hell no not for a platoon Chief no
but there was a caveat uhoh we were we
were reordering the team uh Iraq was
closed down and they were looking to get
back towards the uh Pacific with our
team in particular so that was the catch
like hey if you're standing in team
one this is what's happening do you want
in and I was like yeah man I'm in cool
platoon Chief how'd that feel felt great
I mean that that is uh for me that was
the Pinnacle you know when being in a
listed
seal you know that that was everything I
wanted to be was to to run your own
platoon and you feel like you know doing
all the platoon and workups and
deployments prior you feel prepared and
all those Lessons Learned and everything
I learned from Tony and my other Chiefs
and and Leif and and everyone else had
kind of prepared me for that moment so
it's it's just an awesome feeling to now
have this thing that is your own and I
say that I mean you have't OIC they
shared responsibility it's your platoon
but you know the the platoon Chief is
really running those platoon and has a
heavy amount of influence so to be able
to take all the lessons learned and kind
of Infuse that in that time um which is
awesome man in kind of the honor
honestly of my career of all the I
did one of the most rewarding things I
did you know even aside from the combat
stuff was to be able to to raise a
platoon and to do it the way that you
think is right um and had a great group
group of guys man we had a lot of fun we
made that uh you know it was challenging
managing expectations with guys that you
know didn't have a combat deployment we
had a lot of guys who didn't have a lot
of combat experience being told that
they're not going you know to the show
for this deployment so in terms of the
leadership challenge of getting people
on board with you know this new Mission
this new mission for us is to go here
and do this and and while that may not
be sexy like this other stuff it's
important and here's why and and going
through all that and uh and doing it
like in a genuine way that people
weren't like this guy's just selling out
and this is all everything we
do doesn't matter and and ultimately um
you know we we trained hard and we did
things the right way and we did all this
to be a good platoon which is what
you should be doing is training hard
making yourself better you know as an
operator as a platoon um so I think we
did well with that I was um talking to
to a guy that was in that platoon and uh
apparently you guys got a lot of um
Arnold on a lot of pumping iron and a
lot of a predator so you just kept the
you kept the theme going the action
theme going through the whole through
your whole career Yeah man so I again I
I've been a movie buff you know so every
time I could Infuse something into it uh
something we used to do is uh we would
roll out to training Evolutions playing
the theme song from predator
yeah what is that the d d what is that
one yeah what's the I'm GNA do it I know
it I don't want to do it either okay you
guys are weak yeah okay what it
was apparently you uh and I tried to get
a hold of this you're Charlie platoon
Manifesto which I'm sure we'll get I'll
get a hold of it at some point somebody
will have a copy of it but laying out
hey this is what a frogman is this is
what's expected of you guys uh from what
I understand that left a big mark on the
boys that that worked for you
yeah you kind of don't know what's
what's going to stick and you know it
was cool to see that thing still exist
and someone has a copy of it um but yeah
I did my best I I felt I felt obligated
everything that I had kind of seen and
learned and kind of where the teams were
kind of evolving and the different
experiences that guys were showing up
and you know the different experience
that I was kind of bring in I felt
obligated to to pass whatever I could
along um and you know you spend the
better part of 12 Years on the teams
you're going to see a lot of things done
poorly and you're going to see a lot of
things done well so um yeah you know I I
mean I was telling you nothing pills in
comparison to all the great stuff that
that you've written but um yeah I tried
to tried to leave a little little Mark
there and uh I tell you what man it's
just so cool now to see now that I've
moved on to see these guys leading
platoon and to being and to lead the
community um how that goes full circle
um it wasn't always easy man you know
but really really cool to to see that
happen yeah like they um I know you made
a patch for that what was your patch at
that you made for the team one what was
it uh you know the the Bravo one was uh
weird it was just kind of a hodge podge
um but the the Charlie patch that I well
I I won't say I and we although heavily
influenced by by the platoon Chief was
uh
PCB which is uh Elvis slang for taking
care of business in a Flash so we were
Charlie platoon so there was a big
emphasis on the CA and the patch and we
had the lightning bolt and uh yeah that
was us I forgot to do the whole Elvis
thing like in tasking a Bruiser we had
you guys got the freaking card because
you're an Elvis fan you got this
freaking cardboard cut out it was in the
it was in the like our our planning area
in ratti a freaking cardboard cut out of
Elvis the king made it to ratti but
he didn't make it back I I don't know
where he ended up unless someone has
been holding him hostage for 18 years
and you guys hit graceand in work up too
probably did that every I I was uh was I
I am a big Elvis fan especially like
late 70s or not yeah yeah mid mid late
70s where you know the the tempo just
he's going with it um yeah I I went to
graceand for three
workups went with with with Johnny and
some of the boys and Leif that last one
for sure fired up is that where you guys
got the is that when you got the the
cardboard cut out I that was probably
leif's doing yeah Leif was really good
about that but uh yeah I think Leif got
it check yeah um so you got this this uh
Manifesto going on um and then now this
is like 2012 you said that's this is
when your dad died right 2012 it is yeah
so uh my dad you know I told his story
uh a while ago but um you just suffered
from alcohol alcoholism his entire life
so that was that was his he carried a
lot of Burden abandonment loss of his
brother um he didn't pass that down to
me like in a way that was damaging to me
other than seeing him you know hurt
himself over that period but you know he
had a problem with alcohol um my entire
life and went into the teams um and he
tried
to tried to get sober like this is in
2004 a week before my second deployment
and you know not knowing what I know now
especially about coming off of uh
alcohol and and Other Drugs is you can't
just cold you can't quit cold turkey uh
and he gave himself a stroke so 2004
gave himself a stroke and was just like
from that point on from 2004 to uh 2008
he ended up uh divorcing his wife um it
just got bad you know so he he was just
and it wasn't even even there was booze
involved but he was heavily medicated
they didn't know what to do with him and
there was like a lot of 50150 um
over those years to where he was getting
getting picked up on the street you know
just just suffering man so me uh
2012 uh basically his his organs gave
out and winded up in in the hospital and
they were keeping him you know on life
support so I was in workup when that
happened and pulled myself out uh went
home and you know my brother and I I
mean basically pulled the plug on my dad
and and
then you know a couple days later did a
celebration life for him and then I went
right back to plon so like not much of a
a Break um or time to wallow for
that uh you know my my dad and I we we
left on on good terms uh you know I mean
he was he he was a loving dad dad did
did a lot of great things right like
raised me right in a lot of ways I get
all my manners you know from him those
good old Texas manners uh taught me how
to fish uh
shoot um you know so obviously uh losing
anyone's tough losing your dad is tough
and that that was a rough time man you
know it
was that that period that year um it
just the hits kept coming uh you know
there there was a bright bright spot my
my second kid was born 6 months after I
lost my dad so yeah that that was great
um but then just three months after that
you know Chris was
murdered um where were you when you
heard about
that uh we were in workup we were just
in San Diego um I I don't recall
uh you know what it was a former
platoon mate that uh that called me me I
I was in town uh you know hit us with
the news and then we assembled and uh
you know went went to
Texas yeah that was I
mean yeah just just a freaking nightmare
um yeah it was it was a rough time man I
I I had a rough year there and uh you
know aside from the tragedy uh you know
of those events as well the stress of
being a platoon
leader um you know we had a pending
deployment all
that uh jacked up my back big time like
this was like you
know wasn't anything like I I I broke
bones or or anything like that but it
was it was extremely
painful um right before deployment and a
broken bone sometime would be better
it's like just freaking break the bone
the the weird like muscular freaking
soft tissue yeah that stuff and
like if you talking your buddy and
you're like oh yeah I have a broken
vertebrae they're like oh okay cool like
I get it like you can we accept your
excuse when you're like well my back
kind of hurt it's like the worst right
my back floor and it feels weird you
know like just it's the worst yeah I I
was walking around I mean with wraps and
all this stupid stuff and doing
everything I could to relieve that I you
know I deployed
and luckily we weren't in a doing a
combat deployment so a lot of training
though um but yeah you know just just
kind of a weird rough time just trying
to keep my together you know and
and not let that impact the uh the
platoon I mean especially this is like
my
chance to to lead a platoon and you know
not to muff it up so um but luckily had
a great group of guys and uh they made
it really easy so what was it like with
Chris
um like kind of this
whole image of Chris from the outside
world and then you know us guys knowing
him and and then like you who' like
obviously did multiple deployments with
him and um man it was like what was your
perspective when you saw like the world
watching Chris and reacting and like I
didn't know this but uh I think American
Sniper is the most popular military
movie of all time like beats Saving
Private Ryan beats platoon like it's yep
it's the most popular I don't know maybe
Top Gun has got it now but it like what
did it look like for
you like didn't didn't we we all I don't
know if you were at this they had like a
screening of the movie in Coronado for
us and we all went to it and it was
really like weird it it was weird man
and you know there's some uh structural
issues when you're trying to fit
someone's life into yeah yeah for sure a
two-hour block you know so you know
trying to make sense of all
right okay what what is this but yeah I
mean I was glad to see you know Chris
Chris had a reputation I mean the stuff
he did in fuia
was you know kind of it was just
legendary man you know I mean that
that's that's what uh that's where he
got the name or you know in that time
frame but um he did a lot of great
man and you
know took care of business down there
and to see him get the credit for it and
and tell the story and kind of the full
full cycle kind of the you know
Redemption aspect ECT of him going
through all that like I I told you
when I was done with my third platoon I
I was mentally smoked right I I need to
take a break Chris stuck around and hit
another yeah into solder City by the way
into solder City had another tough
deployment um so he was got shot got
shot in the helmet did you hear that you
probably knew I mean he got shot in the
helmet like yeah in yeah so he
volunteered for the hardest Duty I mean
was in
fuia that uh that second pump when
weren't even in Iraq so I mean he
constantly volunteered for the hardest
Duty put himself in the front lines and
um yeah I I felt I'm glad he was
recognized for that and uh I'm glad you
know the story was
told um of him kind of going full circle
and you know I didn't keep in great
touch with him whenever he got out and I
did reach out like when the book was
coming out and you know just like
reconnecting with him a little bit but
he did he did reply back to me and it
just was uh super glad that he left when
he did and like super thankful and
grateful that he got to be Daddy I I
remember I I was actually looking
through some old stuff and you know came
across a note there that uh that was one
of the things that he really appreciated
was you know getting out of that and
being being a being a father you know
yeah yeah and then I mean obviously
Bagels when when bigles died which again
it was like what was hard about those
guys it was like we were home you know
and like we all think oh yeah like like
you said it's not supposed to happen
yeah it's not supposed to happen and
um freaking just terrible and you know
the the the movie I remember we went to
see the movie and you're just like you
don't really know what to expect and
it's just kind of overwhelming to see
this movie and just and you know the
like you like you pointed out and what
I've come to realize what you pointed
out is like they had to take a guy's
life his whole life um four deployments
four combat deployments his wife and
family his growing up family his mom
they had to take that whole thing and
put it into an hour and a
half like that's that's that's an
impossible task and so you got to kind
of look at it from a different frame of
mind and I think what it did do is it it
did a great job of showing you know what
the stresses on the family what you know
T's wife had been through his kids and
like the fact that you said you know
like he was trying to you know he was
coming back he was going to move in that
direction and I think that's what they
look the combat stuff it is what it is
this the the way they make things look
in Iraq it kind of is what it is but to
tell the story of you know and it's not
just Chris's story it's the story of so
many guys that went on deployment and
their families that had to deal with
that and the
aftermath so um the only the other thing
that always kind of bums me out is is
like Chris being such a freaking wise
ass and being so funny and being like
just they just didn't capture that kind
of at all like they didn't really show
like dude this guy was funny as hell
like would be harassing people making
jokes prac the whole nine yards he was
not sulking or brooding I mean he was he
was a wise ass and salty as hell yeah
and and a cackling aggressive laugh that
like if somebody did something and he
was laughing it was like little darts
were hitting you know you could just you
hear that cackling freaking laugh so I
I'll give you just like a little tidbit
of Chris's you know mischievous nature
um he he used to like to poke me I mean
we were buddies we would often on uh
training trips when we had to share
rooms or whatever we'd share rooms so
we'd like do little pranks and stuff but
on our second deployment we were um in
Baghdad in like an abandoned building or
whatever
and in between Ops I mean it was
sleeping and lift like get super strong
and watch movies and you know and until
you have something to plan for whatever
MH and I I used to like my quiet time
and I was known to nap occasionally so I
I would nap and uh close my door I had
my own little
room and he did not want me napping you
know he he didn't think that was right
so what what he would do is he would
come he didn't think that was right he
he would doorbell ditch me he'd come and
like knock on my door and bang bang bang
and then you know I'd come out and he'd
get me all riled up and this went on for
like a couple months and I got like
really pissy about it and I actually
went to the extent to go get like you
know syruptitious camera equipment and
set up to to catch him I end up not not
catching him but uh yeah he's funny dude
great guy um yeah man he's
missed um and then that deployment as a
platoon Chief you got guys deploy kind
of a standard uh doing exercises and
stuff overseas um wasn't a combat
deployment this is probably
the maybe around the low point of combat
for the teams well I guess depends on
where you are but for you it was yeah
that your first non- combat deployment
it was and uh pretty impressive man I'll
tell you what was kind of neat I mean
the younger guys didn't like it right CU
and we all want to be in the but
it's easier to say you know when you
have a couple of combat deployments it's
like H you know I'm I'm I'm good um but
the guys that are eager who've never
done that whatever you know didn't
didn't take it so lightly but yeah I
kind of got that like '90s Frogman Pig
on deployment and got to see a lot of
the world I'd never seen and uh it was
blast man I mean I I really had some fun
and uh I mean honestly at the end of
that thing we had done so much training
like we were sharp oh man our CQC so
tight um yeah good good group of dudes
and uh uh good deployment different type
of deployment but but rewarding in
different ways and by the way you're
married this whole time when did you get
married so you married Beth your high
school sweetheart I did yeah I I married
uh yeah sorry don't don't want to forget
that no I know we're no Beth you are at
the top of our story but we had to cover
some other things yeah uhor so we ended
up uh you we broke up for a while
whenever I I went psycho pre- Navy and
then uh started dating again and after
my first platoon and then uh we got
married after after that ratti
deployment so 2007 check yeah right on
and and so she's she racked up a bunch
of deployments of deployments she earned
it and uh and then I I have two kids you
so one was born uh in 2009 and then the
other in 2012 yeah now after that
platoon Chief tour you decideed you're
going to do uh you're going to switch
over to Warren officer well it it kind
of uh the tour got extended they they
ended up uh kind of keeping us together
there was another reorg undoing what
they had already
done classic classic move um so they
kept us together we did we did like
another year and it was like kind of do
your own workup which is kind of fun and
then we did a another mini deployment to
paccom so it's like another yearh and
then um at the end of that it was clear
that I hadn't thought one second Beyond
being a platoon Chief this was like all
the way back in high school again like
no plan whatsoever um but thankfully you
know being around good people someone's
gonna have a good idea and one of those
people was Jeremy Jeremy had gone
warrant the year
prior and I was like you know I didn't
really think much of it until I was in
the position I'm like hey man what's
this a warrant deal I'm looking for I'm
looking for a change and at that point
of the career you know you have as an
enlisted dude you have a couple
different options um you know you can go
the senior enlisted route and or you
know you can do something like what I
did um and I just wanted to do something
different so I I thought I I
liked I liked that the Warren officer
career path was just a little bit
different and I thought would challenge
me in some different ways so I put it in
the package and um they must have been
low on candidates that year because I
got picked up so you get picked up for
Warren officer and and now you go to
Seal Team 3 um back to team three that
must have been kind of cool yeah yeah
that that was was really cool although
in a much I mean we talk about going
full circle too oh yeah you're being
being a helion to a company man you know
working working up in Ops and and with
the headquarters yeah and then you you
know you basically become the training
officer is that what's going on yeah so
we jumped on deployment pretty quick um
went back to Iraq so news flash if you
haven't been following the news for the
last decade we end up going back into
Iraq um and was kind of thrown to the
wolves in terms of like you know one day
you're
commissioned kind of no training and
then you're like right in the op shop so
I was
right right on the wrong side of the Ops
in Iraq um did that came back and then
was the the training officer for that
you know we did a full cycle got it at
at Team three and then where'd you go
the next time on deployment um we did a
went out to the Middle East a non
non-combat Zone um yeah kind are you
still into golf at this point yeah cuz
as a warrant officer you got a little
bit more a little bit more Flex time
yeah yeah yeah well it's almost like an
echo Charles type
schedule especially after we got back
from Iraq I found myself being in San
Diego like a lot having a lot of time so
yeah I I rammed up that was actually
when you know the golf had been in
Obsession kind of up that point but like
not in a mature way right just like
whenever I had time I'd go golf and uh
and honestly in that kind of 20 2012
2013 it got me through I think some kind
of tough stuff there but you know come
after that deployment Circa
26ish I had some time to actually
practice and uh lo and behold like would
you be shocked that when you practice at
something you actually like get better
way it works like man believable yeah
yeah I I didn't have to be losing all
these balls you know that often so not
not that I'm good I'm very far away from
good but I got a lot better I started
practicing and then it it just kind of
like you know build some momentum there
once you get a little bit better um you
want to get better and better and better
and so that really gave me like as I was
kind of griping you're dealing with this
challenge of being out of a platoon
which you know whether you leave the
Navy that way or it happens in your
career it's tough you know you spend an
entire career as this thing as an
operator whatever it may be and then
you're a company man I'm I'm working a
desk job I don't have the same buddies I
don't have those relationships you know
it's important to have something else if
that's jiujitsu working out um whatever
it is I I found golf so I just like went
into that and that gave me something
that I was constantly thinking about and
and working on I never really thought
about this even though I spent my adult
life in the sealed teams you were
talking about the fact that you were
home during workup and I was like oh
damn because I was always in a platoon
so the fact that I was like oh all those
people a bunch of those people up in the
head shet they weren't freaking doing
what what a platoon guy is doing platoon
guy's just going just like you're just
going and you I didn't I didn't even
recognize that until like I was thinking
about that I was like oh there's a bunch
of people that are just like going home
at night that's weird it's weird you
know and one thing I I didn't really
talk about but uh I was still dealing
with that back injury that that was part
of the reason I wanted to go warrant I
cuz I felt like I was never going to get
better got it I like this is it man you
know it's a did did you ever figure out
what the injury was it a specific thing
or was it like musculature it it was
musculature and some imbalances yeah I I
went like almost two years without any
pain relief and it was like gnarly man
so it's was like you know putting on
shoes hurt everything we did it was just
excruciating and if you've dealt with
back issues and there's a lot worse ones
to deal with but um yeah I just really
couldn't function with that but I went
in um after that second pump I did uh
second platoon Chief deal
I went in in kind of desperation to the
uh physical therapy and I'd been working
with people and no relief or whatever
and you know we're blessed that we have
in the community they hire like some
legit dude so guys that work for
professional sports teams whatever Jason
he was one of them check right on um not
not for that event but I I worked with
him before that but uh anyways I I went
back into this guy in desperation I'm
like dude figure this out please and
within an hour he had no figured it
out and he's like all right dude this is
an imbalance we're going to do this this
and this and you know my leg was sucked
up into my uh my hip and was creating
just all these kind of uh you know
contorsion of forces there that were
just so I mean he whatever he did
provided relief for the first time I had
in almost you know a year and a half or
whatever you have to go on some like
stretching protocol or something I did
yeah and I I did some things and I end
up uh strengthening some things and
doing some other stuff um and knock on
wood haven't had that I I've had a
couple of episodes but I got through I
got through that I didn't think I was
going to get through but I I actually
ended up getting in uh I dare I say for
me ridiculous shape when I was a warrant
like dude because you're you're not
getting hammered on the work the workup
is hard on you right like you're running
and gunning body armor hopping over
walls just up and down just getting beat
down there's like no rest shitty sleep
just like all shitty sleep shitty food
just freaking stress be down but now now
I have an opport to like chill out a
little bit and uh I got in great shape
and it it was good man yeah so you do a
couple tours at Team three and now
you're your your last I think your last
tour is at sqt yeah yep and what was
your job there I was the training
officer so just overseeing everything
that's it yeah I I mean essentially uh
was responsible for the curriculum and
execution of training so just making
sure that our guys were getting the
right type of training and that it was
being conducted you know the right way
so it was a it was a good challenge I
mean it every kind of job I had in the
teams was a new challenge outside of the
platoon for sure and these sqt guys are
getting freaking outstanding training oh
dude for sure com compared there's no
doubt compared to what I got going
through and then the guys before me like
did you go through St or through St yeah
yeah I mean everything has gotten more
professional Prof and better so these
guys are you know High Caliber
dudes when they show up to a team now
look you're still a new guy there's
still like a lot to learn but they're
starting their Baseline hey you yes you
you're still a new guy I don't care how
B you've been turned you're still a new
guy the Baseline the Baseline is so much
higher than than what it used to be y
yeah and then you at that point you're
like going to retire you decide to
retire
Yeah by this point so I was kicking in
scaming in terms of making it to 20
years I didn't want to do a career
really um but then eventually I was like
okay I'm going to do it commissioned as
a warrant I thought I'd do 25 years um
but I went to sqt and that was my real
first Shore Duty that I'd had you know
in bad decade and I just took a deep
breath I was like damn it's time
and I thought that was a great place to
end it on I I just thought it was like
kind of Full
Circle I just ran I lost steam that was
it so uh I made the decision to get out
um but yet again I found myself in a
position of like not knowing you know I
I didn't have anything set up so what
was your
plan
to buy myself some time yeah I ended up
getting into um you know I look around
whenever I struggle to know what to do I
looked to those around me that are doing
doing things and uh there were some guys
that were going um through a NBA program
up at UCLA uh executive NBA program um
so I was like yeah that's that's pretty
cool um you know maybe I'll go learn
about business all the different facets
of of business maybe that would be good
you know give me some skill sets to kind
of lean on get myself a good job um so I
thought I'd do that and that I ended up
getting into that my last year on active
duty and that was right around I mean
covid 2020 got weird so I I ended
up doing a year of school on active duty
um a lot of unknowns during Co during
during Co yeah so that was like probably
pretty nice I'm assuming because it was
like uh whatever virtual classroom or
whatever yeah it was easier I I didn't
enjoy it you know I wanted it to be up
in in person um I don't have a hard
enough time learning as it is you know
especially on a computer screen um but
yeah so you know I I went through that
program and uh halfway through ended up
retiring still had no idea of what I
wanted to do although I had taken an
entrepreneurship class and they had this
class that was kind of like a uh
exploratory class so you have a you have
an idea business idea something here's
your opportunity to test the concept for
kind of viability and just you know just
a semester's worth of research so I had
an idea um I actually had this kind of
epiphany during that period I mean I
just woke up on a Saturday and it's like
I'm gonna make at the time it was a a
Navy SEAL inspired golf bag so like
inspired by the kit that we wear
designed in a way um and I ended up kind
of drawing I I grew up drawing and and
doing stuff when I was a kid but ended
up drawing like for a whole weekend like
concept art
and tactical golf bags yeah yeah kind of
um I like it yeah yeah
yeah had a name had an idea and I was
like you know I don't know it wasn't
fully fleshed out but I had this
opportunity that next year this
entrepreneurship class I still didn't
know what I want to do at all I had no
clue whatsoever and I was like you know
let's let's maybe just pitch this and
let's see if there's something there um
had no idea what the market looked like
what the opportunity you know didn't
really know anything so I the one
prerequisite to be in the class is you
either had to join a team or create a
team so I ended up recruiting people I
didn't know the class that well we were
six months in so they had this kind of
like bio book and I was going through
and just looking for like anyone who had
hobby of
golf and uh actually the first guy I
came across Uh Kevin Lee was in the bio
book hobby golf I was like boom yeah
reached out to him and uh he's like hey
man yeah I'm in uh you know basically
been in kind of manufacturing my entire
career so I was like oh yeah great let's
do it so he was the first on the team
and then uh recruited some other folks
and we took that through a series of uh
multiple classes so it's kind of like a
you graduate from one you go you have a
option to go on to the next stage and we
started with one group that first class
and then moving into the second class we
had to like reform teams essentially so
Kevin stayed on um recruited some other
people had just a great team super
fortunate and and it just kind of built
some steam you know the more that we
kind of researched it and the more I
fleshed out the idea of what later would
be hulie and kind of where we are you
know we moved away from golf bags and uh
you know did this research and and
thought there was room to get into uh
the apparel side and all that and golf
apparel Golf Apparel and the company is
called hulie hulie golf yes sir I guess
it's just hulie but it's hulie yep it's
julig golf.com right it is the the
website is holig golf.com h l i e which
is named after the hulie tool yeah so as
a breacher that's one of the tools that
you carry sure you carry explosives you
might carry a sledgehammer and you might
carry a hulie tool which is taken from
the fire department who uses either a
hooligan tool or a Halligan tool right
yeah correct I I think uh I think we
talked about I know you and I talked
about but I I don't I think the hallagan
is the guy that originally invented this
tool which looks like a big ass weird
looking pry bar
basically and then people copied the
idea and but they couldn't use the same
name because they kind of copied the
idea so they changed they changed the
design a little bit but that also is a
very practical thing and that's what the
SEAL Teams that's all we ever said was
hulie tool yeah probably because we're
more holig ginish well yeah I think
there was a structural difference too in
that I think a heligan is a one piece
cast and hooligan is like has a bolt or
something that yeah it's like a three
piece like a three piece something like
that so yeah that that was uh you know
we did our name exploration I was going
through and I I just like the way it
sounded and there's a connection to my
background I thought that was kind of
cool and then loone behold I found out
that hulie is actually like an old
obscure Scottish golf term that means
blowing a strong wind so dang layers
layers layers call that layers yeah so
you know if you in Scotland and it's
blowing it's blowing a
hulie so yeah you know on once I knew
that I was like man all right we're on
it's meant to be and so you re when did
you retire so did you wait let me phrase
that did you have school finished by the
time you retired no so you re you
retired from the teams in July of 21 and
then how' that feel uh man if I'm being
honest like a wait with was lifted I
felt great yeah it you know especially
where I was I had been away from the
platoon for a while right the nucleus of
the team so like you're you're a company
man you're doing different stuff
rewarding important stuff but when I
retired I was like at trade at and so
like I was out with platoon all the time
I was like in a platoon I was basically
in nine platoon at a time I'd be out
with this and you're just like oh how
can I ever leave yeah and then I had to
clean out my cage and I was like oh
this is the wrong
move but after being a tu Commander
troop Commander yeah yeah I mean you're
just in different yeah company positions
essentially you know or executive
positions after that but uh yeah so uh
got out July retired July 21 and then
that program that I was in um I
graduated in June of 22 so yeah year and
a half ago some change and then by that
point uh I was all in man I you
know I I I looked at all the pros and
cons and basically came to the
conclusion that if you think you have a
good idea and you could can pull it off
and you don't I mean I'm just going to
regret that my entire life you know so
the uh there really was no other choice
but to proceed and obviously uh you know
we're a young company uh ended up
launching this last last April a lot of
stuff to figure out and being a small
company is precarious MH a lot of stuff
to figure out but uh it's extremely
rewarding and I found all these other
things that when I was looking
for what I wanted to
do you know
I one of the things that just to back up
here a little bit that I think it's
worth mentioning give these guys a call
out because they do great work but
there's an organization called the honor
Foundation um and what they do is they
help soft transition from the military
and you know it's a I don't remember how
long the program is but essentially
there is kind of like a uh exploration
period like a self- exloration period so
did you do that whole thing at the honor
Foundation I did yeah and you know I
kind of like didn't want to do it but
there were other guys that I respected
that we're doing it I'm like all right I
got to go do it I don't want to do all
this touchy Philly stuff and get in line
with my you know emotions and history
and blah blah blah and uh it ended up
being like one of the best things for me
because wait did you do all that that
stuff what is that stuff well the first
I think the first six weeks it's like
journaling and like like going through
your history and trying to like you know
decipher what makes you tick like here's
your history but why why is it like that
why did you do this why are you the way
you are why why did you choose this path
what drives you like those things like
why why are you waking up in the morning
so so you did ended up doing all that I
did and you got reward out of it you
learned something yeah yeah yeah I I did
I you know it didn't pop up when I was
in the program really like I I was they
they give you a coach and the coach is
supposed to kind of guide you through
the process and I was kind of is the
coach a civilian or a team guy civilian
okay civilian and uh you know they try
to align if you have some sort
of Industry you're trying to get into or
something like that they want to try to
align you and personalities and stuff
like that so they do the best they can
but uh had had a great great uh coach
there who was helping me guide through
some stuff and have these conversations
but you know looking back I could see he
was he was trying to pull teeth because
I wasn't being easy yeah I wasn't
converting very easily but what I got
from that program like really what it
did is it force me to look at my
priorities like what are the things that
I think make me tick um and these things
equal happiness right and that's that
that mix of you know what am I trying to
get out of my family life what am I
trying to get out of my work life and
like really what am I trying to get out
of work am I trying to make money am I
trying to be home a lot am I trying to
be My Own Boss uh I didn't have all
those answers but it it set the
precedent for me to be introspective and
to look at all that stuff I found it
very very helpful and it took some time
but when I started to get into the hulie
stuff I was like you know what man I
kind of like designing
and I kind of like building things
and I kind of like the challenge
of doing something that maybe the odds
are stacked against me um building a
brand uh these things are are kind of
scary like in a different way um risky
in a different way um yeah I just kind
of it it grew on me and then I was like
man maybe maybe I'm an
entrepreneur yeah I'd say you're
definitely an entrepreneur what what I
remember is like you were you initially
talked to me about this idea and you're
like well you know I'm golf my God I
don't I like golf come talk to me when
I'm 98 and I'm going to start playing
golf cuz I'm doing Jiu-Jitsu and I'm
freaking surfing and I'm playing guitar
and all this but you know but I was like
oh you're like hey I got this idea
because you're but I know I've known so
many Team guys that were so into golf
and then when you were telling me the
idea I was like well I also know there's
a whole group of dudes that play golf
that are not like a stereotypical golf
person and I was like oh you're GNA
freaking land because there's all kinds
of people that are that think the way
you think about Golf and they're a huge
part of that market and I know tons of
them and no one's no one's reaching them
no one's no one's talking to those
people and definitely no one's making
cool stuff for them to wear so as soon
as you were talking to me I was like oh
yeah this is going to be this is going
to be great you're going to nail it
because that those people exist and
you're making this is what I always
think is important you make something
that's for you and your friends like
you're making something that's for you I
make all kinds of stuff that's for me
and my friends like I make Jiu-Jitsu
gear why that's for me and my friends
make rash CS that's for me and my
friends make energy drinks that's for me
and my friends this is all stuff that I
use and so as as you were talking to me
I was like oh he's gonna make stuff for
him and his friends and there's a and I
know that there's a huge I mean look
golf is a freaking huge thing and I know
that it's not all people in a country
club with a Mercedes it's a bunch of
hooligans and so oh you got a whole
group of people that you're going to be
that that want to get on board with this
and not only that but people that you
know they're doing it early in the
morning they're doing it because they
got a regular job they're doing it you
know in between when they're taking care
of their kids they're practicing in
their backyard hitting into a net you
know like these are the PE there's a
whole culture of like hulie golf that's
out there I already know it and so when
you were like oh I'm going to make
clothes for them I was like oh that's
freaking awesome that's going to do
outstanding so it may be your first eort
efor in business but I think it's going
to slay because I think you're you're
nailing a group of people that are are
that think the way you do about a very
uh something that people are super
passionate about I've seen freaking Team
guys spend their all their money on golf
right new clubs new balls new freaking
te's new this new that but they're
hardcore dudes and and they work out and
they train and so you're taking that
team guy approach to golf and I think
it's G to Crush so man that that's
awesome I appreciate you saying all that
because you said it way better than I
possibly ever could have man that's it I
mean you know we're trying to trying to
bring golf to uh you know a group of
dudes out there that are Cut From a
Different Cloth and see the world maybe
a little bit different and yeah maybe a
little bit hardcore up in the mind yeah
like dude you post workout stuff and
like Early Morning Golf right you're
like dawn patrol golf preon golf is salt
like that's what you're doing that's if
I when I start playing golf when I'm 79
years old I'll be like early dawn patrol
golf I'll be in the game I'll be I'll be
hulie to the to the core Julie to the
core I know what the issue is man you're
you're scared to get hooked because it
it's in all of us I definitely don't
need any more Hobbies I can tell you
that right now no doubt um and
especially a hobby that takes four hours
like and I know you could do it faster
how fast can you play how fast can you
play nine holes do you play nine or do
you play 18 no I'm not playing nine I'm
I'm no quitter Joo come on so how long
do it take you play 18 holes it it
depends so if I'm hitting it good I
could do it in two and a half hours like
at a mild pace you jog a little bit I
might yog okay uh it it it really
depends on how I'm playing um like just
an average round even if I'm playing
like three hours uh and this is all
if I get off the first you know te first
so if there's no one in front Okay but I
played as fast I mean now uh there's
this new thing I haven't tried it yet
but I'm going to have to get back into
running shape drop a couple LVS but they
have speed Golf and these guys do it
like in an hour hour and a half and
they're like legit sprinting around um
I've done that and the fastest I've
golfed is I've I played in less than two
hours and for for a hack that's pretty
damn fast yeah you went to the freaking
caddy course in Scotland what what's
that all about how long did that take
what kind of pressure situations where
they're like yo we give me a club give
me a club what's the distance what's the
distance oh man I'm I'm glad you brought
that up um nether good great
organization worth uh talking about but
um caddy schools for for uh CAD school
for soldiers is another program that's a
program I went in this last May um great
organization and basically what they do
is they fly a group of veterans out uh
to Scotland and it was a month period
that we spent in Scotland and really the
purpose of the uh of that is to you know
guys who've been through a lot of
to uh share their experiences with each
other you know help each other uh heal
and find out what's what's next and uh
and connect with golf and then also to
you know find some employment so there's
a lot of guys who leave that program and
they they are caddies um you know
working their way up or uh going to
Resort towns and being Cades so um it
was an awesome experience I had a great
group of guys and to uh to everyone you
know running the program just say thank
you guys for having me um kind when you
when you does so
every this is soldiers what is it
soldiers what what's the name of it
caddy school for soldiers cadd they all
go to Scotland or just some yeah it's uh
I they had one class um that I think
went to Whistling
Straits um but yeah they have a couple
couple classes that go each year to
Scotland that that's it yeah damn unless
something's changed how much does it
cost to go to school if I was just like
signing
up well I mean if you're a veteran in
the program it's free no but what about
me or not what about Ekko he's not a
veteran but he's just fired up for golf
and he wants to go do you even know uh
man no clue but you talk in airfare
that's Couple Grand minimum and then you
talk about I mean we stayed they have a
uh they have a house in St Andrew so you
know since you don't know much about
golf but I do know that that's like the
that's the mecca of golf it is the Holy
Girl the that is the best way to say it
is the mecca of golf is it's Ground Zero
is it where golf started there's
probably some debate but um the course
is pardon me hundreds of years old yeah
I want to say they it's been pissing
people off for hundreds of years I want
to say yeah I I I hope I don't get this
wrong um but you'll just edit it out I
think it's from the 17th century um like
old old old so uh yeah I mean you you go
there and uh man one of the best places
I've ever visited I can't wait to go
back I don't know when that will be but
um country is just so gracious and you
know it's just amazing and and you go
around best golf courses you know
probably on the planet and they're all
stacked right next to each other there's
so many golf courses are they sitting
you down is they're like a freaking old
freaking Mickey type dude that rolls in
with like sunburned face leathered and
he's like let me tell you when you get
in the sand
trap and there's a four not offshore win
you want to go with this like is it like
that like what's it going down yeah so
in terms of golf Yoda where's he
at they have a training program and and
they go through kind of the basics and
and most of the guys that show up are
proficient golfers but not always it's
not a prerequisite in fact one guy was
uh you know great guy was out there had
just picked up golf um so they go
through some of the kind of fundamentals
but in terms of like what you're doing
as a caddy
your goal is to help your golfer have
his best day and so there's a lot that
goes into that um aside from the
Tactical stuff of you know what is the
yardage what is the LI you carry a
rangefinder yeah yeah I I actually I
went old school and Mill it out no I I
stepped it out yeah I I didn't I didn't
use a rangefinder in the program they
have uh you have a book and you have
markers on the course oh okay so you're
using markers and like okay from there
it's 20 paces and just like your you're
diving Pace count I I had a pace count
okay um but yeah really really fun and
and rewarding and uh I who knows man um
maybe in retirement I'll I'll go caddy
and uh I put in my LinkedIn profile uh
part-time caddy for hire no no one's
taking me up on that but I'm I'm willing
by bro you may be out there cading yeah
but uh you know the other part in terms
of helping someone have their best round
is managing you know emotions and
strategy out there
because having someone who can help you
make the right decisions out there when
you're not in the Heat of the Moment
because you know ego you talk about ego
a lot ego on the golf course it's not
good especially when your skill level
doesn't isn't you
know up to your levels of the ego on par
on par yeah look at that he speaks up
and he comes in with the slam dunk pun
bro he's been waiting all day he had
that written down just waiting just
waiting good to go so that that's you
learned a lot and good you you were
posting cool videos and stuff when you
were um when you were over there look
look freaking badass absolute blast and
obviously I'm not a golfer but you know
we know how that goes um and that
obviously helps you out with hulie you
understand the game better and all that
which is which is Awesome by the way you
know we mentioned Beth your wife um
she is a a program manager for the Navy
SEAL Foundation which is like just
awesome and she's been there for a while
but um I just wanted to point that out
that you know you've been out there you
know serving our country and now you
retired but she still is serving our
country and serving the teams through
what she does with the Navy SEAL
Foundation
um pretty awesome effort and a great
organization that has
helped uh obviously helped so many of
our friends and and our friends
families um what what's that like what
do you what do you look at from the
outside how hard is she busting her ass
to make that happen and is there is it
possible that anyone could be more
passionate about taking care of Team
guys than Team guys wives yeah it I mean
you said it right there it's uh the
organization is just amazing they've
done so much over the last couple
decades and continue to you know I mean
help help out the
families and and now you know with the
all the veteran issues they they got
these new programs um the warrior
fitness program just opened up in San
Diego helping helping uh veterans Team
guys you know recover from years of
abuse on their bodies and and minds and
all that um and and always you know
there for the wounded and family have to
fallen and all that so yeah man to uh
it's been really really neat to see Beth
you know pick up that service I mean she
served you know I mean while I was
running around doing stuff you know
running the family I mean that's that's
service keeping keeping the family
together keeping everything moving it's
service and then to get out you know and
have her do that and be a part of that
organization just really cool man and on
top of that it's it's really neat to
stay kind of connected through her to
the community as well yeah so kind of a
another you know blessing as well no
it's awesome and it was pretty cool we
we all went to an event and correct me
if I'm wrong but there was four it was a
Navy SEAL Foundation event in Los
Angeles and there was four guys from
task unit Bruiser there and we were all
with our wives the same wives that we
had I mean I guess Beth was your
girlfriend at the time but Jeremy was
there with his wife still married and
then one other guy who's still active
duty with his wife just still there
there's four of us there right
uh I remember the three I don't know
about there might have been one more oh
yeah yeah yeah no you're right yeah
there's four of us they're four so
pretty awesome pretty awesome to see and
we got a we got a picture of that
momentous occasion um four Team guys
that have all been married to one woman
for a long time that's pretty impressive
and uh pretty impressive what that
Foundation does and Beth thank you for
what you do um and thanks to that
foundation for what you guys do what
does this get us up to speed man I I
mean that I think that's everything
that's the most I've talked about my
life ever hopefully you'll never have to
do it again yeah no man you know thank
you for having me on um you know I said
when I started or if I didn't say I
meant to say extremely humble to be here
man I mean to think of the people that
have sat in the seat um and kind of what
you've done you know over the last
decade man it's it's amazing glad to be
here thank you so much for having me
um yeah that's all I got Echo Charles
you got any questions yeah yeah got few
question oh here we go football
questions well no come on bro not as
much that's your job wait D tackle no
and nose guard right football all right
so I started out uh D end uh freshman
year and then I moved in nose
guard yeah cuz 190 195 is not big for
noard oh no no no no I I wasn't big but
uh I was aggressive and and I was a
shoot the nose guard yeah yeah yeah
relied on the speed that's good but you
were into drawing growing up I did you
think do you think that that has a
direct correlation to you know design
cloes like that 100% man like there was
a you know it's it's interesting guys
come on your podcast and and do
interviews you learn about a lot of
things and I think there's a lot of guys
who are kind
of unless you can come up with something
better creatively inclined oh for sure
you know I mean like play guitar I grew
up playing guitar um drawing you know
you got guys that are great at
photography or this or that or whatever
and uh I think that all plays into what
we do there there's a a lot of
creativity to you know being a special
operator no doubt about it yeah for sure
what was the uh what was the original
name for the Tactical golf
bag uh we didn't have a name it I mean
the no you had a name you had a name did
I have a name did you write didn't you
just say you you said we had a name for
it and then it became I I I had it I had
a name for the brand yeah yeah the name
for the brand the uh the original the
original oh god oh man I'll say was was
Julie Bros Julie Bros jie bros
oh dude wait why is it why is that hey
we can edit this
out why is that bad just cuz it's too
bro bro look man I I was very early it
the idea hadn't matured but but hulie
hulie was in the first iteration and
then and then I played around with
hooligan so we went through like our
first kind of a class as hooligan
golf I kind of liked hooligan golf
because that's the kind of people that I
think we're talking about but then I
think there's more layers going straight
hul I think it's cleaner it's it's to on
the nose and then you've got also the
wind the Scottish the Scottish wind
blowing through so we got all kinds of
we're going deep yeah Julie comes off as
more refined which is kind of the same
element of refinement that golf kind of
seems to have overboard not overboard
it's not well the whole idea is already
not snobby it's already hardcore you see
what I'm saying but then if you take
that hardcore no matter how much you
refine it's still going to be hardcore
no matter what see what I'm saying so I
think I'm going to have to get my
father-in-law's
golfer and my dad I have to get them
some some golf shirts and see what's up
hey if if I don't play golf can I still
wear your stuff or no yeah absolutely
man I mean look it's just cool
looking yeah that's what I'm saying
like like this like yeah yeah yeah look
you see it's got like a little
camouflage activity in the C that's kind
of deal so it's kind of subtle look
we're we're starting in golf and we
hope I think the spirit of the brand is
sound I mean all the things that you
just described which I will not try to
say as eloquently it's you I mean that
that's just a spirit right you know like
we we can take that we can uh you know
whether we get into kind of like
lifestyle apparel or you know you get
into other sports or whatever um but
yeah there's tons of people tons of
hulie customers and I'll just say thank
you to you know all our customers out
there but um that aren't aren't golfers
so you know please please do Che us out
and people can find you so it's holig
golf.com that's where you can get the
stuff you can go to Instagram Twitter
and Facebook hully Golf and then you
have a YouTube channel that you're the
star of hell yeah yeah I look I haven't
been posting on YouTube that often I'm
going to get back to it um but it's it's
over the top hulie at over the top hulie
did you know that's what it was yes why
is it at over the top hulie what's the
what's the difference here well I mean
over the top is the Sylvester Stone
movie well I think for uh copyright
purposes I I can't say it but no you
know the yes over the top is a great
silver slow movie it's just a
coincidence um but over the top is also
layers talking about layers here is a
it's a problem in a golf swing so if you
have an over-the-top swing it's a it's a
swing fault so there's there's some
layers there um but yeah uh over the
over the top Julie and then uh also at
lead Bob Holland is my personal handle
kind of a new account on Instagram have
we reached out to uh the dod King you
know I'm talking about yeah oh yeah this
dude um he's because I because I follow
you now all of a sudden I get golf stuff
in my
algorithm which is you know but and you
know I'll I won't look at much of it but
I saw some kid and he and I from 757
from Virginia Beach where the dames are
and he does this whole thing he doesn't
use a te do you know what a te is I what
a t is okay I'm just making sure thank
you for asking well the thing is he
doesn't use one okay the dod means drive
off the deck okay so he's out there and
he just talks mad okay anyone that
uses a te he calls him a weasel he's
like oh weasel you cheat and all this
stuff te using weasel te using weasel so
he says oh you know oh all you weasel
out there and keyboard Warriors D he
goes off but then he
cracks these drives off the ground he
just throws the ball out there wait who
is this he's a guy it's a his handle is
actually
CVA golf I believe like like an
influencer dude or something I you know
he's the most popular golfer there
is but it's but it's it is man he will
be now he will be he should be C I think
his first name begins with c and then
it's VA because he's from Virginia he's
from Virginia Beach no less and then
what's the last part of it I think it's
just CVA golf okay but his real thing is
DoD King and he tells people he's like
cuz I'm the king he says okay and he
says I'm uh I'm 5 foot7 I got crooked
teeth and a mullet and I'm about to just
crack this down the Fairway Fairway
there we go down the Fairway and he
throws the ball out and then he just
walks up to it and just cracks it yeah
and look there's some of the keyboard
Warriors out there yeah they're saying
oh it's fake but then he'll do like a
long version and be like how fake is
this he'll throw it out there and just
hit it there's no edits oh he's he's
good man he's blowing up and he's doing
some collabs and uh yeah guys's got
skills man he's not very big but he
smash smashes it so we'll get the we we
got to get you connected with the dod
King I mean I am a t using weasel right
but he doesn't want to be one of these
people that's wearing golf shirts that
are made by weasels he wants to be
probably I would imagine he's cuz he's
also like a workingclass dude he's not a
snob he's out there he's out there
working he's got a job you know sure so
yeah I I think he's already sporing
someone else of stuff that's what it is
whenever you get a following but okay
well we'll see yeah we can collab we'll
see I don't think he's a weasel I think
he's a good American he's from Virginia
Beach I think he's probably going to be
really interested in representing hulie
which is more legit than whatever
he's rolling right now no
offense to DOD King and look I'm not a
golfer but he looks like he cracks it
pretty good to me for someone who's not
a golfer you seem to know a lot about it
dude once you got he got in my
algorithm got in your got in my
algorithm so I'm props props to that guy
um so that's where people can find you
YouTube over the top hulie Twitter
Facebook Instagram hully Golf and then
hully golf.com if you want to just go
there and get a badass shirt you could
wear that shirt to a meeting you could
wear it to dinner and yes you could wear
it playing golf and you got a bunch of
cool designs that you're to the designer
of now because we apparently you're the
design guy well I'm I'm not the only
designer to give credit to our great
designer so check cheuck uh Echo did you
have any more questions that is it good
to see you yeah thanks man Bobby any
other closing thoughts man no good
times man thank you wrapped it up um
well thank you thank you for coming down
uh it's freaking legit and that guys are
now retiring I look I hate the fact that
you all have to retire but they you
retire and you can come down here and
kind of share your story um it's awesome
I appreciate it thanks for what you did
for the country thanks for what you did
for the Navy for the teams thanks for
what you did for tasking a Bruiser
thanks for the lessons that you passed
On to the Next Generation that are out
there using your lessons for their
platoon right now um thanks for what you
did and you never faltered you never
wavered you stepped up you led and you
set an example an outstanding example
and you passed on the highest standards
of the Frog men so thanks bro thanks
brother appreciate
it and with that and this actually means
a lot in this particular case yeah Bobby
Holland has left the building because
you know that that came from Elvis lead
Bob yeah Elvis has left the building
yeah that's where it comes from oh yeah
yeah the layers and so today there's a
lot of meaning when I say that Bobby
Holland lead Bob has left the building
he's we talked about a little bit he's
he's a fan of Elvis yeah so Bobby
Holland has left the building awesome to
have him on and see what he's doing here
bringing back a lot of
memories um very cool so thanks thanks
thanks to lead Bob it is always
interesting to hear you even same thing
with GIF MH like especially when there's
other players and the whole history the
story you know Le and like you know all
um Tyler I know Tyler I actually I have
a whole separate history with Tyler by
the way I don't know if you guys knew
this but um so I've known Tyler well you
knew him from hanging out when you were
Jeremy K yeah coming Yeah a different
Jeremy by the way than the Jeremy that
we talked about today yeah
the Jeremy that we talked about today is
a different Jeremy different Jeremy than
yeah exactly than the Jeremy that you're
talking about there's like let's say
there's a Hawaiian Jeremy Y and then
there's a different Jeremy a not ho JY
yeah so yeah so it always is interesting
to hear like another essentially another
perspective of a timeline that I'm very
familiar with with characters that I'm
very familiar with very it's kind of
like um when they do a like a a prequel
or a sequel pre yeah but it's more like
a prequel right pre because a sequel you
kind of you're carrying on but prequel
you're kind of learning more about what
you know about already so there's
something a little cooler about it yep
exactly I guess the only hulie is a
sequel right yeah that's like oh there's
more coming more come yep exactly hulie
business golf there's a movie called go
the name of the movie is go and it's a
it's a we should make a henery drink
called Go oh we did cool okay what's it
about uh it's a you know like a little
thing thing that they all this group of
people get into these kids whatever uh
like you know young 20s whatever they go
to Vegas and all this stuff this this
trouble they get into and they all have
their and they split up and they get
back together they split up or whatever
with their different um over time over
one weekend it's like a night or so got
it you know and but it's so it's like
three movie you know kind three stories
in one movie so and each one is from a
different person's perspective so it's
the exact same story but it's from this
guy's perspective and this girl's
perspective it's like that that's what
it felt like
so you saw a different perspective today
another perspective you know a lot a lot
of overlap which makes it so interesting
and that's what made the movie so
interesting because when when the
overlap you're like oh that's what was
going on at that time you see what I'm
saying same deal yeah and it's good to
be able to capture that stuff I mean and
even Bob was telling me you know he was
going through like just thinking about
stuff and he said on the podcast he's
been doing some thinking about
everything and you start to remember
little things and like even the story he
was telling about being in Mount and
like like repelling off the roof and
like
I'm going to think about it more I can't
really remember it right now and and so
it's nice to be able to capture like at
some point you forget stuff that
happened the more stuff that happens in
your life the more stuff you forget
about the further away you get from it
you know Le sending me those emails and
Bob would saying after man he's like
that email account doesn't exist anymore
so Bob doesn't even have access to those
emails that LEF sent me so man to have
and those emails those old emails are
really interesting to look at because
they're a they're a u a stamp of time
it's like a historical and it's you you
wrote it like you wrote it yeah and
that's you at that time and you you can
get older and you can learn more and you
can become more wise and you can become
more jaded but at that time this is a
pretty good representation of who you
were and how you felt at a certain time
yep so going on pretty cool to be able
to have those documents and be able to
go through them and get back those
memories even even after we got done
recording he was like he he said when I
started reading um he was kind of like
wait oh he you know was like coming back
to him the memory of it came back to him
yeah so it's very cool to be able to
reopen those things and remember details
that you might not otherwise remember
and don't think about and all that stuff
so thanks for coming on Bob appreciate
it lead Bob lead Bob still on the path
after all these years speaking of the
path de resets coming yep de reset is
starting J listen technically speaking
starts January 1st reality starts right
now like if you you got to be ready for
de reset you can't just show up it's
like going to buds you just don't roll
into buds oh first phase day what do
they call it one one day like first week
first day yeah they call one one day if
you roll into one one day and you
haven't done some they give you even the
even they the milit the Navy gives you
six weeks prior to one one day MH so one
one day is coming January 1st you got to
be ready you got the prep phase going on
right now we got the warning order so
we're going to get our lives physical
mental professional family leadership
we're going to get them all squared away
starting January 1 there's prep work
that's happening now don't go into it
cold you won't make it so go to the
defret
we got workouts and fitness with Jason
kipa we got leadership with aalon front
we got discipline directives coming from
me we got Joo fuel we got there's like
benefits benefits you call them hell
yeah we're going to give away like
tickets to the muster we're going to
weigh bunch of jonco fuel stuff so
defres set.com come and check it out
let's get on the path be prepared
January 1 is coming it's December 1st
right now when we're recording this I
don't know when it's coming out but
time is ticking be ready de reset go to
thee reset.com speaking of joof fuel
joof
fuel.com I am currently at this time two
goes deep yep I'm one and I'm feeling
very fired up now look am I fired up
because lead Bob was here sure little
bit kind of yeah kind am I also fired up
because I had a few go two go yes I am
uh so do I have downside am I going to
crash no I'm not going to crash am I
going to get type two diabetes no I'm
not am am I going to get some other
weird uh gut problems because I have
artificial sweeteners no none of that's
going to happen so my downside is
nothing my upside is
everything go to joof fuel.com get
yourself some go you can also go to Wawa
vitamin shop GNC military commissaries
AES Haner Dash stores and Maryland wake
Fern shopright HB HB down they're in
Taos Meyer up in the midwest Harris teer
Lifetime Fitness Shields small gyms
every and listen if you own a small
school Jiu-Jitsu school CrossFit School
powerlifting School Olympic lifting
school maybe it's just a straight globo
gym but you want to sell joof fuel email
JF sales joof fuel.com Chaz he'll get in
touch with you have you met Chaz yet oh
old school old school old school in the
game yeah just getting after it so
that's what we're doing MLK protein cuz
sometimes you look let's face it
sometimes you need 30 grams of protein
like right now RTD just crack One open
you're good 30 gr of protein you're good
I figured something out what's that
about the the M banana RTD little side
side notes please share so do share so
you know like me me like many people I'm
no you
know banana is not the number one flavor
usually it's going to be chocolate
usually this is just in world in the
world just in general yeah you know a
banana flavor it's kind of like you know
it takes a special you know like it's
very rare that that's the number one
flavor some people like I dig it for an
individual human being yes to prefer
banana as their number one favorite
flavor in general correct right and I'm
one of those people or I like the
chocolate I like the whatever so the
Banana's like fine but but for whatever
reason freaking the banana MK RTD is my
number one favorite one I don't know why
okay till now so I used to make these
homemade milkshakes back in the day when
I was
teenager H yeah and then the formula was
freaking good like really good so here's
the recipe it's
sugar
milk
vanilla one egg one raw egg mhm and one
banana hell
yeah bro bro I'm telling you you get the
ingredients the proportions perfect bro
it tastes freaking super good uhhuh
especially if the banana is a ripe
banana you can't get the under rpe
banana the pre- rpe banana don't do that
ripe banana what was tulsi's deal with
ban Bas oh yeah the Frozen one Frozen
yeah yeah to make it more creamy
whatever but nonetheless that was the
formula for my homemade milkshake it was
freaking was really good since you blend
it up really good the egg makes it like
thicker and Stu it's really good oh yeah
ice too that's what the M artd banana
tastes like bro it tastes exactly like
it GTG GTG big time and if you put in
the fridge for a long time or the
freezer for a short time it'll be extra
cold which adds another layer of like um
what do you call appeal to The Taste
bro I'm telling you I'm telling you oh
there you go all kinds of good stuff
joint Warfare super Crill vitamin D Cold
War that's that's what we're doing
hydrate hydrate yeah you're gonna need
to hydrate you get done with
that even before the yeah and then
here's a key component to your daily
life greens and creatine if you're not
doing greens and creatine in the morning
you should be there's no one that
shouldn't be doing that not one person
yeah everyone should be doing greens and
creatine like brushing your teeth brush
your teeth greens and creatine actually
don't do it right away because you get
that weird what's that thing what is
that you don't want to do that you brush
your teeth you can't drink you can't eat
anything for how long half an hour yeah
half hour 45 minutes 45 minutes 45
minutes then maybe get done with your
workout by the time you're done with
your workout 100% you're cleared hot
yeah for greens and creatine or you can
follow my protocol if you don't know
already I said it before right when you
wake up no problem uh GRE I don't care
the greens I don't put in in but I put
just put creatine hydrate pre-brush
pre-brush 100% pre-brush creatine and
and the hydrate you brush your teeth bro
right after that what you go down to the
kitchen and you're like functioning
doing stuff bro it's staged right on my
nightstand okay a whole thing of hydrate
water's already there hawaian from last
night you see what I'm saying hydrate
creatine right there here's what's bad
anyone that goes in my room and they
know what cocaine looks like you know
how the creatine you put in you spill a
little bit it looks it looks bad but hey
man if you can end that but that's a
perfect staging uh sequence see what I'm
saying yes pre-brush boom done before I
even get
up I'm already in you see what
I'm saying with the creatine dude I'm
going to give that the triple stamp of
approval dig it dig it hydrate and I had
the vision of you walking around your
house with morning breath for like an
hour your wife comes down Sarah Charles
is like yo get back away from go back up
back away get out the get out the lisine
homes so that's what we're doing f.com
go check it out origin usa.com we're
doing Jiu-Jitsu we're lifting we're
hunting are we playing golf some people
are yeah kind of I mean shoot you hear
freaking lead Bob talk about it you're
kind of like I don't know it might be a
little bit more to it I've never you've
never played have you ever played a
round of golf on the golf course I have
played like literally one round of golf
on the golf course on the golf course
where where else were I play round of
golf I know you know how they say mini
I've played mini golf it's not the same
I've played more mini golf yeah yeah I
played mini golf I've never played one
single round I was playing mini golf I
was playing mini golf my son he was
probably like six and he straight up
like full driver with the putter like
full driver shot that thing like Tiger
Woods bro it was like such a hazard it
was if if it would have hit somebody
like another kid it would have been
major major injury concussion possible
like Temple shot death I don't know but
I believe uh origin usa.com that's what
we're doing get awesome clothes there
and they're all made in America look we
in this country have fought for freedom
and right now we're selling that freedom
selling it you go and buy something from
China you're you're you're you're
selling it you're you're giving it
away all this Freedom that we fought for
being sold don't let it happen bu
American buy American made we go through
the most extreme lengths to produce and
manufacture things in the United States
of America at origin usa.com everything
that you need workout
clothes hunt clothes jeans you need a
pair of jeans you probably need two
pairs of jeans we got you get
americanmade jeans support the American
worker support the American economy
support American Security because if we
can't produce things in this country we
don't have a country
origin usa.com go get some it's true
also Joo store G to represent on the
whether you're on De reset or not you
just on the path in general or even if
you're taking a break from the path
doesn't matter you can still represent
look I'm not recommending it I'm not
over here recommending getting off the
path if you're taking a break from the
path yeah by the time the order shows up
you should definitely be back on the
path from an ideal standpoint I think
you're right but on reality boots on the
ground hey we live in a world where some
people aren't on the path 100% of the
time what I'm saying is it doesn't
matter
necessarily it's hard to put on a
discipline equals Freedom
T-shirt and not be on the path that's
true it's hard to put on a de core
t-shirt a t-shirt that literally says
death core on it discipline equals
freedom to the core to the core and
you're like yeah I'm going to where's
that donut at yes it's very hard you're
correct so but we live in an imperfect
World in human beings which we all are I
can see what kind of mood you're in
today did you violate something did you
do we have problems did you train today
I'm a very understanding I did not train
today I'm a very understanding person
you see what I'm saying that's all I'm
saying that's really the end all Beall
point that I'm trying to make look but
you can still represent when you do you
want a new shirt that you want to
represent with you go to Joost store.com
that's where you get it discipline
equals Freedom regardless if you're
resting or not it still does equal
Freedom you I'm
saying good you think things are going
to go freaking perfect the way you want
them to go right now all the time every
single day they don't no not going to
happen it's okay it's okay everything's
going to be all right anyway you want to
represent Jole store.com if you want to
get on the short Locker subscription
what that is is a new design every
single month it's good people like them
check them out see if you like them if
you like them boom subscription that's
where you can get that as well hey
speaking of America Americans look do we
need milk yes we do do we get 30 grams
of
milk 30 gram of protein of milk yes do
we get 14 grams of protein from a MK
cookie we do yeah guess what else
sometimes you need supplemental protein
actually your primary source of protein
primary yeah let's go steak yes sir
let's go American Steak let's
go let's go Primal beef.com and let's go
colorcraft beef.com two American
companies bringing you steak that tastes
like it's just it's just next level it's
next level on that grass-fed fruit
finish but I had the um I got the
burgers right last night or last night I
was making the burgers so here's a good
tactic too just it's a side tip look
does it
me is this essential to do no but it's a
side tip might help you out so what I do
is I grab the burger grab three of them
right you know they come in the stacks
right get them to room temperature i
ball them up into one big ball and I
make make them into a bunch of Sliders
for the
kids grass-fed fruit finish that's where
you're at that's what I did last night
yes check it out we got you Colorado
craft beef.com and Primal beef.com go
check those out subscribe to the podcast
check out Joo underground check out our
YouTube channel check out psychological
warfare check out Flipside canvas.com
Dakota Myers selling you cool stuff to
hang on your wall keep you on the path
also bunch of books I've written a bunch
of books you know what they are and look
they will help you they will help you
read them read them and then look you
got kids in your life get them the way
the warrior books 1 2 3 4 and five these
are the books when you get them and you
see kids read them you see their lives
change so that's what we're doing check
them out Mike and the dragons about face
extreme ownership dichotomy leadership
it's all there Eon front you heard about
Le Babin
today he and I have a leadership
consultancy it's called ashon front go
to Echelon front.com we can help your
organization we can help you with every
problem that you have because all the
problems that you have are leadership
problems and we solve problems through
leadership we got Live Events we can
come into your into your organization
and work with you on a long-term basis
we will figure out a plan to get you and
your team aligned so Echelon front.com
we also have an online Training Academy
if you want
to train look for leadership but it's
training for life because when you
interact with other human beings which
you do all day long every day unless
you're
hermit you got to interact with other
people that's
leadership so you got to lead yourself
you got to lead other people you got to
interact with other people go to extrem
ownership. comom and learn these
skills also if you want to help service
members active and retired you want to
help their families gold star families
check out Mark Le's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate or get involved go to
America's Mighty warriors.org also
heroes and horses. org also Jimmy May's
organization beyond the brotherhood. org
and finally the Navy SEAL Foundation
which is where Bobby's wife works she's
been there for a while but there's a
bunch of great human beings these are
the people this is the organization that
takes care of
seals families and the seals but when
someone gets killed or wounded their
support is unbelievably strong so check
them out as well Navy SEAL Foundation if
you want to connect with Bob he's on the
interwebs hully
golf.com he's on Instagram Twitter
Facebook hulie golf he's on YouTube with
overthe toop hulie and Ekko is at Echo
Charles I am at Joo willink and again
just be careful because the algorithm
you'll look at one golf thing and the
next thing you know you'll have a bunch
of golf stuff inside your algorithm
showing you the dod King so just be
careful for whoever else you know if you
look at a one dog one knife you'll have
a thing full of knives it's true you if
you talk about something it'll pick it
up put it in there it's wild you got to
turn off your microphone setting on your
phone okay that's true sounds like a
good plan so just be careful we're there
but there's algorithms on the hunt once
again thanks lead Bob Bobby Holland for
joining us today check out jul lef.com
most important thanks to Bob for his
service leadership and the teams and for
our great nation and thanks to Beth as
well for everything you do for all of us
and thanks to all the Personnel out
there in uniform right now that are
serving and protecting us around the
world your sacrifice is appreciated and
will not be forgotten and the same goes
to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers Board of Patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
thank you for serving and protecting us
here at home we are
grateful and everyone else out there
you got a good example from lead Bob
Bobby
Holland Step Up work hard have F have
fun have fun man put some Elvis in your
life take care of your
friends take care of your family run
things raise the
bar stay humble and of
course keep getting after it and until
next time this is Ekko and Joo
out